This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of The Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliott Kalin. So today we're still in part 6, The Lust for Power. We're covering four chapters, 35-38, that's pages 807-894. And later in this episode our special guest is Majora Carter. Majora is a neighborhood developer from the South Bronx. Growing up, she always viewed her neighborhood as a place where she had to leave to find success, but as she got older, she became more involved. She began undoing some of Moses's legacy, and she became a champion
这是《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·卡林。今天我们继续探讨第六部分“权力的欲望”。我们将涵盖第35至38章，即第807至894页。本期节目的特邀嘉宾是马乔拉·卡特。马乔拉是来自南布朗克斯的社区开发商。在成长过程中，她一直认为自己的社区是一个必须离开才能获得成功的地方，但随着年龄增长，她参与得越来越多。她开始扭转摩西的一些遗产，并成为了一名捍卫者，
for bettering neighborhoods like the South Bronx so that they are places where people want to remain, even when they have been ruined by a tyrant. Before we get started with one of my favorite chapters in one of my favorite books, so it's going to be great, we did want to talk about something that we teased last month, our very special live event with Robert Caro. Roman, me, Robert Caro on stage, reunited for the first time at the New York Historical Society. I'm so excited about it. It's going to be great. But Historical Society. I'm so excited about it. It's going to be great. But when the tickets went on sale, they sold out almost immediately, which made us very proud, but we know was disappointing for a lot of you who did not get a chance to buy tickets. We're really sorry about that. If we
致力于改善像南布朗克斯这样的社区，使它们成为人们愿意留下的地方，即使这些地方曾被暴君摧毁。在我们开始阅读我最喜欢的书中最喜欢的章节之一（这一定会很棒）之前，我们想谈谈上个月预告过的事情，那就是我们与罗伯特·卡罗的特别现场活动。罗曼、我，还有罗伯特·卡罗同台，这是我们在纽约历史学会的首次重聚。我对此感到非常兴奋。这一定会很棒。但是当门票开始发售时，几乎立刻就售罄了，这让我们感到非常自豪，但我们也知道，对于许多没能买到票的听众来说，这很令人失望。我们对此深表歉意。如果我们
could have held the event at a stadium large enough to hold you all, we would have done it. But you are not totally out of luck. You can still watch the event on your computer. Livestream tickets are still available. You can go to nyhistory.org slash programs to learn more. So on the last episode of the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker, we covered chapters 33 and 34, which detailed the ways in which Robert Moses spent the 1940s and 50s becoming the center of political corruption and honest grafts in New York City construction world and his lust for power that transformed them into this kind of political machine boss that he used to despise when he was a young reformer.
能在一个足够大的体育场举办这场活动来容纳你们所有人，我们一定会这么做。但你们也不必完全灰心。你们仍然可以在电脑上观看这场活动。直播门票仍然有售。你可以访问 nyhistory.org/programs 了解更多信息。在上期《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的解析中，我们讨论了第33和34章，详细介绍了罗伯特·摩西如何在40和50年代成为纽约市建筑界政治腐败和合法贪腐的中心，以及他那将自己转变为他年轻时曾鄙视的那种政治机器老板的权力欲望。
And then Caro does this delightful chapter on the three mayors that followed LaGuardia, which did not warrant their own chapters. It's hard to imagine a version of the book where Mayor M.B. gets a full chapter to himself, as much as I love that section so much. So it's just a series of mayors that he dominated during this period of time. And on this episode, we'll be continuing our jaunt through part six, The Lust for Power, by looking at chapters 35 through 38 in the print edition, that's pages 807 to 894. And chapter 35 is titled RM. And that doesn't stand for Roman Mars, unfortunately,
随后，卡罗写了这令人愉悦的一章，讲述了拉瓜迪亚之后的三位市长，他们甚至不配拥有自己的独立章节。很难想象这本书里市长M.B.能拥有完整的一章，尽管我非常喜欢那部分。所以这只是一系列他在这一时期所支配的市长。在本期节目中，我们将继续漫游第六部分“权力的欲望”，阅读印刷版第35至38章，即第807至894页。第35章标题为“RM”。不幸的是，这并不代表罗曼·马尔斯，
because that would be a fantastic chapter. When you first turned the page, did you think for a second, oh, I'm in this book. Oh yeah, I signed off on something. No, RM stands for Robert Moses. And more importantly, RM is what the Moses men called Robert Moses through a lot of his life. So let's talk about this chapter
因为那会是非常精彩的一章。当你第一次翻开这一页时，有没有想过，哦，我在这本书里？哦，对了，我签了什么东西。不，RM代表罗伯特·摩西。更重要的是，RM是摩西的手下在他一生中大部分时间里对他的称呼。所以让我们来谈谈这一章，
because it's kind of a fun chapter in certain ways. I know this is one of your favorites, Elliot. So what do you like about it? So this chapter, it is very fun and the rest of the episode is going to be less fun because it's, I love this chapter, partly for what it does on its own and partly how it works in counterpoint with the, with
因为它在某些方面非常有趣。我知道这是你最喜欢的章节之一，埃利奥特。你喜欢它什么？这一章确实非常有趣，而本期节目的其余部分会没那么有趣，因为我喜欢这一章，部分是因为它本身的内容，部分是因为它与紧随其后的章节形成了对比，
the chapters that come right after it. Because this chapter is entirely about Robert Moses' imperial control of the world of the Triborough and park system. But there's a lot of also like, I just, I'm just gonna say like public power wealth porn, where Caro is taking you through the experience of being a guest at a Robert Moses event
因为这一章完全是关于罗伯特·摩西对三区大桥和公园系统的帝国式控制。但其中也有很多，我只想说，就像是公共权力的财富色情，卡罗带你体验作为罗伯特·摩西活动嘉宾的感受，
and kind of the resources he has and the ways he uses them and just for entertaining people who he can use in some way. And I just love the feeling of ridiculous opulence, like ludicrous opulence that Caro presents this chapter. It feels like satirical. This chapter feels satirical to me. It's kind of to the point that it feels kind of silly. But then the chapters after it are so are so much more somber and so much more hard hitting that I love the trick that Caro pulls here where you're like, I'm having fun. Robert Moses, you know what?
以及他拥有的资源，他使用这些资源的方式，以及仅仅是为了娱乐那些他可以利用的人。我非常喜欢卡罗在这一章中呈现的那种荒谬的奢华感。这感觉像是讽刺。这一章对我来说感觉是讽刺性的。甚至到了感觉有点愚蠢的地步。但随后的章节却如此沉重，如此震撼，以至于我喜欢卡罗在这里使用的技巧，让你觉得，我玩得很开心。罗伯特·摩西，你知道吗？
He could have me over to his personal open air arena anytime and then the next chapters are, and here's what that power was doing. It wasn't just bringing people to parties where there are martini fountains, as we'll see, as we get into the chapter, but it's fun while it lasts. Yeah, and it's one of the things about the book, when a book is this long, getting a bird's eye view
他随时都可以邀请我去他的私人露天竞技场，但接下来的章节却是，这就是那种权力所做的事情。正如我们进入这一章时所看到的，这不仅仅是把人们带到有马提尼喷泉的派对上，但在它持续的时候，这确实很有趣。是的，这是这本书的特点之一，当一本书这么长时，从鸟瞰的角度来看，
of what these two chapters juxtaposed against each other, you do get kind of lost sometimes because you're spending 30, 40, 50 pages on one thing and it's kind of hard to know, oh yeah, they're setting up all this sort of excess and opulence and how he's getting things done. And then the, I mean there's dark sides, like even that part is dark in its way. I mean even this part, he doesn't come off as a great guy. It's not like he's like,
这两章并置在一起，你有时会感到迷失，因为你在一个问题上花了30、40、50页，很难知道，哦，对了，他们正在铺垫所有这些过剩和奢华，以及他是如何完成事情的。而且，我的意思是，这里有黑暗面，即使是那部分在某种程度上也是黑暗的。我的意思是，即使是这部分，他看起来也不是个好人。并不是说他是个，
yeah he'd be fun to hang out with. But and also the juxtaposition of the money at his command to do things. Just in the next chapters, people who are in the lower, lower middle, lower classes, and how they barely have the money they need to pay for their rent. Just the juxtaposition between the two is very stark. Well, because we got out of the timeline a little bit, because we went through those three mayors, let's just sort of get our bearings here.
是的，和他在一起会很有趣。而且他所掌握的资金与他要做的事情并置。就在接下来的章节中，那些处于底层、中下层、下层阶级的人，他们几乎没有钱支付房租。两者之间的并置非常鲜明。好吧，因为我们稍微偏离了时间线，因为我们经历了那三位市长，让我们在这里理清一下思路。
So this chapter starts when Moses is 60 years old. It's 1948 He's kind of at the height of his power and um, let's sort of describe where he is at this point So robber mose at this point he has Something like nine or ten public official posts He has all this money flowing in from the bridges that he and the and the tunnels now also I think he still has the tunnel authority that he controls the tolls that are coming in from those so as you may remember from last time this is when he has built this kind of personal corruption machine and it's starting to get really into motion at the late 40s this is when it's really ramping up uh and he is can do basically what he
这一章开始时，摩西60岁。那是1948年。他正处于权力的巅峰，嗯，让我们描述一下他此时的状态。罗伯特·摩西此时拥有大约九或十个公职。他从他控制的桥梁和隧道中获得了源源不断的资金，我想他仍然控制着隧道管理局，控制着从那里收取的通行费。所以正如你可能从上次节目中记得的那样，这是他建立这种个人腐败机器的时候，它在40年代末开始真正运转起来，这是它真正加速的时候，嗯，他基本上可以做他
needs to the government is the federal government's pouring tons of money into cities. The city government does not have the money to pay for its own things. And now Robert Moses has access to all that. And he doesn't just have access to money. Carath talks at the beginning of this chapter, he describes him as having this incredible access to the ability to do work.
需要做的事。政府，联邦政府正在向城市投入大量资金。市政府没有钱支付自己的项目。现在罗伯特·摩西可以动用所有这些资金。而且他不仅仅能动用资金。卡罗在这一章开头谈到，他描述他拥有这种令人难以置信的执行工作的能力。
He has a voracious appetite for power and a voracious appetite for work. He has no hobbies except for swimming, which he does at night often. Like he otherwise, his entire life is work. Cara tells the story about there was a play, a Broadway musical called Fiorello that was about Fiorello LaGuardia. And Moses went to go see it because he had known LaGuardia.
他有着对权力的贪婪胃口和对工作的贪婪胃口。他除了游泳之外没有任何爱好，他经常在晚上游泳。除此之外，他的整个生活就是工作。卡罗讲了一个故事，有一部百老汇音乐剧叫《菲奥雷洛》，是关于菲奥雷洛·拉瓜迪亚的。摩西去看了，因为他认识拉瓜迪亚。
And this is in 1960. And he goes, oh yeah, that's the first Broadway show I've been to in years. Like he has no, he doesn't do anything for recreation. And he's still relying on his wife, Mary to do like, she arranges his haircuts. She arranges his clothes. She makes sure that the stuff in his pockets that he needs is the right stuff. And it's, he's just focused on work all the time. If he goes on vacation, then part of that vacation is spending time with people
那是1960年。他说，哦，那是多年来我看的第一场百老汇演出。他没有任何娱乐活动。他仍然依赖他的妻子玛丽来处理琐事，她安排他的理发。她安排他的衣服。她确保他口袋里的东西是他需要的正确东西。他只是时刻专注于工作。如果他去度假，那么度假的一部分就是花时间与那些
that he needs to lobby for support for his projects. Like he's, Caro refers to it on page 808 as a feast of work. And I love that phrase because it gets across that, he's not burdened by all this work. Like he loves it. Like he wants it. He wants to be doing this. And 10 years later at 1958, Caro is saying that Moses at 70,
他需要游说以支持他项目的人在一起。就像他在第808页所说的，这是一场“工作的盛宴”。我喜欢这个短语，因为它传达出，他并没有被所有这些工作所累。他热爱它。他想要它。他想要做这些事。10年后的1958年，卡罗说70岁的摩西，
he's still sitting at that feast. Like he can't get enough of it. He loves, he just loves working. He wants to do nothing else but work, which gives him a real leg up on most human beings who like to stop working every now and then. That's right. And he goes through all these sort of things
他仍然坐在那场盛宴中。他似乎永远不够。他热爱，他只是热爱工作。他除了工作什么都不想做，这让他比大多数喜欢时不时停止工作的人更有优势。没错。他经历了所有这些事情，
where he's working all the time, the secretaries work all the time. He turns his car into a working office. And I love this detail that he purposely doesn't put a phone in so that he can do more work in the car. It doesn't want to be interrupted. Yeah. If he can get away from a place that where people
他一直在工作，秘书们也一直在工作。他把他的车变成了一个移动办公室。我喜欢这个细节，他故意不在车里装电话，这样他就能在车里做更多的工作。他不想被打扰。是的。如果他能远离那些
can't reach him, it's not like, oh, I've made it to myself. It's like, good, I can get this work done, finally. It makes a point of saying that the car is a limousine where the windows don't go all the way to the back. So he doesn't look out the window when he's being driven around so he can just work. It's really something else. It's amazing.
人们找不到他的地方，那并不是说，哦，我终于有时间留给自己了。而是说，太好了，我终于可以完成这项工作了。他特意提到那辆车是一辆豪华轿车，窗户不能完全降到后面。所以当他被开车到处走时，他不会往窗外看，这样他就可以专心工作。这真是太特别了。太神奇了。
Caro's like, 1955, he has an eye operation. The next day he's sitting in the hospital dictating letters and memos to secretaries. Another time he's got a 104 degree fever. He's in bed, but he's still taking meetings in bed. Like he's still doing work. And he's presenting this portrait of Moses who is so full of energy.
卡罗说，1955年，他做了一次眼部手术。第二天他就坐在医院里给秘书口述信件和备忘录。还有一次他发着104度的高烧。他躺在床上，但仍然在床上开会。他还在工作。他呈现了一个摩西的肖像，他精力充沛。
He's always pacing, he's always impatient. And the image presenting this portrait of Moses who is so full of energy. He's always pacing, he's always impatient. And the image you get of him, which is kind of, no, it would be tragic if he wasn't ruining so many people's lives or sad in that way, is someone who is very aware that the things he wants to accomplish are more than a reasonable life can contain. And so he's pushing himself and he's pushing the people around him so fast and so hard so he can get even a fraction of the things that his dreams into reality. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he's still swimming at night.
他总是踱步，总是急躁。你得到的关于他的形象，如果他没有毁掉那么多人的生活，这会是悲剧性的，或者以那种方式令人悲伤，他是一个非常清楚自己想要完成的事情超出了合理寿命所能容纳的人。所以他逼迫自己，逼迫周围的人，如此迅速、如此努力，以便能将他梦想中的哪怕一小部分变为现实。是的，是的，是的。而且他还在晚上游泳。
His aides start swimming with him because they're worried about him going out into the ocean by himself, but he outpaces all of the swimmers. I mean, it's pretty funny how much Caro kind of talks up all of his like physical prowess and his ability. I mean, we're getting into Paul Bunyan territory at a certain point, where it's like, they swam with him and they couldn't keep up,
他的助手开始和他一起游泳，因为他们担心他独自一人去海里，但他超过了所有的游泳者。我的意思是，卡罗谈论他所有的身体素质和能力，这很有趣。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我们进入了保罗·邦扬的领域，就像是，他们和他一起游泳，却跟不上他，
even when he was in his 60s, what an amazing swimmer. It's like New York tall tales, and it's really amazing. But also, so here's something that speaks to me particularly. At the same time, Moses is doing all this work, he's also doing a lot of writing. Like he needs money because the jobs don't pay him that much and he lives a lavish lifestyle. So he's writing articles for pay.
即使在他60多岁的时候，他也是多么出色的游泳者。这就像纽约的民间传说，真的很神奇。但还有一点，这对我来说特别有感触。在摩西做所有这些工作的同时，他也在进行大量的写作。他需要钱，因为这些工作给他的报酬并不多，而且他过着奢华的生活方式。所以他写文章赚钱。
He writes dozens of articles for magazines and he takes the time. Apparently he always wanted to write kind of trash novels. And so he writes a pulp romance novel called From Palms to Pines that is rejected by all publishers. I'm sure it's terrible. And someone who's, I think if I remember correctly, Carol's like, someone read it and was like,
他为杂志写了几十篇文章，而且他花时间去写。显然他一直想写那种垃圾小说。所以他写了一本名为《从棕榈到松树》的通俗浪漫小说，被所有出版商拒绝了。我敢肯定那很糟糕。如果我没记错的话，卡罗说，有人读了它，觉得，
there's more sex in it than I thought there would be. But that Carol makes it clear that even if it's a bad novel, Moses wrote an entire novel while he's also holding down eight full-time executive jobs and all these other side things that he, like, it's, it's amazing. It's, it's, you know, where's he finding the time to do it? Well, I mean, he's finding the time to do it
里面的性描写比我想象的要多。但卡罗明确表示，即使这是一本糟糕的小说，摩西在同时担任八份全职行政工作和所有其他副业的同时，写了一整本小说，这真是太神奇了，你知道，他在哪里找到时间做这些事的？好吧，我的意思是，他找到时间做这些事
because he can yell at people and, and, and tell them not to call him and work. He has his own private car and everything, but he has a, he has his, it's just amazing that the amount of work he's capable of doing. And I, but I think it's very funny. There's this alternate universe where Robert Moses sold that novel and he was like but I think it's very funny. There's this alternate universe where Robert Moses sold that novel.
是因为他可以对人大吼大叫，告诉他们不要给他打电话，然后工作。他有自己的私人汽车等等，但他有他的，他能完成的工作量真是太惊人了。而且，我觉得这很有趣。有一个平行宇宙，罗伯特·摩西卖掉了那本小说，他就像，但我认为这很有趣。有一个平行宇宙，罗伯特·摩西卖掉了那本小说。
And he was like, I'm done with city building. Like now I'm just, I'm like Harold Robbins. Like I just write kind of trashy novels. That's what I do. Yeah. But, but the funny thing is about all this money that he needs is that when Carol sort of like lays out all of his privileges and the access to things that he has at his disposal
他说，我不干城市建设了。现在我就像哈罗德·罗宾斯。我只是写那种垃圾小说。这就是我做的。是的。但关于他需要的所有这些钱，有趣的是，当卡罗列出他所有的特权和他可以支配的资源时，
it's kind of surprising he needs money at all because he has, um, he has these like restaurants that are just like staffed and ready for him to go to and, uh, get fed. He has access to a yacht at all times. He has three drivers, which is like three drivers in eight hour shifts. So they can always be ready at any time. Uh, he has the yacht and the captains just sit there by the phone every day, just in case he wants to go out on it.
他竟然还需要钱，这令人惊讶，因为他有，嗯，他有这些餐厅，随时都有人手准备好让他去，嗯，去吃饭。他随时可以使用游艇。他有三名司机，就像三名司机轮班八小时。所以他们随时准备着。嗯，他有游艇，船长们每天就坐在电话旁，以防他想出去。
Then the restaurants, so these are amazing. So at three different offices, he has full dining rooms with cooking and serving staffs. And again, they're just there. They're just on call every day in case he decides he wants to host a lunch in that office. And as Carol keeps saying, this is the kind of thing that King has, you know, King has these kinds of people waiting on him all the time.
然后是餐厅，这些太棒了。在三个不同的办公室，他都有配备烹饪和服务人员的完整餐厅。同样，他们每天都在待命，以防他决定在那个办公室举办午餐会。正如卡罗一直说的，这是国王才有的待遇，你知道，国王一直有这些人伺候他。
And, uh, there's a couple in this section. I'd love to read just a few of these short sections, because I love the way Carol just kind of, it's almost like breathless. It feels like the way he writes some of these descriptions as if like, can you believe this? Like, this is amazing, but also this is ridiculous. Can you believe this stuff? And so he says, he talks about bringing you into the experience of being with Robert Moses and being entertained this way. And I have to assume it is because he probably experienced a fair amount of this.
在这一节里有几段。我很想读几段这些短小的部分，因为我喜欢卡罗那种几乎是气喘吁吁的写作方式。感觉就像他写这些描述时，好像在说，你能相信吗？这太神奇了，但也太荒谬了。你能相信这些东西吗？所以他说，他谈到带你进入与罗伯特·摩西在一起并以这种方式被招待的体验。我必须假设这是因为他可能亲身经历过不少这样的事情。
I think that in the notes, I think he talks about a day when he was given the kind of the Robert Moses treatment before RM cut the cut him out when he was still interviewing with him. It says, waiting to lunch with Robert Moses, a guest would be ushered at Randall's Island into an anteroom lined with pictures of Robert Moses' bridges, Robert Moses' parks, Robert Moses' parkways, of Robert Moses posing with Hoover, of Robert Moses posing with Roosevelt, of Robert Moses posing with Truman, with Eisenhower, and later with Kennedy and Johnson, and Pope John. At Belmont Lake, into an anteroom with walls covered literally from wall to ceiling,
我想在笔记里，他谈到了有一天他受到了罗伯特·摩西的待遇，在RM还在采访他时，就把他拒之门外了。书中写道，等待与罗伯特·摩西共进午餐的客人会被带到兰德尔岛的一个前厅，墙上挂满了罗伯特·摩西的桥梁、罗伯特·摩西的公园、罗伯特·摩西的公园大道，罗伯特·摩西与胡佛、罗斯福、杜鲁门、艾森豪威尔，以及后来的肯尼迪、约翰逊和教皇约翰的合影。在贝尔蒙特湖，进入一个墙上从墙到天花板都贴满了
with Robert Moses's plaques and trophies. There might be a gleaming white scale model or two of past or future achievements lying carelessly about... Finally, RM himself would appear, at the head of a procession of eight or ten aides, for if emperors had courts, so of course did he. If by chance he was called out of the room to take a telephone call when he returned his aides would jump to their feet and would not sit down until he sat down dot dot dot the food at lunches at Randall's Island, not special luncheons, just the typical lunch served by white coated waiters to groups ranging in size from half a dozen to half a hundred, perhaps 150 times a year was spoken of by guests in tones of awe. And it's, I just love the,
罗伯特·摩西的牌匾和奖杯的前厅。可能会有几个闪闪发光的白色比例模型，漫不经心地摆放着……最后，RM本人会出现，身后跟着八九个助手，因为如果皇帝有朝廷，他当然也有。如果他碰巧被叫出房间去接电话，当他回来时，他的助手们会跳起来，直到他坐下才敢坐下……在兰德尔岛午餐的食物，不是特别的午餐，只是由穿白大褂的服务员为人数从半打到半百不等的人群提供的典型午餐，每年大约有150次，客人们谈论时都带着敬畏的语气。我只是喜欢，
like you can so luxury in that, but he's also getting across. It's not just that Moses likes this stuff for luxury sake, although I'm sure he does a certain amount. It is a way of expressing power. When you're being fed by Robert Moses, you are being overwhelmed by the, by the power of this guy and what he can do. And you go to lunch with him, he will talk the entire time. He does not let you do any talking. Caro says that there's a reporter who went to one of these lunches and secretly timed it, like checking his watch.
你可以在其中感受到奢华，但他也在传达。摩西不仅仅是为了奢华而喜欢这些东西，尽管我相信他确实有一定程度的享受。这是一种表达权力的方式。当你被罗伯特·摩西招待时，你会被这个人的权力和他能做的事情所压倒。当你和他一起吃午餐时，他会一直说话。他不让你说话。卡罗说，有一位记者去参加了其中一次午餐，并偷偷计时，就像看手表一样。
And he goes, he came back and said, well, Moses talked for an hour and 20 minutes straight without interruption. And it is all, it's all of this is a way of softening you up so that you are, you're ready for the hard sell that he's gonna make on you. Yeah. And he's surrounded by all these people All of this is a way of softening you up so that you're ready for the hard sell that he's gonna make on you. Yeah, and he's surrounded by all these people
他说，他回来后说，摩西连续说了一个小时20分钟，中间没有停顿。所有这些都是为了软化你，让你准备好接受他要向你推销的东西。是的。而且他被所有这些人包围着，所有这些都是为了软化你，让你准备好接受他要向你推销的东西。是的，而且他被所有这些人包围着，
so that if you have any type of disagreement with him or come to just bring up any point, he'll go, I don't know, that sounds dumb to me. What do you think, Sam? What do you think, Jimmy? What do you think this? And they all go, I think you're right, sir. And then he's like, yep, uh-huh, that's what I thought.
这样如果你对他有任何不同意见，或者提出任何观点，他就会说，我不知道，这听起来很蠢。你怎么看，萨姆？你怎么看，吉米？你怎么看这个？他们都说，我认为你是对的，先生。然后他说，是的，嗯哼，我也是这么想的。
And that's it. It's amazing how openly straightforward it is, that it's like, yeah, all my guys say I'm right, so are you gonna argue with a whole room full of people? And those guys, they are, I mean, I should say, they are guys for the most part. They're Moses men, they call themselves. They also feel that power themselves.
就是这样。这种公开的直接性令人惊叹，就像是，是的，我的人都说我是对的，所以你要和一个满屋子的人争论吗？而那些人，他们是，我的意思是，我应该说，他们大多是男人。他们是摩西的人，他们自称如此。他们自己也感受到了那种权力。
And Kara talks about, this is another passage I love where he talks about them getting the news as Robert Moses is being driven to work. As he passes each kind of toll booth or stopping point, he doesn't stop, he goes straight through, but as he passes what would be stopping points for normal people, the people at those points are calling the office to say RM is five minutes away, RM is three minutes away. It says they would hurriedly recheck one last time to make sure that any map or blueprint for
卡罗谈到了这一点，这是我喜欢的另一段，他谈到当罗伯特·摩西被开车送去上班时，他们如何得到消息。当他经过每一个收费站或停车点时，他不停下来，他直接穿过，但当他经过正常人会停下的地方时，那些点的人会打电话给办公室说RM还有五分钟就到了，RM还有三分钟就到了。书中说，他们会匆忙地最后检查一遍，确保任何他可能要求的地图或蓝图
which he might ask was ready for his perusal. Scurrying back and forth, secretaries would put a dozen freshly sharpened pencils in the pencil holder on his desk, straighten the pile of letters there, dust his office one last time. Worst of all, says one, was when he headed first from his Babylon home to Belmont Lake, for that trip took only about five minutes. Everyone would start shouting, the boss is coming, the boss is coming. He's on his way over from Thompson Avenue. And everyone would start rushing around in little circles
都准备好供他查阅。秘书们匆忙地跑来跑去，在办公桌的笔筒里放上一打刚削好的铅笔，整理好那里的信件堆，最后一次打扫他的办公室。最糟糕的是，其中一个人说，是他从巴比伦的家前往贝尔蒙特湖的时候，因为那段路程只需要五分钟。每个人都会开始大喊，老板来了，老板来了。他正从汤普森大道过来。每个人都开始在小圈子里跑来跑去，
as if they were crazy. And it's just the idea that they are keeping tabs on how many minutes they have before he gets to the office so they can get things just right. Because he also, part of this workaholism and this energy is he also has a temper. And he's known to slam his hand down on his desk or punch the wall or yell at people. It's a, it's all power. It's all ways of imposing your will on other people. Yeah. Yeah. And you know, it's not just Randall's Island where he hosts these folks. The real
好像他们疯了一样。这只是一个想法，他们记录着他在到达办公室前还有多少分钟，这样他们就能把事情做得恰到好处。因为他也是，这种工作狂和这种精力的一部分是他也有脾气。他以猛拍桌子、打墙或对人大吼大叫而闻名。这是一种，这全是权力。这全是强加你意志于他人的方式。是的。是的。而且你知道，他招待这些人的地方不仅仅是兰德尔岛。真正
place to host people to show the glory of Robert Moses is Jones Beach, this like great triumph early on and is still kept up as a kind of a temple to Robert Moses of this period. Jones Beach is still an amazing, you know, it's the greatest bathing beach in the world probably, you know, according to Moses. And he has all these things there so that he can take his guests and they can go yachting,
招待人们以展示罗伯特·摩西荣耀的地方是琼斯海滩，这是早期的一个伟大胜利，至今仍被视为这一时期罗伯特·摩西的某种神庙。琼斯海滩仍然是一个令人惊叹的，你知道，它可能是世界上最伟大的沐浴海滩，你知道，根据摩西的说法。他在那里有所有这些东西，这样他就可以带他的客人去游艇，
they can go horseback riding, they can go swimming, there's fancy food, he has, you know, the restaurants there pay ludicrously low rents to the department. And in exchange, they are just always available to host Robert Moses' guests for free, I assume. And similarly, he runs the Jones Beach Marine Stadium that way, which is it's an 8,200 seat theater that is essentially his private theater.
他们可以去骑马，他们可以去游泳，有高级食品，他有，你知道，那里的餐厅向部门支付极其低廉的租金。作为交换，他们总是随时准备免费招待罗伯特·摩西的客人，我想。同样，他以这种方式经营琼斯海滩海洋体育场，这是一个8200座的剧院，本质上是他的私人剧院。
There's this stage on a manmade island that's separated from the front seats by a moat. And the front seats are all luxury boxes that are reserved for his, either for banks and corporations or for his personal guests, not the public. And the center box, the people worth their nicknamed it the Royal Box.
有一个舞台在一个人工岛上，与前排座位隔着一条护城河。前排座位全是豪华包厢，是为他的，要么是为银行和公司，要么是为他的私人客人预留的，而不是为公众。中间的包厢，人们戏称它为皇家包厢。
And that's reserved for Moses and his personal guests. And whenever he's there, the band leader, Guy Lombardo, very well-known band leader of the time, he's mentioned in the lyrics to guys and dolls. He gets a personal introduction from the stage, from Guy Lombardo, and Carol makes a point of saying, Moses acts as if, what? Oh, I don't need it, I don't need it. He kind of acts like he's ignoring it.
那是为摩西和他的私人客人预留的。每当他在那里时，乐队指挥盖伊·隆巴多，当时非常著名的乐队指挥，他在《红男绿女》的歌词中被提到，他会从舞台上得到盖伊·隆巴多的个人介绍，卡罗特意说，摩西表现得好像，什么？哦，我不需要，我不需要。他表现得好像在忽略它。
Oh, it's not special. But he kind of always shows up just at the right time to get this introduction, where he'll show up just to get the introduction and then leave the show. And Moses decides what's gonna be on in the stadium, what shows are gonna be there, ticket sales, they're never very good.
哦，这没什么特别的。但他总是恰好在正确的时间出现以获得这个介绍，他会仅仅为了获得介绍而出现，然后离开演出。摩西决定体育场里要上演什么，会有什么节目，门票销售，从来都不太好。
The theater is rarely more than half full, but it doesn't really matter because Moses is not really putting up a public theater. He's putting up a place for himself to impress his guests. And another part of that is showing them, I have Guy Lombardo on my personal call whenever, one of America's biggest band leaders. And in exchange, all I have to do is that Guy Lombardo
剧院很少有超过一半满座的时候，但这并不重要，因为摩西并不是真的在经营一个公共剧院。他是在建立一个让自己给客人留下深刻印象的地方。这其中的另一部分是向他们展示，我有盖伊·隆巴多随时听候我的差遣，他是美国最伟大的乐队指挥之一。作为交换，我所要做的就是让盖伊·隆巴多
and his brother take all the money from the theater for themselves. And it's like the state built this theater for $4.2 million and the state never sees that money back. It's all going to Guy Lombardo. And it's just another example of Moses saying, I'm gonna use the public money to build something and I'm gonna use it for my private needs
和他的兄弟自己拿走剧院的所有钱。这就像州政府花了420万美元建造了这个剧院，而州政府却从未收回那笔钱。钱全进了盖伊·隆巴多的口袋。这只是摩西的另一个例子，他说，我要用公共资金建造一些东西，我要用它来满足我的私人需求，
of exposing power. And the way that I get that is by letting someone else make money out of it. You know, it's this, the state pays the money, you take the money, I don't want that, but I'm gonna need you whenever I need a favor to impress somebody else. Yeah, and the the money, I don't want that, but I'm gonna need you whenever I need a favor to impress somebody else. Yeah, and the thing is, again, he's figured out
即展示权力。我得到这一点的方法是让别人从中赚钱。你知道，这是，州政府付钱，你拿钱，我不想要那个，但我需要你的时候，我需要你帮我一个忙来给别人留下深刻印象。是的，而且，钱，我不想要那个，但我需要你的时候，我需要你帮我一个忙来给别人留下深刻印象。是的，而且，事情是，再一次，他已经弄清楚了
something really critical, which is like, you don't need to take money from people if you use their money to give you everything you want anyway. Yeah. Because normally, if you want your own outdoor amphitheater on a beach, you have to pay $4 million to build that thing.
一些非常关键的事情，那就是，如果你用别人的钱来给你想要的一切，你就不需要从别人那里拿钱。是的。因为通常，如果你想要一个自己在海滩上的露天圆形剧场，你必须支付400万美元来建造那个东西。
But instead, you have other people build it. You don't claim any part of it, but you use it as your own. That's pretty much just taking it for yourself. Yeah, that's a good point. If it's like, well, the house department is gonna build this mansion for me, I'm gonna live in it, but you know what? It's just part of my public use.
但相反，你让别人建造它。你不声称拥有它的任何部分，但你把它当作自己的使用。这基本上就是把它据为己有。是的，这是一个很好的观点。如果就像，嗯，住房部门要为我建造这座豪宅，我要住在里面，但你知道吗？这只是我公共用途的一部分。
Yeah, if your house is paid for, your cars are paid for, your food is paid for, you have theaters and all this stuff happening for you, like what do you need money for? And yet he is still constantly low on money and running into debt, which is astounding. Caro, so this is a section that's well worth reading for anybody where he takes you through kind of like what it's like to be the guest of Moses. There's this fleet
是的，如果你的房子有人付钱，你的车有人付钱，你的食物有人付钱，你有剧院和所有这些为你发生的事情，那你还需要钱干什么？然而他仍然经常缺钱并陷入债务，这令人震惊。卡罗，所以这是一个非常值得任何人阅读的部分，他带你体验作为摩西的客人是什么感觉。这里有一个车队
of limos. There's this, the concierge service that's provided to you. Would your children like to ride in a little boat with Guy Lombardo as he goes to the stage? They can do that. You know, would you like another martini? Of course, sir. Uh, and you don't get to see too much of Moses during these visits because he's working and he has a cubicle built in the stadium, this little office goal that he can sit in, so he can work, go up for his introduction from Guy Lombardo that he goes, "'Oh, I don't need it, I don't need it,'
的豪华轿车。这里有为你提供的礼宾服务。你的孩子想在盖伊·隆巴多去舞台时坐小船吗？他们可以那样做。你知道，你想要另一杯马提尼吗？当然，先生。嗯，在这些访问期间你见不到摩西太多次，因为他在工作，他在体育场里建了一个隔间，这个小办公室目标，他可以坐在里面，这样他就可以工作，上去接受盖伊·隆巴多的介绍，他说，“哦，我不需要，我不需要，”
and then leave and go back to work. And he'll see you for a couple minutes, in those couple minutes, he'll just totally charm you. He'll be telling you anecdotes about all the amazing things he's done in his career, kind of press you a little bit on the thing that he wants you to do, kind of press you a little bit on the thing that he wants you to do. And then it's over and the limousines
然后离开回去工作。他会见你几分钟，在那几分钟里，他会完全迷住你。他会告诉你关于他职业生涯中所有惊人成就的轶事，在某种程度上稍微向你施压，让你做他想让你做的事情，在某种程度上稍微向你施压，让你做他想让你做的事情。然后就结束了，豪华轿车
take you back home again. And it's like Jones Beach, it's almost like a corporate version of what Disneyland looks like in commercials is what it sounds like, you know, for adult for mid century, American professionals, it's like, this is their kind of like magical day in a kingdom run by this magical powerful man. That's right. And then he kind of does many versions of this every time there is an opening of a public
把你送回家。这就像琼斯海滩，它几乎是广告中迪士尼乐园看起来的某种企业版本，这就是它听起来的样子，你知道，对于中世纪的美国专业人士来说，这就像是，这是他们在由这个神奇的强大男人经营的王国里的神奇一天。没错。然后他每次有公共工程开幕时，都会做很多这样的版本
work somewhere. Like he just lavishes everyone with food and champagne and waiters dressed to the nines and everything like this. Like he really does, he becomes a kind of his own PR machine in a certain way through this whining and dining. I mean, if you wanna put a good spin on it, you could say, hey, he's always up for a party and any excuse for a party and he's ready to have fun.
在某个地方。就像他用食物、香槟和穿着考究的服务员来款待每个人，一切都像这样。就像他真的，他通过这种吃喝玩乐，在某种程度上成为了他自己的公关机器。我的意思是，如果你想往好的方面想，你可以说，嘿，他总是准备好参加派对，任何派对的借口，他都准备好玩得开心。
But it is always for a purpose. It is to get people on his side. It's not just cause he loves a good hang, but you're right, in 1953, they're opening some new tollbooths on the Northern State Parkway. And he's like, yeah, we need a party, 40 foot long buffet table, bring in the waiters, we need champagne to celebrate these new tollbooths.
但这总是为了一个目的。这是为了让人们站在他这一边。这不仅仅是因为他喜欢聚会，但你是对的，1953年，他们在北部州立公园大道上开设了一些新的收费站。他说，是的，我们需要一个派对，40英尺长的自助餐桌，带上服务员，我们需要香槟来庆祝这些新的收费站。
And if a big project opened, then it was just done in amazing style. And he is so particular about the details of what he does that he is overseeing all this. It's not like he tells his people, throw a party. Okay, great, we did it. He is very particular about his style and what he wants to do.
如果一个大项目开工了，那就会以惊人的风格完成。而且他对细节非常讲究，他监督着这一切。并不是说他告诉他的人，举办一个派对。好的，太棒了，我们做到了。他对自己的风格和他想做的事情非常讲究。
And Carol quotes from a memo that I love so much where, so Arnold Schleifer, who was running Tavern on the Green, you know, where he had gotten a sweetheart deal from Moses that he paid very little rent to run this restaurant in Central Park. He caters one of these and I guess he tries to make it too fancy or too nouveau riche, I'm not sure. And Moses writes this thing goes,
卡罗引用了一份我非常喜欢的备忘录，所以阿诺德·施莱弗，他经营着绿地酒馆，你知道，他在那里从摩西那里得到了一个甜头，他支付很少的租金来经营这个中央公园的餐厅。他承办了其中一个，我想他试图让它变得太花哨或太暴发户，我不确定。摩西写了这段话，
last night Schleifer version of Bolshezar's feast was contrary to all instructions. The catering crew was all right. The hat chicks were belles amies. Other than the fact that he talked, he mentions the looks of the hat chicks is ridiculous. And the barkeepers upheld the finest traditions of the craft, but the hors d'oeuvres were disgusting. Tray after tray of indigestible insides, cow's eyes on mushrooms, squid in its own ink, pastry, costume jewelry, mounted dog food, mayonnaise, rococo, and gaudy gook. Hitch life over the head for me. We are not celebrating a gangster wedding.
昨晚施莱弗版本的伯沙撒盛宴违背了所有指示。餐饮人员还可以。帽子女孩是美女。除了他谈到帽子女孩的样子很荒谬之外。酒保保持了该行业最优秀的传统，但开胃菜令人作呕。一盘又一盘难以消化的内脏，蘑菇上的牛眼，墨鱼汁里的鱿鱼，糕点，仿制珠宝，安装的狗粮，蛋黄酱，洛可可和俗气的粘糊糊的东西。替我把施莱弗的头打爆。我们不是在庆祝黑帮婚礼。
And it's just, I love that he is so, everything has to be perfect for him. Our derves have to be the right kind of our derves. And at the same time, he is running so much of the construction in the city, but he's still got time to get mad about these hors d'oeuvres. Yeah, I think it's hilarious. Especially the kind of like,
我只是喜欢他，一切对他来说都必须是完美的。开胃菜必须是正确的开胃菜。与此同时，他经营着城市里大部分的建筑，但他仍然有时间对这些开胃菜感到愤怒。是的，我觉得这很搞笑。尤其是那种，
I mean, everything about him is tinged with a kind of, uh, xenophobia. You know what I mean? Like, you know, there's like, he's basically saying, I want normal food. You know, normal food that white people eat, you know, normal food, you know what I mean? Where are the deviled eggs Schleifer? What's going on here? Later in that memo, he goes, he goes, we want a few simple appetizing things, not a pastry competition to be judged by
我的意思是，关于他的一切都带有一种，嗯，仇外心理。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你知道，他基本上是在说，我想要正常的食物。你知道我的意思吗？白人吃的正常食物，你知道我的意思吗？施莱弗，魔鬼蛋在哪里？这里发生了什么？在那份备忘录的后面，他说，他说，我们想要一些简单的开胃菜，而不是一场由
Pretzel Varnisher's Union Number Three. And like it's. I mean, that makes me think his book was pretty good, actually. Yeah. That's a Varnisher Union Number Three. That's some good detail. I mean, that's, it's a, it's, there's something similar to,
三号上光工工会评判的糕点比赛。这让我想起他的书其实写得挺好的。是的。三号上光工工会。那是一些很好的细节。我的意思是，这是一个，这是一个，
there's certain, there's certain people who are bad people and are very mean, but in that meanness, they can say very funny things, you know. I assume you're talking about here. Yeah. And so once again, this is not something he does just to feel like a big man or just because he enjoys it. This is a way also of rewarding people who have done things that he likes.
有些人是坏人，而且非常刻薄，但在那种刻薄中，他们可以说出非常有趣的事情，你知道。我假设你在这里说的是。是的。所以再一次，这不是他为了感觉自己是个大人物或仅仅因为他喜欢而做的事情。这也是奖励那些做了他喜欢的事情的人的一种方式。
He invites them to these parties, punishing someone who did something that he didn't like by denying them an invitation. It's all tools of power. If you're a reporter, he will give you special treatment until you write a negative article about him and then you're cut off and you don't get it. And it's a tool for persuading people. And Carol talks about how it is more difficult to challenge someone, to challenge their facts, to challenge their argument when you are having
他邀请他们参加这些派对，通过拒绝邀请来惩罚那些做了他不喜欢的坏事的人。这全是权力的工具。如果你是一名记者，他会给你特殊待遇，直到你写了一篇关于他的负面文章，然后你就被切断了，你得不到它。这是说服人们的工具。卡罗谈到了当你在他们的领地喝鸡尾酒，当他们被同意他们的人包围时，挑战某人，挑战他们的事实，挑战他们的论点是多么困难，很难不同意和挑战一个在用豪华轿车把你接过来后为你提供美味午餐的人。当你明知道如果你不同意他，他不会尊重你，他不会接受，他会非常生气。如果他想让你在那种环境下签署一份文件，
cocktails in their territory and when they're surrounded by people who agree with them, it's very hard to disagree and challenge someone who is serving you a delicious lunch after bringing you over in a limousine. And when you know that if you disagree with him, he's not gonna be respectable, he's not gonna take it, he's gonna get very mad. And if he wants you to sign a document in that setting,
而且一切都为你准备好了，他在午餐时把它递给你，很难说不。你怎么找到一种礼貌的方式说不？他以一种非常冷酷、非常精于算计的方式，将中世纪的礼仪和人们天生想要被对方喜欢，或者至少被另一个人认可的愿望武器化了。
and it's all ready for you, and he hands it to you at lunch, it's very hard to say no. How do you find a polite way to say no? He has kind of weaponized mid-century etiquette and people's natural want to be liked by the other person or at least be approved of by another person in a way that is really kind of cold, very calculating, very cold and calculating.
是的，是的。所以呈现所有这些有趣的过剩，我的意思是，我想这是有趣的过剩。你肯定能发现所有这些东西背后的一些邪恶的暗流，但主要是它被呈现为，让我们享受这种疯狂的细节。卡罗然后又转过这一章，
Yeah, yeah. And so presenting all this sort of fun excess, I mean, I guess it's fun excess. You can definitely find some nefarious, you know, undercurrent to all of this stuff, but mostly it's presented as like, let's just kind of enjoy the details of this craziness. Carol then sort of turns the chapter again
提醒你，哦，顺便说一句，这就是我们正在谈论的家伙。这是一个像移动了比世界上几乎任何人类历史上更多的地球的家伙，并开始为下一章做铺垫。但他真的只是在谈论20世纪的纽约市就是摩西的时代。是的，他开始说，
and just like reminds you, oh, by the way, here's our guy that we're talking about. This is a guy who's like moved more Earth than almost any human in the history of the world, and sort of starts to go to set us up for the next chapter. But he's really just talking about how the 20th century in New York City is just the age of Moses. Yeah, he starts kind of saying,
这就像是在提醒你，哦，顺便说一下，这就是我们正在谈论的那个人。他移动的土方量几乎超过了世界历史上任何一个人，这为我们开启了下一个篇章。但他实际上只是在谈论20世纪的纽约市就是摩西的时代。是的，他开始说，
you basically can't compare him with other people who have done these things. You have to say, oh, the age of Moses is like the age of railroads. Other people may have invented things or created things, this guy has, or built things. This guy is shaping a city and he's doing it over the course of 44 years.
你基本上无法将他与做过这些事情的其他人相提并论。你必须说，哦，摩西时代就像铁路时代。其他人可能发明了东西或创造了东西，而这家伙，或者说建造了东西。这家伙正在塑造一座城市，而且他是在44年的时间里完成的。
He's in some form of high office, high appointed office from 1924 to 1968. And it's just this enormous territory that he has so much control over. And Caro is quoting Moses at one point predicting that his work's gonna stand through the year 1999, and because, you know, it was a far off year at the time when it was written. And Caro is like, of course it will. He goes, why won't it last 2,000 years? The works of ancient Rome, they lasted for millennia. There's no reason to say that Moses's work won't. And the funny thing there is that Carol, two of his
从1924年到1968年，他一直担任某种高级公职，高级任命职位。他所掌控的领土范围之广令人震惊。卡罗在书中引用了摩西的一段话，预测他的作品将屹立到1999年，因为你知道，在写下这段话的时候，那还是一个遥远的年份。卡罗对此表示，当然会。他说，为什么不能屹立2000年呢？古罗马的作品，它们屹立了千年。没有理由说摩西的作品不会。有趣的是，卡罗提到的两个
examples that he gives are Shea Stadium and the New York Coliseum because they were so patterned on the Roman Coliseum, but then those are both gone. They did last until 1999, though, I think. That's true. Yeah, that's true. I'll give you that. And Carol was like, unless there's an atomic attack on New York, or a massive natural catastrophe, New York will remain the city that Moses built and shaped far more than any other single person, possibly to the end of human civilization, you know, which is really astounding. And he follows that up with a kind of, this has been a testament to
例子是谢伊体育场和纽约体育馆，因为它们在很大程度上模仿了罗马斗兽场，但现在这两个建筑都不存在了。不过我想它们确实坚持到了1999年。没错。是的，确实如此。我承认这一点。卡罗说，除非纽约遭到原子弹袭击，或者发生巨大的自然灾难，否则纽约将依然是摩西建造和塑造的城市，其程度远超任何其他个人，甚至可能直到人类文明终结，你知道，这真的很令人震惊。他接着说，这证明了
Moses's influence, to his power, and he follows that up with a testament to Moses's kind of, this has been a testament to Moses's influence, to his power. And he follows that with a testament to Moses's kind of inability to change and the flip side of that power, which is someone who refuses to listen to others and is even blind and deaf to their existence or needs. And he says there's a deliberate blindness, a deliberate deafness to reason, to argument, to new ideas. And Moses, we've seen it many times, and caretakers, again, he doesn't believe ordinary rules apply to him. When, like, they're little things. When he goes to the board of estimate to speak at a public meeting, every speaker is supposed to say their name and address, just kind of to establish who they are
摩西的影响力，他的权力，他接着又证明了摩西的某种，这证明了摩西的影响力，他的权力。他接着证明了摩西某种无法改变的特质，以及这种权力的另一面，即一个人拒绝倾听他人，甚至对他们的存在或需求视而不见、充耳不闻。他说，这是一种故意的盲目，对理性、争论和新思想的故意充耳不闻。摩西，我们已经多次见识过了，而且看管者，再说一次，他不相信普通规则适用于他。当，比如，一些小事。当他去估价委员会在公开会议上发言时，每个发言者都应该说出自己的名字和地址，这只是为了确定他们的身份
and why they have a right to be there. And he refuses to do it. And nobody makes him. And when people in the crowd start going, make him say his name, make him say his name, the mayor is like, everybody knows who he is, he's Robert Moses, anyway, talk, talk. And when he needs beach grass to hold the sand around Idlewild Airport in place, he just sends his guys to steal it from private homes. And there's a moment where W. Kingsland Macy, who you may remember many episodes back,
以及他们为什么有权在那里。但他拒绝这样做。没人能强迫他。当人群开始喊“让他说出名字，让他说出名字”时，市长却说，大家都知道他是谁，他是罗伯特·摩西，总之，让他说吧。当他需要海滩草来固定艾德怀尔德机场周围的沙子时，他只是派人去从私人住宅里偷。有一次，W·金斯兰·梅西，你可能还记得几集前提到过，
was Moses' enemy in the 20s, and then became an ally of his, he's like, why are Parks employees starting to take the grass away from my house and other people's houses? And they don't stop doing it until 13 Parks employees are arrested by the police. Like it's just, Moses does not believe the rules apply to him because he thinks of himself at such a high level, at such a, that he is a figure of such enormous history and importance. Yeah, yeah. I mean, there's a mention that Caros says that he begins to think of himself as Abraham Lincoln. You've read a lot of books on Abraham Lincoln.
他是摩西20年代的敌人，后来成了他的盟友，他说，为什么公园的员工开始从我家和其他人的房子里拿走草？直到13名公园员工被警察逮捕，他们才停止这样做。就像是，摩西不相信规则适用于他，因为他认为自己处于如此高的水平，处于如此，他是一个具有如此巨大历史意义和重要性的人物。是的，是的。我的意思是，卡罗提到他开始认为自己是亚伯拉罕·林肯。你读过很多关于亚伯拉罕·林肯的书。
Do you compare Robert Moses to Abraham Lincoln very often? I will say, I mean, the answer, the short answer is no. Long answer is, in Moses' defense, Abraham Lincoln moved much less Earth than Robert Moses, unless it was earth being blasted by you know Cannon shot the grape shot and things like that and artillery but the but I would say no I think there's that there's a grandiosity to that and a sense that uh, their goals were different I think I think and the impact of one over time more more positive than the other but it but it really speaks to it that He is he is not just
你经常把罗伯特·摩西和亚伯拉罕·林肯相提并论吗？我会说，我的意思是，简短的回答是不。长一点的回答是，为摩西辩护的话，亚伯拉罕·林肯移动的土方量比罗伯特·摩西少得多，除非那是被炮弹、葡萄弹之类的东西和火炮炸开的泥土，但我会说不，我认为这其中有一种宏大感，而且他们目标不同，我认为，我认为随着时间的推移，一个人的影响比另一个人更积极，但这确实说明了，他不仅仅是
associating himself with a great, powerful person from history, but from a revered, almost sacred person from American history. Like he's basically America's saint. We have like a few of them, and Abraham Lincoln is one of them, and he puts himself in that territory. But I would say like the strength of Abraham Lincoln
将自己与历史上一个伟大、有权势的人联系起来，而是与美国历史上一个受人尊敬、近乎神圣的人联系起来。就像他基本上是美国的圣人。我们有几个这样的人，亚伯拉罕·林肯就是其中之一，他把自己放在了那个领域。但我会说，亚伯拉罕·林肯的力量
is that he changed over time. You know, like- Yes, very much so. And Robert Moses has this inability to take in new information and change. There's a, not to get too much into Lincoln, because I could talk about him for hours. We'll do a Lincoln podcast eventually, I guess.
在于他随着时间的推移而改变。你知道，就像——是的，非常如此。而罗伯特·摩西有一种无法吸收新信息并做出改变的无能。有一个，不是说要过多地谈论林肯，因为我可以谈论他几个小时。我想我们最终会做一个关于林肯的播客。
But it's that, yeah, the thing that, one of the many things that made him the great man that he was, was that he was constantly questioning, do I really know the things that I know? Do I really understand the things that I understand? And moving and changing with time and with thought and with reason and with changing events around him
但就是这样，是的，让他成为伟大人物的众多原因之一，是他不断地质疑，我真的知道我所知道的事情吗？我真的理解我所理解的事情吗？并随着时间和思想、理性的变化，以及周围事件的变化而移动和改变
so that he can adjust himself to what, people talk about, right know, rightfully, because it's true that Lincoln for a while believed that colonization of Africa was the only way to deal with the race fraud in America, that black people and white people can't live in the same country. They have to go somewhere else and have their own country. But by the end of his life, he does not seem to have believed that. It seems to be a different thing. A change in his exposure to new realities, his exposure to new ideas changed the way he thought.
这样他就能调整自己以适应，人们谈论的，对的，因为林肯确实有一段时间认为非洲殖民化是解决美国种族欺诈的唯一途径，即黑人和白人不能生活在同一个国家。他们必须去别的地方，拥有自己的国家。但在他生命的最后，他似乎不再相信这一点了。这似乎是另一回事。他接触新现实、接触新思想的变化改变了他的思维方式。
And the strength of him is in allowing himself that exposure, even while in a position of power. Whereas Moses is deliberately going out of his way not to expose himself to new ideas, new realities, changing ways, changing times, because he doesn't care. He doesn't want to, he doesn't care, he doesn't think it's worthwhile. Yeah, he's really locked into what, you know,
他的力量在于允许自己接触这些，即使在掌权的时候。而摩西则故意避开接触新思想、新现实、不断变化的方式和时代，因为他不在乎。他不想，他不在乎，他不认为这值得。是的，他真的被锁在了，你知道，
kind of like, I keep on saying this sort of word, firmware. Like he's kind of locked into this, what was written down in his brain in the 1920s, because so much of what he did was successful, you know, like just, it worked of the moment, you know, so that he got sort of intoxicated by his own success. But he really like, the role of the automobile he really liked the role of the automobile in society and the role of the automobile in cities
有点像，我一直在说这个词，固件。就像他被锁在了20世纪20年代写在他大脑里的东西里，因为他所做的大部分事情都成功了，你知道，就像，它在当时奏效了，你知道，所以他被自己的成功陶醉了。但他真的，汽车在社会中的作用，他真的很喜欢汽车在社会中的作用，以及汽车在城市中的作用
changed so drastically from the 19 teens to the 1950s. And he just did not seem to notice or care that that was the case. That is a remarkable thing for someone who maybe does things that I don't agree with, but he definitely thought about the city a lot, but he just ignored this huge change in piece of information.
从1910年代到1950年代发生了如此巨大的变化。而他似乎根本没有注意到或不在乎这种情况。对于一个可能做了一些我不赞同的事情的人来说，这是一件了不起的事情，但他确实对城市思考了很多，但他只是忽略了这个巨大的变化信息。
It's kind of stunning to me. It's amazing. It's almost as if, Roman, you and I were like, we still thought about telephones as a thing that plugs into a wall. It's only connected to a building, and you can't listen to music on it, and you can't look up information like a computer.
这对我来说有点令人震惊。太神奇了。这几乎就像，罗曼，你和我，我们仍然认为电话是插在墙上的东西。它只连接到建筑物，你不能用它听音乐，也不能像电脑一样查找信息。
It's such a massive kind of misunderstanding of the way a thing is used, the way that the other people think of the thing at that point. Maybe I'm exaggerating a little bit, I don't know. But Robert Harrow, he talks about Moses in the way you would talk about an artist, a genius artist whose initial work is stunning,
这是一种对事物使用方式、其他人当时对该事物的看法的大规模误解。也许我有点夸张了，我不知道。但罗伯特·卡罗，他谈论摩西的方式就像你谈论一位艺术家，一位天才艺术家，其最初的作品令人惊叹，
is new and innovative and exciting, but who because of the reputation of that work they can get away with this arrogance that they used to distance themselves from the world and so their later work becomes stale. It doesn't work the same way that a genius, even if you're a genius, you still need to be rooted in some understanding of reality and once you remove yourself from reality, your work becomes at best, if you're an artist, just unpopular. And at worst, if you are building massive roads through cities, it becomes catastrophic
新颖、创新且令人兴奋，但由于这些作品的声誉，他们可以逃脱这种傲慢，他们用这种傲慢将自己与世界隔离开来，所以他们后期的作品变得陈腐。它不像天才那样运作，即使你是天才，你仍然需要扎根于对现实的某种理解，一旦你脱离了现实，你的作品充其量，如果你是艺术家，就变得不受欢迎。而最坏的情况是，如果你正在城市中建造巨大的道路，它就会变得灾难性
for the people who are living there. Absolutely. Absolutely. It's just really, he just sort of puts this bubble around him. This is the other part of that world he creates, his kingdom that he creates to entertain these people, is there's this bubble around him that stops him from evolving in any significant way that would matter and so that it would serve a city and the people better.
对于住在那里的人来说。绝对是这样。绝对是这样。他只是把自己关在一个泡泡里。这是他创造的那个世界的另一部分，他为了娱乐这些人而创造的王国，他周围有一个泡泡，阻止他以任何重要的方式进化，从而更好地服务于城市和人民。
Yeah, and because he's in that bubble, he never has to think about things, he doesn't reflect. And that's, Caro, I think he's hit this before, the idea that Moses is working too fast. He's not taking time and Caro, of course, is not an author who believes in working fast. He doesn't, he doesn't like to do things too quickly. And he says there was a time when Moses had to ride a train from work to his home and would just stare out the window and see the world outside that window and think about it. And there was a time when he would spend days, if not weeks, if not months,
是的，因为他在那个泡泡里，他从不需要思考事情，他不反思。这就是，卡罗，我想他之前提到过这一点，摩西工作太快了。他没有花时间，而卡罗当然不是一个相信快速工作的作者。他不喜欢太快地做事情。他说曾经有一段时间，摩西不得不坐火车从工作地点回家，只是盯着窗外，看着窗外的世界并思考它。曾经有一段时间，他会花几天，甚至几周，甚至几个月，
tromping around in nature, experiencing what Long Island is actually like and thinking about the land there and how it could be used. And now he doesn't do those things. And Caro kind of implicitly approves of this earlier Moses because his methods are so much more like Caro's methods. They're methodical and detail-oriented, they're thorough, they take time. And he disapproves of the later Moses, who's very un-Caro-like,
在自然界中漫步，体验长岛的真实面貌，思考那里的土地以及如何利用它。现在他不再做这些事情了。卡罗在某种程度上默认了早期的摩西，因为他的方法更像卡罗的方法。它们是有条理的、注重细节的、彻底的，它们需要时间。而他反对后期的摩西，那是非常不像卡罗的，
who is just like, gotta do it, get it done, okay, put it in, who cares? Move that over there, yes, this is what we're doing, don't listen to him. And it's a wonderful thing in a biography, I think, when you see the writer expressing their philosophy through what they're doing in a way that is not just judgy, not just good, this is good and this is bad, but where you kind of you get the feeling that a person is writing this who has beliefs about how work should be done and they're expressing that not through just telling us but through the way they're kind of talking about this other
他只是像，必须做，完成它，好的，放进去，谁在乎？把那个移到那边，是的，这就是我们要做的，不要听他的。我认为在传记中，当你看到作者通过他们正在做的事情表达他们的哲学时，这是一件美妙的事情，这种方式不仅仅是评判，不仅仅是好，这是好的，这是坏的，而是你有一种感觉，一个对工作应该如何完成有信念的人正在写这本书，他们不仅通过告诉我们，而且通过他们谈论这个人的方式来表达这一点。
person. It's exciting to me to read a biography where it feels like the author as a point of view about different things about it other than was this a good guy or is this a bad guy? It's exciting to me to read a biography where it feels like the author as a point of view about different things about it, other than was this a good guy or was this a bad guy? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And at this point in Moses' life, this sort of deafness to new ideas is not metaphorical anymore.
读一本传记让我感到兴奋，因为它感觉作者对其中的不同事物有观点，而不是这是否是一个好人或坏人？读一本传记让我感到兴奋，因为它感觉作者对其中的不同事物有观点，而不是这是否是一个好人或坏人？是的，是的，是的。在摩西生命的这个阶段，这种对新思想的充耳不闻不再是隐喻了。
He actually is literally going deaf, which is another thing a biographer can't resist. Oh, yeah, I mean, it's such a, the subtext becomes instant text, but it's like, this is reality doing it. I don't have to look. The same way, he was like, hey, he tried to resign from that swim team from Yale,
他实际上正在变聋，这是传记作者无法抗拒的另一件事。哦，是的，我的意思是，这太，潜台词变成了即时文本，但这就像，这是现实在起作用。我不必去寻找。同样地，他就像，嘿，他试图从耶鲁大学的游泳队辞职，
and he resigned as a threat for this thing? This is gold, this is a bit, you know. Exactly. This is wonderful. So he has hearing, he's very sensitive to these things because a lot of his like, his, his way of being is, you know, his bearing depends on a kind of physical dominance. And there's so much in this book that I feel like Caro is only scratching the surface of because I don't think he wants, he's psychologists, sometimes not too much. Robert Moses clearly afraid of dying, clearly knows that he will die someday, is afraid of being forgotten, is afraid of being someone who hasn't made a mark on the world, and wants to say young.
他辞职是为了威胁这件事？这是金子，这是一个梗，你知道。完全正确。这太棒了。所以他有听力，他对这些事情非常敏感，因为他的很多，他的存在方式是，你知道，他的举止取决于一种身体上的统治力。我觉得这本书里有很多卡罗只是触及了表面，因为我不认为他想，他是心理学家，有时不要太多。罗伯特·摩西显然害怕死亡，显然知道他总有一天会死，害怕被遗忘，害怕成为一个没有在世界上留下印记的人，并想保持年轻。
He wants to be young and vigorous and vital. And so he's always swimming, and he's gotta keep making things, he's gotta show that he's powerful. And once you stop hearing, you feel old, people think of you as old. He can't have anyone think of him as the old man. And we'll see later on when he is no longer in power
他想保持年轻、精力充沛和充满活力。所以他总是游泳，他必须不断地制造东西，他必须展示他是强大的。一旦你停止听力，你就会觉得自己老了，人们认为你老了。他不能让任何人认为他是老人。我们稍后会看到，当他不再掌权时
that one of the big blows against him is that like, now he's the old man. Like, who cares? He's the old, he's gone from yesterday. And so he's doing whatever he can to try to not let people know that he's deaf. And they go to, like the degree that he goes to not wear a hearing aid seems really ridiculous.
对他打击最大的事情之一就是，现在他成了老人。就像，谁在乎呢？他是旧的，他已经从昨天消失了。所以他尽其所能试图不让人们知道他是聋子。他们去，比如他不去戴助听器的程度看起来真的很荒谬。
You know, that he's got like this this system of amplifiers and microphones installed in his office so that there's a hidden microphone in his desk. So when someone's talking to him at his desk, their words are being screamed at him, I guess from a hidden speaker behind him, so that it looks like he's listening to them and can hear what they're saying. But even that doesn't work before too long. And you're just like, Mr. Moses, like RM, just if you wear a hearing aid, people will see it, but you'll be able to hear what people are saying,
你知道，他在办公室里安装了这种放大器和麦克风系统，所以他的桌子里有一个隐藏的麦克风。当有人在桌子旁和他说话时，他们的话语被对他尖叫，我想是从他身后一个隐藏的扬声器里传出来的，这样看起来他是在听他们说话，能听到他们在说什么。但即使那样，没过多久也不起作用了。你只是觉得，摩西先生，比如RM，如果你戴上助听器，人们会看到它，但你就能听到人们在说什么，
but there's a vanity to him, and not wanting to be old that is causing him trouble. Yeah, but Kare was very quick to point out that this sort of deafness is much more, the metaphorical deafness is much more, the metaphorical deafness is much more important than his literal deafness. Like he cannot update to the world that it is like, he mentions that he thinks of golf
但他有一种虚荣心，不想变老，这给他带来了麻烦。是的，但卡罗很快指出，这种耳聋更多的是，隐喻性的耳聋更多的是，隐喻性的耳聋更多的是，比他字面上的耳聋更重要。就像他无法更新到这个世界，就像，他提到他认为高尔夫
as just being only for rich people in the 1920s, maybe it was, in the 50s, maybe less so, it's a little bit more available to the proletariat. But I was, if he had watched any episode of like The Honeymooners, he'd see that like, the characters on that play golf, one of them works in the sewers and the other is a bus driver. Like we're no longer in, you know, the legend of bagger Vance type territory. We're in golf is is just for the for the rich, you know,
只是20世纪20年代富人的运动，也许是，在50年代，也许少一点，它对无产阶级来说稍微更容易获得一点。但我当时，如果他看过任何一集像《蜜月期》这样的节目，他会看到，那上面的角色打高尔夫球，其中一个在下水道工作，另一个是公交车司机。我们不再处于，你知道，那种《重返荣耀》类型的领域。我们处于高尔夫只是为富人准备的，你知道，
and he doesn't notice the change in public transportation and cars. You know, he really is just just been on autopilot, but has so much power that it can be quite devastating. And he wields that power like a meat ax. So that brings us to the next chapter, which we'll get to after the break. ["The Meat Axe"] Now onto chapter 36, the meat ax, which is quite a name. So I think it's going to be positive. I think that it's going to be a positive chapter,
他没有注意到公共交通和汽车的变化。你知道，他真的只是处于自动驾驶状态，但拥有如此大的权力，以至于它可能是毁灭性的。他像肉斧一样挥舞着那种权力。所以这把我们带到了下一章，我们将在休息后讨论。["肉斧"] 现在进入第36章，肉斧，这真是一个名字。所以我认为这将是积极的。我认为这将是积极的一章，
the meat ax. It's such a, I mean, and he's taking, this is something it's, you will see at the end of the chapter, this is from a quote from Moses, this phrase, the meat ax, but it's such a horrifying sounding thing and it's like a cleaver right but it sounds like to say like a meat cleaver a butcher knife feels so much less terrifying than the meat axe like you shouldn't be hitting a meat with an axe that's that's that's not what that should be it's this it's so frightening so going yeah going into this chapter Roman you were like oh the, the meat acts, this is going to
肉斧。这真是一个，我的意思是，他正在采取，这是某件事，你会在本章末尾看到，这是来自摩西的一句引语，这个短语，肉斧，但这听起来太可怕了，它就像一把切肉刀，对吧，但它听起来像说一把切肉刀，一把屠刀感觉比肉斧恐怖得多，你不应该用斧头砍肉，那不是那应该有的样子，这太可怕了，所以去，是的，进入这一章，罗曼，你就像，哦，肉斧，这将是
be more about the cooking at this restaurant. No, sir, it's not. So at the beginning of the chapter, there's something Caro's doing here that it felt a little interesting to me that he's doing it now. We're 837 pages into the book, and only now is Caro kind of comparing Moses' roads to the great roads of history, which, as we said in the last chapter, it's time about all this dirt was moved. He's compared to the Pharaohs before.
更多关于这家餐厅的烹饪。不，先生，不是。所以在本章开头，卡罗在这里做了一些事情，我觉得这对我来说有点意思，他现在正在做。我们已经读了837页，直到现在卡罗才将摩西的道路与历史上的伟大道路进行比较，正如我们在上一章所说，是时候移动所有这些泥土了。他之前被比作法老。
And only now is he talking about roads, historical roads. And the reason is this chapter is kind of the first of like a trilogy of chapters that form a sort of sub book within this book that all kind of go together as one, you call it, maybe it's one episode, you know, of the Power Broker TV show. And to do that, he wants to give you a set he's going taking that idea of Moses as this world historical urban figure, and transitioning it to
直到现在他才谈论道路，历史道路。原因在于这一章是某种三部曲的第一章，构成了这本书内的一个子书，它们都像一个整体一样结合在一起，你称之为，也许它是一集，你知道，权力掮客电视节目。为了做到这一点，他想给你一套，他正在采取摩西作为这个世界历史城市人物的想法，并将其过渡到
a much smaller human level. And so he starts talking about how Moses is roads compared to the Royal Road of Persia, which is 1500 miles or the Silk Road Road or the ancient Roman highways. And he says the people building these roads, you know, thousands of years ago, they had to deal with bad terrain, bad weather. He doesn't only mention the primitive technology, but they did not face the major complication that Robert Moses faced in New York. And he says it this way. in New York. And he says it this way. They did not have to evict from their homes tens of thousands of protesting voters, demolish those homes, tunnel under or cut across subways and elevated railroads, sewers and water mains and gas mains and telephone and electric conduits
一个更小的人类层面。所以他开始谈论摩西的道路与波斯的皇家大道相比，那是1500英里，或者丝绸之路，或者古罗马公路。他说建造这些道路的人，你知道，几千年前，他们不得不处理糟糕的地形、糟糕的天气。他不仅提到了原始技术，但他们没有面临罗伯特·摩西在纽约面临的主要复杂情况。他是这样说的。在纽约。他是这样说的。他们不必将成千上万的抗议选民从家中驱逐出去，拆除这些房屋，在地铁和高架铁路、下水道和水管、煤气管道和电话及电力管道下挖掘或穿过
and cables, all of which providing a city with essential services had to be kept in operation during construction. They did not have to solve these problems in space almost unbearably constricted, because to obtain a single extra foot of width would require additional thousands of evictions. So he's saying, this is the difference with a Moses road is it is being carved through a living city. And the consequence of that is what we're gonna be looking
和电缆，所有这些为城市提供基本服务的设施在施工期间都必须保持运行。他们不必在几乎无法忍受的狭窄空间内解决这些问题，因为获得额外的一英尺宽度就需要额外成千上万次的驱逐。所以他说，这就是摩西道路的区别，它是在一个活生生的城市中开辟出来的。而这带来的后果就是我们接下来几章将要看到的
at in a small scale example in these next couple of chapters. And he points out how the roads built in ancient cities, they were much smaller and mostly they weren't meant for cars. They're meant for people. They're meant for horses, goats probably too, probably goats and probably cows too. But these are highways. These are built for cars and trucks. The people building the Silk Road, the Roman roads, they didn't have to deal with that stuff. And so now in 1945, Moses is planning to build these enormous superhighways straight through the heart of the most densely populated city in the United States. He's going to build more
小规模例子。他指出古代城市建造的道路，它们要小得多，而且大多不是为汽车准备的。它们是为人们准备的。它们是为马、山羊准备的，可能还有牛。但这些是高速公路。这些是为汽车和卡车建造的。建造丝绸之路、罗马道路的人，他们不必处理那些东西。所以现在在1945年，摩西计划在美利坚合众国人口最稠密的城市中心建造这些巨大的超级公路。他将建造更多
superhighway miles in this one city than up to that point had ever been built in all the cities of the world in human history. This new like massive form of road for motorized intense vehicles. And he's gonna do it through New York City, and a city that never sleeps. You can't even do it while people are sleeping and they don't notice, because it never sleeps. And as much as that passage talks about like the cables and the wires and the tunnels and this stuff,
超级公路英里，在这个城市里，比到那时为止在人类历史上所有城市中建造的都要多。这种新的像机动车辆密集的道路形式。他要在纽约市建造它，一个不夜城。你甚至不能在人们睡觉时做，他们没注意到，因为它从不睡觉。尽管那段话谈到了电缆、电线、隧道和这些东西，
what the real problem here is that people live on this land. The final word is evictions. And that's pretty much what the next couple chapters is about, is about the number of evictions required to do the work that Moses feels is necessary. And we should mention, of course, that the story of America is the story of building things on lands where people have to be evicted,
这里真正的问题是人们住在这片土地上。最后一个词是驱逐。这基本上就是接下来几章的内容，关于摩西认为必要的工作所需的驱逐数量。我们当然应该提到，美国的故事是在人们必须被驱逐的土地上建造东西的故事，
because there were already people living on it. But he's gonna start by talking about there's the seven mile cross Bronx Expressway, which we've mentioned on the show before. And if you've never driven on it, it's essentially a trench gouged through the Bronx. When you're driving through it, you look up and you see there's apartment buildings on either side. You're right through the middle of the city you're right through the middle of the city. And it's going to be disruptive, they're going to destroy hundreds of buildings, half of them apartment buildings, but they're going to have to also, as I said, gouge this, this trench through the city, this enormous trench
因为那里已经有人住在上面了。但他将从谈论七英里的跨布朗克斯高速公路开始，我们之前在节目中提到过。如果你从来没有开过它，它本质上是一条在布朗克斯挖出的沟渠。当你开车穿过它时，你抬头看，你会看到两边都是公寓楼。你就在城市中间，你就在城市中间。它将具有破坏性，他们将摧毁数百座建筑物，其中一半是公寓楼，但他们也必须，正如我所说，在城市中挖出这条沟渠，这条巨大的沟渠
without disturbing all the things that keep the city moving, they're gonna have to cross the Grand Concourse, which is the major thoroughfare of the borough. And you can't, like shut the road down for the years it's going to take to build this thing. They're going to have to dig under it. There's only one problem with digging under the streets of New York. That's where the subway lives. Did you forget there's a train underneath there?
在不打扰所有让城市运转的东西的情况下，他们将不得不穿过大广场，这是该区的主要干道。你不能，像关闭道路几年去建造这个东西。他们将不得不从下面挖掘。在纽约街道下挖掘只有一个问题。那是地铁所在的地方。你忘了下面有火车吗？
So they have to go under the subway, which means blasting through the rock that is so the reason New York can exist is because it's on this incredibly hard rock foundation and they're gonna have to blast through that and it's a lot of this chapter is about the technical difficulty of building this road and then on top of that, Caro's gonna layer this this even more important layer of the people on top of that road and while they're doing it there's no wiggle room. They're gonna have to like be blasting through rock and digging a trench underneath train tracks that they need to keep up and not shake too much. And they're also building through areas where Moses is already building other roads at the same time. Like Carol makes this whole thing sound impossible. It's like an impossible feat of engineering. Yeah. This is one of those sections where, you know, what Caro covers in a couple of paragraphs
所以他们必须从地铁下面走，这意味着炸开岩石，这是纽约之所以能存在的原因，因为它建立在这个极其坚硬的岩石基础上，他们将不得不炸开它，这一章的很多内容是关于建造这条道路的技术难度，除此之外，卡罗还要加上这一层更重要的道路上的人，当他们这样做时，没有回旋余地。他们将不得不像在火车轨道下炸开岩石和挖掘沟渠，他们需要保持运行且不能震动太大。他们还在摩西同时建造其他道路的区域进行建设。就像卡罗让这一切听起来不可能。这就像一项不可能的工程壮举。是的。这是其中一个部分，你知道，卡罗在几段中涵盖的内容
represents an enormous amount of research. It is just mind boggling. Having to like often tell stories in this vein, the fact that he just sort of dashes off like the type of rock and the distance and the time and the grading and like all the different alternates and everything about it is just a stunning amount of work. When I read this, just having covered this type of stuff
代表了大量的研究。这简直令人难以置信。不得不像经常讲述这个方向的故事，他只是草草写下岩石类型、距离、时间和坡度，以及所有不同的替代方案和关于它的一切，这简直是令人震惊的工作量。当我读到这个时，只是涵盖了这类事情
for now a decade and a half. That's an old infrastructure reporter hand, yeah. Like seven years doesn't seem like enough time to write this book, to tell you the truth. that in and of itself would have taken weeks or months of just like getting the details Right is it kind of blows my mind and then have to synthesize it into a very short amount of space because For all that work the reader is not gonna want to read a whole chapter about the type of rock that that they've got to do like it's you're right, it's an enormous amount of it's I hadn't even thought about that.
现在已经十五年了。那是一位老基础设施记者，是的。就像七年时间写这本书似乎不够，说实话。这本身就需要几周或几个月的时间来把细节弄对，这让我感到震惊，然后必须将其合成到一个非常短的空间里，因为尽管做了所有这些工作，读者也不会想读一整章关于他们必须做的岩石类型，就像，你是对的，这是巨大的，我甚至没想过这一点。
How much, cause I, so much of the research in my mind about this book is. Him interviewing people and him going through documents. And yet there's so much in just knowledge that he needs about how the city operates even without Moses and things like that, but they, they've got to do all this crazy stuff. They've got to jack up the rapid transit train line, like three tenths of an inch at a time, cause the trains are still running on the line as they're jacking it up.
多少，因为我，关于这本书的研究在我的脑海中大部分是。他采访人们，他查阅文件。然而，即使没有摩西，他关于城市如何运作的知识也有很多，诸如此类，但他们，他们必须做所有这些疯狂的事情。他们必须一次将快速交通火车线路顶起十分之三英寸，因为当他们顶起它时，火车仍然在轨道上运行。
And they have to, he talks about how the job is so difficult that they have to move a river 500 feet. And that's one of the things nobody bothers talking about afterwards, because it's one of the smaller things they had to do. They're building these enormous interchanges for connecting the expressways. There's barely enough room for the road,
他们必须，他谈到这项工作是多么困难，以至于他们必须将一条河流移动500英尺。这是事后没人费心谈论的事情之一，因为这是他们必须做的较小的事情之一。他们正在为连接高速公路建造这些巨大的立交桥。几乎没有足够的空间给道路，
let alone the machines and the workers that have to build it. They've got to design new equipment. They have to use handmade steel reinforcements because the steel has to be shaped so precisely. And this is just one of 13 expressways that Moses is building throughout the city. This is seven miles out of 130 miles of Moses City Expressway. And the other expressways are not easier. Like the Van Wick Expressway, they have to hold up the Long Island Railroad's 13-track switching yard up in the air. Carlos says it's the busiest stretch of railroad in the world. They have to hold it in the air for seven months, steady, so the trains can run through it while they're building a road underneath it. It's so,
更不用说必须建造它的机器和工人了。他们必须设计新设备。他们必须使用手工制作的钢筋，因为钢必须精确地成型。这只是摩西在整个城市建造的13条高速公路之一。这是摩西城市高速公路130英里中的7英里。其他高速公路并不容易。比如范威克高速公路，他们必须在空中支撑长岛铁路的13条轨道调车场。卡罗说这是世界上最繁忙的铁路路段。他们必须在空中支撑它七个月，稳定，这样火车可以在他们建造下面的道路时通过它。这太，
it's phenomenal. And he says the roads cost at least $10 million per mile to build. And this is in the 40s and 50s. And he says the total cost to all 10 million dollars per mile to build and this is in the 40s and 50s and He says the total cost to all the roads Moses built in the city after World War two is over two billion dollars It's just it's astonishing. Just the resources going into this because the thing they're doing is is bonkers It's amazing. I have this one little piece detail. This is not in the text at all This is just something that I happened to me when I was in Milan This is not in the text at all. This is just something that happened to me when I was in Milan.
太惊人了。他说这些道路每英里至少耗资1000万美元。这是在40和50年代。他说所有1000万美元每英里建造，这是在40和50年代。他说摩西在二战后在城市建造的所有道路的总成本超过20亿美元。这简直令人震惊。仅仅是投入到这里的资源，因为他们正在做的事情是疯狂的。太神奇了。我有一个小细节。这根本不在文本中，这只是我碰巧在米兰时发生的事情。这根本不在文本中，这只是我碰巧在米兰时发生的事情。
You know, they have all these- Must be nice, all right, okay, sure. They have all these beautiful things in Milan and the Duomo in Milan and the sort of Piazza Duomo is there and it's gorgeous and it's this sort of gothic cathedral there and it had been there obviously a long time and they started to build the subway underneath it.
你知道，他们有所有这些——一定很好，好吧，好的，当然。他们在米兰有所有这些美丽的东西，米兰大教堂和米兰大教堂广场在那里，它很华丽，它是那种哥特式大教堂，它显然已经在那里很长时间了，他们开始在它下面建造地铁。
And so my favorite detail, and amongst all this like amazing filigree and amazing, you know, statuary. It's a very pointy building. I'm looking at it now, it's very pointy. It's super pointy, it has lots of details in it, but it has these things up called little noses and they're these little bulbous things
所以我最喜欢的细节，在所有这些令人惊叹的装饰和令人惊叹的，你知道，雕像中。这是一座非常尖的建筑。我现在看着它，它非常尖。它超级尖，它有很多细节，但它上面有这些东西叫小鼻子，它们是这些小球状的东西
and they were put on the columns and they were like a little stone bulb, like a little nose that sticks out and it had a piece of glass inside. Think of it like a laboratory slide, you know, a microscope slide. And they put it in there because if they found that the subway tunneling broke the glass inside the slide,
它们被放在柱子上，它们就像一个小石球，就像一个突出来的小鼻子，里面有一块玻璃。把它想象成实验室载玻片，你知道，显微镜载玻片。他们把它放进去，因为如果他们发现地铁隧道打破了载玻片里的玻璃，
they would stop and reinforce everything. And so it was like a little check against destroying these like amazing old artifacts. And that's what I think of when I think about them trying to build all this stuff underneath all this other stuff that's already built, you know. Anyway, that's a little detail of the world. It's a little 99% invisible detail.
他们会停下来加固一切。所以这就像是对摧毁这些令人惊叹的古老文物的小检查。这就是当我想到他们试图在所有这些已经建好的东西下面建造所有这些东西时，我所想到的，你知道。总之，那是世界的一个小细节。这是一个小小的99%隐形细节。
Now I can write off my trip to Italy. When I go someday, I'm gonna be looking for those. And if I don't see them, I'll be like texting you, I'll be like, Roman, where did I find them? But they're called the little noses. And they're to sniff out whether there was too much seismic activity because of digging underneath these sort of national treasures.
现在我可以报销我的意大利之行了。当我有一天去的时候，我会寻找那些。如果我没看到它们，我会像发短信给你，我会说，罗曼，我在哪里找到它们？但它们被称为小鼻子。它们是为了嗅出是否有太多的地震活动，因为在这些国家宝藏下面挖掘。
That's amazing. I wanna believe that Moses was putting that kind of care into the things above him, but I have trouble believing it. I have trouble imagining it. And Carol, he loves to talk about, I think he really enjoys talking about the scale of all these things. And the one thing I want to mention is how he talks about how the Verrazano narrows bridge, it's the longest suspension bridge in the world at the time. He goes, it's towers so far apart that in designing them allowance had to be made for the curvature of the earth. Like he's just like,
太神奇了。我想相信摩西在上面的东西上投入了那种关心，但我很难相信。我很难想象它。卡罗，他喜欢谈论，我想他真的很喜欢谈论所有这些东西的规模。我想提到的唯一一件事是他如何谈论韦拉扎诺海峡大桥，它是当时世界上最长的悬索桥。他说，它的塔架相距如此之远，以至于在设计它们时必须考虑地球的曲率。就像他只是说，
this is big, this is big, big stuff, big stuff. And he's, he's got the people to do it. Most of his engineers, they're up to the task. His staff is all about getting through red tape, the office is working nonstop. When they need permissions for things, they will bother any city official, they'll call them at midnight, they will show up at a Broadway show that someone is attending and make them sign it in the dark at their seat. They get all this money they have, they put through this $500 million bond issue,
这很大，这是大，大的东西，大的东西。而且他，他有做这件事的人。他的大多数工程师，他们能胜任这项任务。他的员工都是关于通过繁文缛节，办公室在不停地工作。当他们需要许可时，他们会打扰任何城市官员，他们会在午夜给他们打电话，他们会出现在某人正在参加的百老汇演出中，让他们在黑暗中在座位上签字。他们得到所有这些钱，他们通过了5亿美元的债券发行，
and that's still enough money. They've got to wait for the 1956 federal and interstate highway act, and then Moses has to lobby them to put in a provision allowing toll roads to be eligible so we can get some of that money. And Caro says, I love this line, he goes, there were other minor but irritating inconveniences, wars, for example, the Korean conflict was a source of real irritation. And it's like, almost as cares about is his stuff. So they're like, well, we need this steel for the war effort to make sure that communism doesn't overrun South Korea. And he's like, I don't care. And he's lobbying the federal government. They let him use 10% of the entire civilian supply of steel for the country is just for his stuff.
那仍然是足够的钱。他们必须等待1956年的联邦和州际公路法案，然后摩西必须游说他们加入一项允许收费公路有资格的条款，这样我们才能得到一些钱。卡罗说，我喜欢这一行，他说，还有其他次要但令人恼火的不便，战争，例如，朝鲜冲突是一个真正的刺激来源。这就像，几乎像卡罗关心的是他的东西。所以他们就像，好吧，我们需要这些钢材用于战争努力，以确保共产主义不会占领韩国。而他就像，我不在乎。他正在游说联邦政府。他们让他使用全国整个民用钢材供应量的10%仅仅用于他的东西。
And he's like, that's not enough. And he starts attacking them in the media till they give him more. It's really amazing. And he's doing a similar thing of making deals with different power areas in the city to get land and things. I'll trade the Catholic church a little bit of land here so they can have some land there. I'll do that with Con Ed. And he makes the city feel like it's a giant Rubik's cube that he can just manipulate and change in different ways. He's moving buildings everywhere just because he can. And it's, he seems to have a real joy of the power
而他就像，那还不够。他开始在媒体上攻击他们，直到他们给他更多。这真的很神奇。他正在做类似的事情，与城市中的不同权力领域达成交易以获得土地和东西。我会和天主教会交换一点土地，这样他们就可以在那里拥有一些土地。我会和联合爱迪生公司那样做。他让城市感觉就像一个巨大的魔方，他可以随意操纵和改变。他到处移动建筑物，仅仅因为他可以。而且，他似乎有一种真正的权力快乐
of being able to manipulate these enormous physical masses, the way that he wants them to be manipulated. Yeah. And because he does it so often, he still revels in his ability to sort of come up with a solution of like turning a church 90 degrees so it fits on a lot or whatever. But also because he does it so much, when he really bungles it, he kind of doesn't care.
能够操纵这些巨大的物理质量，按照他想要的方式操纵它们。是的。因为他经常这样做，他仍然陶醉于他能够想出一个解决方案，比如将教堂旋转90度，这样它就能适合地块等等。但也因为他做得太多了，当他真的搞砸时，他有点不在乎。
He just kind of laughs it off and just like, oh, that was a real boner. I didn't get that one right. But he doesn't care because he does it so much. You just get used to that type of failure. And for him, it matters nothing for his overall goal. He really treats the city, the real city people live in, as if it is a model that he is.
他只是有点一笑置之，就像，哦，那真是一个笨拙的错误。我没弄对那个。但他不在乎，因为他做得太多了。你只是习惯了那种失败。对他来说，这对他的总体目标毫无影响。他真的把城市，人们居住的真实城市，当作一个模型，他
He is able to move around and change things like that. It's really, it's amazing. And who wouldn't want that power? I mean, that's literally, it's the fantasy of children everywhere is to have a play city that you can move around and control the fantasy of children everywhere is to, you know, have a play city that you can, you know, move around and control the people of. So really, I guess you could say Moses is just young at heart. Anyway, the biggest problem he has though, and this is where we're going to go from kind of the awe of what Moses can do and being like, eh, he's kind of a stinker, but look at what he's accomplishing to the real problem at heart of it, which
能够四处移动和改变东西。这真的很神奇。谁不想拥有那种权力呢？我的意思是，这字面上，这是到处孩子们的幻想，拥有一个你可以四处移动和控制的玩具城市，到处孩子们的幻想是，你知道，拥有一个你可以，你知道，四处移动和控制人们的玩具城市。所以真的，我想你可以说摩西只是童心未泯。总之，他面临的最大问题，这就是我们将从摩西能做什么的敬畏，以及像，呃，他有点讨厌，但看看他正在完成什么，转向核心的真正问题，这
is his real problem isn't the physical difficulties, it's bureaucracy and it's politics. And Caro says, these great roads that I mentioned earlier, the Roman roads, the Persian roads, the Silk roads, the Autobahn in Germany, those were not built by democracies. Those were built by kings, those were built by Führers. A totalitarian government can say, all of our money is going to a big road
是他的真正问题不是物理困难，而是官僚主义和政治。卡罗说，我之前提到的这些伟大的道路，罗马道路，波斯道路，丝绸之路，德国的高速公路，那些不是由民主国家建造的。那些是由国王建造的，那些是由元首建造的。极权政府可以说，我们所有的钱都将用于一条大路
that's gonna go through your house and you have to deal with it. But in a democratic society, people need to agree that a work of this impact is worth the expense, is worth the impact. And some people might see a need for this road, but a lot of people might not. And nobody I think is ever like,
那条路会穿过你的房子，你必须去面对它。但在民主社会中，人们需要达成共识，即一项具有如此影响力的工程是否值得付出代价，是否值得产生这种影响。有些人可能认为这条路有必要，但很多人可能并不这么认为。而且我想没人会说，
I believe in this road so much that I don't want a house anymore. I don't wanna live here. I will give up my house for this. Yeah, yeah. And this is his big impediment is democracy. And he, again, we have to get to this point. He has never been elected at all.
我如此坚信这条路，以至于我不再想要房子了。我不想住在这里了。我愿意为了它放弃我的房子。是啊，是啊。这就是他面临的最大障碍——民主。而且，我们必须再次强调这一点，他从未经过任何选举。
He is not really that big of a friend to democracy. But like he had to solve the problem of, you know, the democratic process slowing him down. And basically he says that Moses solved it by ignoring democracy. Yeah, it's not that he never takes people you know, the democratic process slowing him down. And basically he says that Moses solved it by ignoring democracy. Yeah, it's not that he never takes people into consideration.
他并不是民主的忠实拥护者。但他必须解决民主进程拖慢他进度的问题。他基本上说摩西通过无视民主解决了这个问题。是的，并不是说他从不考虑人们的感受，而是说民主进程拖慢了他的进度。他基本上说摩西通过无视民主解决了这个问题。是的，并不是说他从不考虑人们的感受。
Sometimes he will move a building rather than destroying it. Although as we know, he seems to love moving buildings. So there's a little joy in that. But if he cannot do that, and it's a choice between the project and people in the way of the project, he will always choose the project, always. And Carol says that Moses took people into consideration mostly by enjoying
有时他会选择搬迁建筑物而不是拆毁它。尽管我们知道，他似乎很喜欢搬迁建筑物。所以这其中有一点乐趣。但如果他做不到这一点，且必须在工程和挡路的人之间做出选择，他总是会选择工程，永远如此。卡罗说，摩西考虑人们的方式主要是通过享受
the act of imposing his will on them. And Carol tells the story of Moses driving somewhere and, or not right, being driven somewhere and stumbling on an anti-Moses demonstration and just sitting there laughing and laughing and watching the whole thing and laughing at it. And I have to assume it is the laughter of someone who knows these people are mad at me and they can't do a thing about it.
将自己的意志强加于人的过程。卡罗讲述了摩西开车去某处，或者说，被人开车送去某处，偶然遇到一场反摩西的示威活动，他只是坐在那里大笑不止，看着这一切并嘲笑它。我不得不认为，这是一个知道这些人对他很生气，却又拿他无可奈何的人的笑声。
It does not matter. And Carol quotes Moses saying that to build a metropolis, quote, you have to hack your way with a meat ax. And so Carol says the meat ax metaphor, quote, expressed his philosophy, but it was not philosophy, but feelings that dictated Moses actions. He didn't just feel that he had to swing a meat ax,
这无关紧要。卡罗引用摩西的话说，要建造一座大都市，引用：“你必须用屠刀杀出一条血路。”所以卡罗说，屠刀的比喻，引用：“表达了他的哲学，但支配摩西行动的不是哲学，而是情感。”他不仅觉得他必须挥舞屠刀，
he loved to swing it. Wow, there you go. And that's the chapter meat ax. In the end, they deliver what the meat ax is all about. He likes wielding it. Which brings us to probably the most consequential chapter, I think, in the whole book. It's called One Mile.
他喜欢挥舞它。哇，就是这样。这就是“屠刀”那一章。最后，他们揭示了屠刀的真正含义。他喜欢挥舞它。这把我们带到了我认为整本书中最重要的一章。它叫“一英里”。
We will cover it after this. ["One Mile"] Okay, up next is chapter 37. It's called One Mile. It is probably the most important chapter of the book. Like, I think it kind of, I don't know how to quantify that sort of stuff, but it's the culmination of everything.
我们稍后会讲到它。["一英里"] 好的，接下来是第37章。它叫“一英里”。这可能是书中最重要的章节。我觉得它有点，我不知道该如何量化这类事情，但它是所有一切的顶点。
And kind of, if I were to sort of boil down to what Robert Caro wanted to do with this whole indictment of Robert Moses, I think this is the chapter that explains most of his motivation. Yes, I agree. I think this chapter really feels like, for Caro, it is the chapter that explains most of his motivation. Yes, I agree. I think this chapter really feels like for Caro, it is the heart of the book. I think the chapter that's closest to his heart, when he talks about writing the book,
而且，如果我要归纳罗伯特·卡罗通过对罗伯特·摩西的全部控诉想要表达什么，我认为这一章解释了他大部分的动机。是的，我同意。我认为这一章对卡罗来说，确实是解释了他大部分动机的章节。是的，我同意。我认为这一章对卡罗来说，确实是这本书的核心。我认为这是他最关心的章节，当他谈到写这本书时，
this is the chapter that he talks about the most, the one he wants to talk about the most. And I agree with you. If you were like, I can't read this whole book, give me one chapter to read it so I get the gist of it. This chapter, in many ways ways kind of says the things that Carol wants to say with the book in, in miniature, in one example, which is to say, you should read the whole book. The whole book is amazing, obviously. But if you were looking at this book in a fractal sense, this
这是他谈论最多、最想谈论的章节。我同意你的看法。如果你说，“我读不完整本书，给我一章读读，让我了解大概内容。”这一章在许多方面以微缩的形式，通过一个例子，说出了卡罗想通过这本书表达的东西，也就是说，你应该读完整本书。整本书显然都很棒。但如果你从分形的角度来看这本书，这一
chapter is, is his purpose and is the intention of the book in miniature and it opens with such simplicity. It says Robert Moses built 627 miles of roads in and around New York City. This is the story of one of those miles. And from that point, he is bringing you to such a personal level about the effect of Robert Moses' work that I remember reading this chapter for the first time, and it was one of the many times I read the book where I got really mad. I got viscerally very angry about what was happening. And these are things that happened before my parents were born.
章就是他的目的，是这本书的微缩意图，而且它以极其简洁的方式开篇。它说：罗伯特·摩西在纽约市及其周边建造了627英里的道路。这是其中一英里的故事。从那时起，他把你带到了一个关于罗伯特·摩西工程影响的极其个人的层面，我记得第一次读这一章时，这是我读这本书时多次感到非常愤怒的时刻之一。我对正在发生的事情感到非常愤怒。而这些事情发生在我父母出生之前。
This is stuff from past history. And yet he manages to make it feel so alive and so vivid and also so contemporary in that these are issues that we're still gonna deal with forever about balancing big needs versus small needs and individual lives versus ideas of the greater good. And it's just a, it's a really amazing chapter and it makes you wish you could kind of step in
这是过去的历史。然而，他设法让它感觉如此鲜活、如此生动，同时也如此具有当代意义，因为这些是我们永远需要面对的问题：平衡大需求与小需求，以及个人生活与更大利益理念之间的关系。这真是一个非常了不起的章节，让你希望自己能介入
and stop it from happening. Yeah, it has that quality to it because you see these moments of like, of where history could have changed and you just really want it to change for these folks. So the chapter really is about one mile and the seven miles of the Cross Bronx Expressway. And he talks about it,
并阻止它发生。是的，它确实有那种特质，因为你看到了历史可能改变的时刻，你真的希望它能为这些人改变。所以这一章确实是关于“一英里”和横贯布朗克斯高速公路的七英里。他谈到了它，
it's this really interesting kind of moment in the beginning, which I don't know if it's even picked up on as much as I would want it to be, but there's this, he's setting the table for this is like, you know, Moses is an engineer that wants to just put roads straight because it's cheaper. Technically not an engineer, Roman. He calls himself an engineer.
在开头有一个非常有趣的时刻，我不知道它是否像我希望的那样被关注到，但他正在铺垫，就像，你知道，摩西是一个工程师，他只想把路修直，因为这样更便宜。严格来说他不是工程师，罗曼。他自称是工程师。
He's technically not. That's right. No training. That's right. No training engineer. But basically, you know, that straight line crazy, that idea that a straight line is the perfect way to solve and cut through these things.
他严格来说不是。没错。没有受过培训。没错。不是受过培训的工程师。但基本上，你知道，那种直线狂热，那种认为直线是解决和切断这些事物的完美方式的想法。
But the cross-box expressway in this one mile has this kind of swerve in it that seems to put it more in the path of more people than is necessary. And it's just a very interesting sort of like the foundation of this whole chapter is this sense that none of this had to happen. Like even if Moses was following his own kind of,
但横贯布朗克斯高速公路在这一英里处有一个弯道，似乎让它比必要地穿过了更多人的路径。这非常有趣，这一章的整个基础在于一种感觉，即这一切本不必发生。就像即使摩西遵循他自己那种，
I don't know, normal behavior or logical sense that all of this tragedy could be avoided. But for some reason he does. I mean, later on we kind of learned maybe the reason that he doesn't. Maybe, but you're right, part of the horror of this chapter is that it seems irrational. Yeah.
我不知道，正常的行为或逻辑感，所有这些悲剧都是可以避免的。但出于某种原因，他还是这么做了。我的意思是，后来我们了解到他这么做的原因。也许吧，但你是对的，这一章的恐怖之处在于它看起来是不合理的。是的。
It seems like, and I feel like this has been, this is often happens in politics nowadays, uh, is that it feels like there are two choices and one of the choices is so incredibly obviously better than the other, and yet it doesn't happen for some reason through some irrational emotional reason or some quirk of the specific
感觉就像，我觉得这在当今的政治中经常发生，就是感觉有两个选择，其中一个选择明显比另一个好得多，但由于某种非理性的情感原因或特定情况的怪癖，它就是没有发生。
situation. And yet through running through, you're right, running through this whole chapter, it's like, there's obviously a better route for this road that would not affect so many people, and he's not taking it. And it's so out of the ordinary for him that he's not, it seems like in this case, it should be a chapter about, in one case, Moses' rules for road building
然而，贯穿这一整章，你是对的，就像，这条路显然有一条更好的路线，不会影响那么多人，但他没有走那条路。这对他来说太不寻常了，似乎在这种情况下，这应该是一章关于，在某种情况下，摩西的筑路规则
also matched up with what was best for the neighborhood. It would go through here across parkland, but he's just not doing it this way. And it's very strange. And so this part of the road, it could go across the top of, was it Crotona Park, I think, but instead it goes north. There's this bulge that takes it through the heart of a neighborhood called East Tremont in the Bronx. And we remember from chapter 25, way back in episode six, he's talking about the neighborhood of Third Avenue in Brooklyn,
也与社区的最佳利益相吻合。它本可以穿过这里，穿过公园用地，但他就是不这么做。这非常奇怪。所以这段路，它本可以穿过克罗托纳公园的顶部，我想，但它却向北延伸。有一个凸起，把它带到了布朗克斯一个叫东特雷蒙特的社区中心。我们记得第25章，早在第六集，他谈到了布鲁克林第三大道的社区，
the one that was destroyed by the elevated highway that went over it. Here, he's kind of talking about this neighborhood in similar terms, kind of what once was there and kind of what a home and a community it was. This is a predominantly Jewish neighborhood. These are the people who were lucky enough to get out of the Lower East Side,
那个被高架公路摧毁的社区。在这里，他以类似的术语谈论这个社区，谈论曾经存在的东西，以及它曾经是一个怎样的家园和社区。这是一个以犹太人为主的社区。这些人是足够幸运能从下东区搬出来的人，
but not successful enough to go to Riverdale or the Grand Concourse, the kind of fancy parts of the Bronx. But here they could find this kind of clean, safe, comfortable, but not luxurious, lower middle class life. These are the Jewish New Yorkers who are still working in the garment trade, but they are saving the money for their kids to go to college so that they can be becoming sconce in the middle class, you know, and he really, I mean, some would see it as some could see it probably as, as I don't know, cloying or kind of sugary, but he really pours it on about what a nice neighborhood it is, you know, how, how easy it is for the people to live there and feel like they're in a community, how you're walkable to the Bronx zoo, the botanic garden.
但又没有成功到能去里弗代尔或大广场，那些布朗克斯的高档地区。但在这里，他们可以找到这种干净、安全、舒适但不奢华的下中产阶级生活。这些犹太裔纽约人仍然在服装行业工作，但他们为孩子存钱上大学，以便他们能跻身中产阶级，你知道，他真的，我的意思是，有些人可能会觉得这，有些人可能会觉得这，我不知道，令人作呕或有点甜腻，但他确实极力描述这是一个多么好的社区，你知道，人们住在那里感觉像在一个社区里是多么容易，步行去布朗克斯动物园、植物园是多么方便。
There's, there's no playgrounds there, but either places to take kids, the elderly people there, they like to sit on benches. They can socialize. There's a couple of generations of people there who are considering it their home, you know, and a lot of this comes from him talking to former residents who are at times I'm like, maybe they're looking at it through rose colored glasses, because if I know anything about, about Jewish neighborhoods, being Jewish and having lived in them, there's a lot of arguments going on and there's a lot of loud yelling, but it's a shabby but
那里没有游乐场，但有带孩子去的地方，那里的老年人喜欢坐在长椅上。他们可以社交。那里有几代人把这里当作自己的家，你知道，很多内容来自他与前居民的交谈，有时我觉得，也许他们戴着玫瑰色的眼镜看它，因为如果我对犹太社区有什么了解的话，作为犹太人并生活在其中，那里有很多争论，有很多大声的叫喊，但这是一个破旧但
safe, secure place. And there's something I want to talk about here that I feel like I think one of the reasons this chapter hits me so hard is me being Jewish and this being a Jewish neighborhood. And I think one of the reasons it hits Caro so hard possibly is because he is also Jewish. And I think people reading this book in 1974 would pick up on the fact that being evicted, being pushed out, trying to find a home and being unable to is very much part of the eternal Jewish experience, but also especially the 20th century Jewish experience. Like this, people reading this book, many of them might have
安全、稳固的地方。这里有一件事我想谈谈，我觉得这一章之所以让我感触如此之深，原因之一是我也是犹太人，而这是一个犹太社区。我认为卡罗感触如此之深的原因之一可能是因为他也是犹太人。我认为1974年读这本书的人会意识到，被驱逐、被赶走、试图寻找家园却无法找到，这在很大程度上是永恒的犹太人经历的一部分，尤其是20世纪的犹太人经历。就像这样，读这本书的人，他们中的许多人可能
experienced, maybe living in New York after having experienced the worst time to be Jewish in the history of the world. And Carol later on, he like is literally quoting dialogue from Fiddler on the Roof. So he really gets, he's really hitting it hard later on. And I wondered if that, I wonder if it hits Gentiles the same way, I don't know. Well, speaking for the Gentile community. Yeah, Roman, I think I've taken on the mantle of Judaism. You tell me what it's like for non-Jews. I mean, I still think it's pretty,
经历过，也许在经历了世界历史上最糟糕的犹太人时期后生活在纽约。卡罗后来甚至直接引用了《屋顶上的提琴手》中的对话。所以他确实在后面重重地打击了这一点。我想知道这是否对非犹太人也有同样的影响，我不知道。嗯，代表非犹太社区发言。是的，罗曼，我想我已经承担了犹太教的重任。你告诉我这对非犹太人来说是什么感觉。我的意思是，我仍然认为它非常，
I still think it's quite accurate. I do think that when you are, you know, in constant culture, those resonances and harmonies and stuff are just built into the stories, which I don't share. But one of the things that Caro does is I think he could make it, he paints a picture that I think anyone can understand. And what he's very clear on is that
我仍然认为它相当准确。我确实认为，当你处于某种文化中时，那些共鸣和和谐等等就内置在故事中，而我没有分享这些。但卡罗所做的事情之一是，我认为他可以做到这一点，他描绘了一幅我认为任何人都能理解的图景。他非常清楚的是，
Moses looks at the same space and views it as tenements and slumps and doesn't see the value in it and doesn't see why you can't just bulldoze it. And having lived mostly in normally shabby places that I considered my home, that I understand., you know, like this thing is like, this means something to me. This is a good place for me
摩西看着同样的空间，将其视为廉租房和贫民窟，看不到它的价值，也不明白为什么不能直接推平它。由于我大部分时间住在被我视为家园的破旧地方，我理解这一点。你知道，这就像，这对我来说意味着什么。这是一个对我来说很好的地方，
that maybe somebody else can't, you know, can't see, you know, like where people think like, oh, this place seems dangerous or, you know, this, you know, like, and it's like, I don't know how to explain it to you, but this is my home. I don't feel fear here. I feel fine here. And that I can certainly relate to.
也许别人看不出来，你知道，就像人们认为，哦，这个地方看起来很危险，或者，你知道，这个，你知道，就像，我不知道该怎么向你解释，但这是我的家。我在这里不感到恐惧。我在这里感觉很好。这一点我当然能感同身受。
And one of the things that when you think about the value of, of what is lost is when he talks about, um, the rents that people are paying. Oh my God. I mean, I was talking about kind of wealth porn in the, in the last chapter. This is the opposite of that, which is low rent porn, which is, they're like, you know, for a four room apartment, this family pays $62 a month. You know, for a six room apartment, this family pays $69 a month.
当你想到所失去的东西的价值时，其中一件事就是他谈到人们支付的租金。天哪。我的意思是，我在上一章谈到了某种财富色情。这是它的反面，也就是低租金色情，他们说，你知道，对于一套四居室公寓，这个家庭每月支付62美元。你知道，对于一套六居室公寓，这个家庭每月支付69美元。
And like, and this is in the Bronx, it's not in the heart of the, you know, ritzy parts of the city, but you just read it and you're like, oh man, why can't I go back in time with like regular money from now? And cause I, when I first had my first apartment in New York, this was in 2002 and I lived on first street and Avenue A and it was two bedrooms and a kitchenette
而且，这还是在布朗克斯，不是在城市的高档地区，但你读到它时，你会想，天哪，为什么我不能带着现在的钱回到过去？因为当我第一次在纽约拥有自己的公寓时，那是在2002年，我住在第一街和A大道，那是两居室带一个小厨房，
and there were three of us in it. And it cost us all together 14.75 a month. And so I was paying, you know, 4.25 a month. And at the time I was like, oh no, not 4.25, a little more than 4.25 a month. And I was like, what a steal. This is amazing. So to read it and be like, oh my God,
我们三个人住在里面。总共每月1475美元。所以我付了，你知道，每月425美元。当时我觉得，哦不，不是425，比425多一点。我当时想，真是太划算了。这太棒了。所以读到它时，就像，天哪，
less than $70 a month for these enormous apartments. It's just, I mean, I guess you just have to keep it in the context of the times that this is also the late 40s, early 50s. But he does give the average wage. And when you compare them, it's kind of like, it seems to equate to maybe one week of a month's worth of wage to pay for that apartment,
这些巨大的公寓每月不到70美元。这只是，我的意思是，我想你必须把它放在那个时代的背景下，这也是40年代末、50年代初。但他确实给出了平均工资。当你比较它们时，似乎相当于一个月工资的一周左右来支付那套公寓，
which is still like a pretty good ratio. That's a healthier ratio than most people have to deal with in most cities. And it's really, to think when you lose that, it's not like you just lose a location and you can go somewhere else. What you lose is the opportunity to ever have a place with that lower rent ever again.
这仍然是一个相当不错的比例。这比大多数城市中大多数人必须面对的比例要健康得多。而且，真的，想到当你失去它时，这不仅仅是失去了一个地点，你可以去别的地方。你失去的是永远无法再拥有那种低租金住所的机会。
Like they'll never be able to get back on that same train that they were on if they get off here when their apartment is destroyed. These are families where their finances are so precise. Like what they're paying for this apartment is what they, yeah, what they can afford to pay. And Kara talks about, if you're a woman with a family, maybe your husband gets sick and misses a little bit of work,
就像如果他们在这里下车，当他们的公寓被摧毁时，他们将永远无法回到他们曾经乘坐的那列火车上。这些家庭的财务状况非常精确。就像他们为这套公寓支付的钱就是他们，是的，他们负担得起的钱。卡罗谈到，如果你是一个有家庭的妇女，也许你的丈夫生病了，错过了一点工作，
now you can't afford the rent. And you slide back down to the Lower East Side to where the true tenements are. Like they, it's not like the people living in the apartments are like, these apartments are so cheap, look at all the money we have to spend on other things now. Like this is what their level is. And so yeah, if they, these apartments are so cheap. Look at all the money we have to spend on other things now. Like this is what their level is.
现在你就付不起房租了。然后你滑回下东区，回到真正的廉租房那里。就像他们，并不是说住在公寓里的人觉得，这些公寓太便宜了，看看我们现在有多少钱可以花在其他事情上。就像这就是他们的水平。所以是的，如果他们，这些公寓太便宜了。看看我们现在有多少钱可以花在其他事情上。就像这就是他们的水平。
And so yeah, if they lose these apartments, they're losing a standard of living and they're losing a community that they cannot ever find again, for the most part. Yeah, yeah. So this part of the story when Carol was talking about this neighborhood is where some of it in the sort of language of the prose
所以是的，如果他们失去了这些公寓，他们就失去了一种生活水平，也失去了一个他们大部分情况下再也找不到的社区。是的，是的。所以当卡罗谈论这个社区时，故事的这一部分是其中一些在散文语言上
gives me pause, like in some of it in the sort of language of the prose gives me pause. Like in sort of like exalting in the greatness of this easy to live in, cheap neighborhood that has a good community, a strong community. He basically puts that against a neighborhood that is failing because of blight, an urban blight, and uses words like slums. And there's something about the way that he's presenting
让我停顿的地方，就像其中一些在散文语言上让我停顿。就像在某种程度上赞美这个容易居住、廉价、拥有良好社区、强大社区的社区的伟大。他基本上把它与一个因为衰败、城市衰败而失败的社区进行了对比，并使用了“贫民窟”这样的词。关于他呈现的方式，有一些东西
of why this works, so this sort of like the backbone of this Jewish community knows how to take care of its neighborhood and that there's this other community nearby which does not, which I do not think, I feel like having read this book and several other books by Robert Caro and talked to him and know, like I know his heart as a progressive and person who cares about the oppressed, but the language of this does not comport with how I would like people to talk about underserved neighborhoods today.
为什么这有效，所以这种犹太社区的骨干知道如何照顾它的社区，而附近有另一个社区却不知道，我不认为，我觉得读过这本书和罗伯特·卡罗的其他几本书，并与他交谈过，知道，就像我知道他作为一个进步人士和关心被压迫者的人的心，但这种语言与我希望人们今天谈论服务不足的社区的方式不符。
Yeah, I agree. He talks about the idea that there are neighborhoods to the south of the park that are, yeah, slum neighborhoods. And there's this constant fear and also struggle to hold back the blight of those neighborhoods from moving up through the park to this neighborhood, turning it from no longer being kind of like a good poor neighborhood into a bad poor neighborhood.
是的，我同意。他谈到了公园南面有贫民窟社区的想法。并且有一种持续的恐惧，以及努力阻止那些社区的衰败穿过公园蔓延到这个社区，使它不再是一个好的贫困社区，而变成一个坏的贫困社区。
And in doing that, he definitely speaks about blight and slums and as almost as if they were, it's a, you get the sense it's almost like this kind of inhuman, evil fog or like stain that can spread and engulf other things. And there's, it's hard to read it now and not feel a racial element to it, a class element to it, a class element to it. Things that I think were even at the time, we're still baked in, but are at cross purpose to, I agree how the, the sense I have of Robert Caro's own beliefs and his own feelings.
在这样做时，他确实谈到了衰败和贫民窟，几乎就好像它们是，你感觉到它几乎就像这种非人的、邪恶的雾气或污点，可以蔓延并吞噬其他事物。现在读起来很难不感到其中有一种种族因素、阶级因素。我认为这些东西即使在当时也是根深蒂固的，但与我所理解的罗伯特·卡罗自己的信仰和感受背道而驰。
And I wonder if it's more a matter of, um, which is rare for him, kind of like insensitivity to the specifics of the language he's using, uh, rather than a real intention to label the people who are in those situations as trouble. But he'll talk about like vagrants and things like that. And there is a real sense in the, in those passages that he is talking about kind of like worthy people and unworthy people, you know, which is, which is a painful thing to read. Like every, when you read it, you get a twinge of like, Oh, I don't,
我想知道这是否更多是一个问题，对他来说很少见，即对所用语言的具体细节缺乏敏感性，而不是真正打算将处于这些情况中的人贴上麻烦的标签。但他会谈论流浪者之类的事情。在那些段落中，确实有一种感觉，他在谈论某种值得尊重的人和不值得尊重的人，你知道，这读起来是一件痛苦的事情。就像每一个，当你读到它时，你会感到一阵刺痛，就像，哦，我不，
I don't like that. That's not good. Yeah. But I think the reason why there's some, there's some dehumanizing sense of it is I think he does dehumanize it as a condition. Like he's not saying that poor people are wrong or a certain type of poor people is wrong. He's saying like the, the sin here is poverty in general, but the language is I think, it's just imprecise here. Like you have to imagine when this book is being published in 1974. Happy birthday, 50 years.
我不喜欢那样。那不好。是的。但我认为之所以有一种非人化的感觉，是因为我认为他将其非人化为一种状况。他并不是说穷人是错的，或者某种类型的穷人是错的。他是说，这里的罪恶是普遍的贫困，但我认为语言在这里是不精确的。就像你必须想象这本书在1974年出版时。生日快乐，50周年。
Exactly. But the idea that urban blight is this monster that could take over and swallow New York, a la escape from New York. Yeah. Or Hedora the smog monster from Godzilla versus the smog monster. Yeah. Is a way that people thought about things and is very prominent. And he's probably speaking to these things. He's like, you cannot think of this as a plighted poor neighborhood that is not functional. This is a good neighborhood, even is a good neighborhood even though it's poor. And he's trying to make that point. And I think in making that point, he commits, I think some sort of dismissal of these other poor neighborhoods that are not as worthy of preservation or care or lifting up and
正是如此。但城市衰败是这种可能接管并吞噬纽约的怪物的想法，就像《纽约大逃亡》一样。是的，或者《哥斯拉对阵烟雾怪》中的烟雾怪。是的，这是人们思考事物的一种方式，而且非常突出。他可能是在谈论这些事情。他就像，你不能认为这是一个功能不正常的衰败贫困社区。这是一个好的社区，即使它很穷。他试图表达这一点。我认为在表达这一点时，他犯了，我认为某种对其他不值得保护、关心或提升的贫困社区的轻视，以及
whose condition is because of outside forces, not necessarily inside forces and not like just taking a point to recognize that, that, that dysfunction is the fault of people who are not living in it. Yeah. It's not the, not the fault of the residents, but the fault of the people who are making the larger decisions, which I think is the larger message of the book that it's, it's Robert Moses that is, and the people like, and they're doing this, but it in the writing, it does come up. It does, it does start to feel as
其状况是因为外部力量，而不是内部力量，也不是仅仅采取一个观点来认识到，这种功能障碍是那些不生活在其中的人的错。是的。这不是居民的错，而是做出更大决策的人的错，我认为这是这本书更大的信息，即是罗伯特·摩西，以及像他们这样的人，他们在做这件事，但在写作中，它确实出现了。它确实开始感觉
if like there's a barbarians at the gates type, type attitude. Exactly. And I think a lot of that is also in the, that's probably the language of the people who he's interviewing. He's taking on some of that empathically, um, and, uh, and not checking it. I just, it's just something to sort of like to think about here that is worth sort of taking head on versus just letting it go. But I think of this as extremely progressive text. I think of it as a very important text that is about telling the stories and taking care of people who are ignored in history, whereas most people write the history of Robert Moses through the greatness of Robert Moses. That's certainly how he would wish it was written.
好像有一种“野蛮人在门口”的态度。正是如此。我认为其中很多也存在于他采访的人的语言中。他同情地吸收了其中的一些，并且没有去核实它。这只是值得在这里思考的事情，值得正面面对，而不是让它过去。但我认为这是一个极其进步的文本。我认为这是一个非常重要的文本，是关于讲述故事和照顾那些在历史上被忽视的人，而大多数人通过罗伯特·摩西的伟大来书写罗伯特·摩西的历史。这当然是他希望被书写的方式。
And so the overall intent, I think, is just, you know, is super heartfelt and meaningful. But I just have some misgivings about some of the way that this is presented. And I would say mild misgivings about the way that's presented. That's not spicy misgivings. And not to belabor it, but before we were talking about this before recording, Roman Yuma mentioned also, which I had, wasn't even thinking about that. When this book came out, New York was in bad shape. Like New York was in, was in rough, rough shape. So the idea of blight and the city deteriorating and rotting, you know, was
所以总体的意图，我认为，只是，你知道，是超级真诚和有意义的。但我对呈现方式的一些方面有一些疑虑。我会说对呈现方式有轻微的疑虑。那不是激烈的疑虑。而且不是要啰嗦，但在录音前我们谈论过这个，罗曼·尤马也提到了，我当时甚至没想过。当这本书出版时，纽约的情况很糟糕。就像纽约处于，处于非常、非常糟糕的状态。所以衰败和城市恶化、腐烂的想法，你知道，是
something that was very much on people's minds. This was the period when it's, I mean, reading the book, it sounds like New York never had any money to do anything, but this is when New York really didn't have any money. And I think the way that you would describe, if this book was written now with 50 more years of New York's history, it would be a different framing and a different way of looking at it because the city now is so different than the city 50 years ago. I mean, it's kind of amazing. Like the fact that in the subtitle is the fall of New York, I think that's a subtitle that can only exist
人们非常关心的事情。这是那个时期，我的意思是，读这本书，听起来好像纽约从来没有钱做任何事情，但这是纽约真的没有钱的时候。我认为如果你描述的方式，如果这本书现在写，有50年更多的纽约历史，它会有不同的框架和不同的看待方式，因为现在的城市与50年前的城市太不同了。我的意思是，这有点令人惊奇。就像副标题中“纽约的衰落”这一事实，我认为这是一个只能存在于
in this narrow window of a few years. And so, I think that a lot of that discussion has to do with that time that it was published. And the fact that he's really like putting his chips in on like, this is the type of neighborhood East Tremont that should be preserved because of all these sort of connections he feels with it. And the people he's talked to. So anyway, but what he does find when he's there are these folks who,
这几年狭窄窗口期的副标题。所以，我认为很多讨论与它出版的那个时代有关。而且他真的把筹码押在，这就是东特雷蒙特这种应该被保护的社区，因为他与它感受到的所有这些联系。以及他交谈过的人。所以无论如何，但当他在那里时，他发现的是这些人，
because they form these communities in East Tremont, they have a little bit of fight in them to stop this. And this is where a lot of the heartbreak is, is because you get the sense that they could stop this from happening, but they cannot. You get the sense that in a properly functioning democracy, these people would have had their voices heard and been able to save their homes. In the Hollywood movie version of this,
因为他们在东特雷蒙特形成了这些社区，他们有一点战斗力来阻止这一切。这就是很多心碎的地方，因为你感觉到他们本可以阻止这一切发生，但他们不能。你感觉到在一个运作良好的民主国家，这些人本可以听到他们的声音，并能够拯救他们的家园。在好莱坞电影版本中，
they were able to save their homes. Spoiler alert, we'll get to it, nobody saves their homes. But so it starts out, he's talked about, more in general about East Tremont, and then there's like a little space between paragraphs. And then there's this one sentence paragraph which just says, the letters came on December 4th, 1952, one day after my birthday, many years before I was born,
他们能够拯救他们的家园。剧透警告，我们会讲到，没有人拯救他们的家园。所以它开始时，他谈到了，更多关于东特雷蒙特的一般情况，然后段落之间有一点空间。然后有一个单句段落，上面写着：信件于1952年12月4日寄出，在我出生前许多年，我生日后一天，
but still, the East Tremonters, they know there's an expressway coming their way. They've been hearing about it for so long, and it's been so long that nothing has happened that they kind of don't worry about it. It's like climate change. They're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, we've been hearing about it. It'll get to us someday, I guess so.
但即便如此，东特雷蒙特的人们，他们知道有一条高速公路要来了。他们听说了很久了，而且已经过了这么久什么都没发生，以至于他们有点不担心了。这就像气候变化。他们就像，是啊，是啊，是啊，我们听说过。我想总有一天它会轮到我们。
And then they figure, it's obviously gonna go along the edge of the, yeah, we've been hearing about it. It'll get, it'll get to us someday. I guess so. And then they figure this, it's obviously going to go along the edge of the park. That's the best place for it. Like, why wouldn't they put it there? But they get these letters signed by Robert Moses, city construction coordinator saying where they live is needed for the cross Bronx expressway. And they have 90 days to move. And one of the residents, uh, Lillian Edelstein, uh, who will become a major figure in this chapter. She says it was like the floor opened up underneath your feet to get a letter in the mail
然后他们认为，它显然会沿着公园的边缘走，是的，我们听说过。它总有一天会轮到我们。我想是这样。然后他们认为，它显然会沿着公园的边缘走。那是最好的地方。就像，为什么他们不把它放在那里？但他们收到了这些由罗伯特·摩西签署的信件，城市建设协调员说他们居住的地方是横贯布朗克斯高速公路所需要的。他们有90天的时间搬走。其中一位居民，莉莲·埃德尔斯坦，她将成为这一章的主要人物。她说，收到一封信就像地板在你脚下裂开了，
saying, you have 90 days, you have to leave your home. And there's no way to push back against it. And the thing is that deadline, that 90 day deadline is incredibly arbitrary. Moses does not even have the money to get the title to the land yet. He doesn't even have the money to get the title to the land yet. That it's like, he doesn't even have the money to get the land and build on it. And he secretly is like, yeah, it's gonna be about 18 months before the area is gonna be clear of people. But he wants to scare them. He wants to make them feel like it's gotta be done now, get out of here.
说，你有90天的时间，你必须离开你的家。而且没有办法反抗。问题是那个截止日期，那个90天的截止日期是非常武断的。摩西甚至还没有钱获得土地的所有权。他甚至还没有钱获得土地的所有权。就像，他甚至没有钱获得土地并在上面建造。他私下里想，是的，大约需要18个月的时间，该地区的人们才能搬走。但他想吓唬他们。他想让他们觉得必须现在就做，离开这里。
And people panic and they start looking for new apartments. And New York is in this post-World War II housing crunch. A lot of people are returning from the war. There's not a lot of, there hasn't been a lot of construction during the war because all the resources were going to the war and there's not enough places for people to live. So they find, they can't find apartments that they can afford that are anywhere near what they were, have been living in for most of
人们恐慌了，他们开始寻找新的公寓。纽约正处于二战后的住房紧缩期。许多人从战争中回来。没有太多的，战争期间没有太多的建设，因为所有的资源都用于战争，没有足够的地方供人们居住。所以他们发现，他们找不到他们负担得起的公寓，这些公寓在任何地方都接近他们大部分时间居住的地方
their lives. Yeah, yeah. The reason the floor is opening up underneath them is they know like how precarious it is and how good they have it in this one spot and that it will not be replicated anywhere else. Again, this is a weird personal story, but when the twins were born in Chicago, we got kicked out of our apartment and a few weeks after they were born,
他们的生活。是的，是的。地板在他们脚下裂开的原因是他们知道这有多么不稳定，以及他们在这一点上有多么好的条件，而且它不会在任何其他地方被复制。再说一次，这是一个奇怪的个人故事，但当双胞胎在芝加哥出生时，我们被赶出了公寓，在他们出生几周后，
and they didn't kick us out, kick us out. They just took down the fire escape and they began demolishing other parts of the apartment. And I had to move three times in the first year of their life in Chicago. And it is, you feel like you are under siege in these situations and that if you can't rest in your home, it is like a war crime to me.
他们没有把我们赶出去，赶出去。他们只是拆除了消防通道，他们开始拆除公寓的其他部分。在芝加哥他们生命的第一年，我不得不搬了三次家。而且，在这些情况下，你感觉自己被围困了，如果你不能在家里休息，对我来说这就像战争罪行。
And that's what these people felt. And I just, I totally empathize with this. It's that's very much, it's like exactly the situation that they're dealing with here. It's really intense and it's very scary. And so people are panicking, so they wanna reassure the residents.
这就是这些人所感受到的。我完全同情这一点。这非常，就像他们在这里处理的情况一模一样。这非常强烈，而且非常可怕。所以人们很恐慌，所以他们想安抚居民。
So another letter goes out and it says, hey, you're in section two of the construction map. Section three, we already have been relocating tenants starting in 1946 and it went fine. And the section two people are like, uh, let's form a committee and go over there and see what it's like. And what they find horrifies them. And it's another, I'm just going to read a tiny bit of this. It's another classic Caro urban dystopia, you know, cataclysm writing. He says, where once apartment buildings or private homes had stood were now hills of rubble, classic Caro urban dystopia, you know, cataclysm writing.
所以另一封信发出去了，上面写着，嘿，你们在施工地图的第二区。第三区，我们已经从1946年开始重新安置租户，进展顺利。第二区的人们就像，呃，让我们组成一个委员会去那里看看情况如何。他们发现的情况让他们感到震惊。这是另一个，我只是要读一点点这个。这是另一个经典的卡罗城市反乌托邦，你知道，灾难写作。他说，曾经矗立着公寓楼或私人住宅的地方，现在变成了瓦砾山，经典的卡罗城市反乌托邦，你知道，灾难写作。
He says, where once apartment buildings or private homes had stood were now hills of rubble decorated with ripped open bags of rotting garbage that had flung atop them. Some of the right away was being cleared. Giant wreckers balls thudded into walls. Mammoth cranes snarled and grumbled over the ruins, picking out their insides.
他说，曾经矗立着公寓楼或私人住宅的地方，现在变成了瓦砾山，上面装饰着被撕开的腐烂垃圾袋。部分通行权正在被清理。巨大的拆迁球撞击着墙壁。巨大的起重机在废墟上咆哮和抱怨，挑选出它们的内部。
Huge bulldozers and earth moving machines rumbled over the rubble. A small army of grime covered demolition workers pounded and pried and shoveled. A thick layer of gritty soot made the very air feel dirty. I took out a handkerchief and wiped my forehead and it came away black, absolutely black," Mrs. Edelstein says. Over the rumble of the bulldozers came the staccato, machine-gun-like banging of jackhammers and occasionally the dull concussion of an exploding dynamite charge, and in the midst of this landscape of destruction, a handful of apartment buildings still stood. And they go into these buildings and the places are wrecked like they're just in shambles,
巨大的推土机和土方机械在瓦砾上隆隆作响。一小群满身污垢的拆迁工人敲打、撬动和铲除。厚厚的煤灰层让空气感觉很脏。我拿出一条手帕擦了擦额头，它变成了黑色，绝对是黑色，”埃德尔斯坦夫人说。在推土机的隆隆声中，传来了像机关枪一样的凿岩机敲击声，偶尔还有爆炸的炸药的沉闷震动声，在这片毁灭的景观中，几栋公寓楼仍然矗立着。他们走进这些建筑物，这些地方被毁坏了，就像它们处于混乱之中，
they're filthy, and they'll knock on doors and they'll find families like themselves still living in these apartments because they have not been relocated. And if they have been, they've been relocated to the next building down the line that is about to be destroyed. It's like something out of like a Franz Kafka or like a Philip K. Dick story that it's like you're being relocated, one building down, and then the building you were adjusting gets destroyed. You're being relocated again. The building you're in now is being destroyed. They're living out of suitcases, kind of being moved from building to building, these people in Section 3. And each time they move, they get hit by a 15% rent bump, which is the thing that always astonishes me the most.
它们很脏，他们会敲门，会发现像他们一样的家庭仍然住在这些公寓里，因为他们没有被重新安置。如果他们被重新安置了，他们被重新安置到了下一栋即将被摧毁的建筑物。这就像弗朗茨·卡夫卡或菲利普·K·迪克故事中的东西，就像你被重新安置，移动一栋楼，然后你正在调整的建筑物被摧毁了。你再次被重新安置。你所在的建筑物正在被摧毁。他们住在手提箱里，从一栋楼搬到另一栋楼，这些第三区的人。每次他们搬家，他们都会受到15%的租金上涨的打击，这是最让我感到惊讶的事情。
They still have to pay rent and they're getting charged more to live in this kind of nightmare land. It's, it's so it's in the end section three is like, oh yeah, we've got the same assurances that you guys got in section two. Um, but when they found there's this tenant relocation bureau, but the apartments found were worse and more expensive. And the bureau basically says, well, you're on your own. If you move now, we'll give you some money to cover your moving costs. If you move into one of these worse apartments, it's more expensive. And people start to swallow their dignity and say, what about
他们仍然必须支付租金，而且他们被收取更多的费用住在这个噩梦般的土地上。它，它太，所以最后第三区就像，哦是的，我们得到了你们在第二区得到的同样的保证。嗯，但当他们发现有一个租户安置局时，但找到的公寓更糟、更贵。该局基本上说，好吧，你们得靠自己了。如果你现在搬走，我们会给你一些钱来支付你的搬家费用。如果你搬进这些更糟的公寓之一，它更贵。人们开始吞下他们的尊严，说，那
public housing? Like they're building all this public housing. You know, we've never wanted to be on assistance. There's a stigma attached to it, but can we, what about that? And they'll be like, uh, the waiting list is tens of thousands of people long. And this one woman in section three, she's like, yeah, I've been on one of the waiting lists for public housing for six years.
公共住房呢？就像他们正在建造所有这些公共住房。你知道，我们从来不想接受援助。这上面有污名，但我们可以，那怎么样？他们会说，呃，等待名单上有成千上万的人。第三区的这个女人，她说，是的，我在公共住房的等待名单上已经排了六年了。
And it's just, there's no, they feel like there's no way to go. There's, there's, they've journeyed from section two to section three, the people of East Tremont, and they've seen this horrible glimpse of their future. And they need to do whatever they can to not be in this situation where their neighborhood is being torn down around them, while they struggle
而且只是，没有，他们觉得没有出路，他们从第二区搬到了第三区，东特雷蒙特的人们，他们看到了他们未来的可怕一瞥。他们需要尽其所能不处于这种社区在他们周围被拆除的情况，同时他们努力
to find a new place to live. It's really, you know, it's like a real life urban equivalent of, you know, someone coming back from the Terminator world and being like, don't let this happen. Exactly, exactly. So they do what all good liberals do, maybe they're liberals, maybe they're not, but they say, you know what? We just can make a logical case to the people involved,
寻找一个新的居住地。这真的，你知道，这就像现实生活中的城市版，你知道，有人从终结者世界回来，说，不要让这种情况发生。正是如此，正是如此。所以他们做了所有好的自由派会做的事，也许他们是自由派，也许他们不是，但他们说，你知道吗？我们只是可以向相关人员提出一个合乎逻辑的理由，
and if we just have the right argument, we can convince them that they're wrong and they should save this neighborhood. It's that we've seen it time and again, it works every time in this book. If as long as we can just sit down with the man, just sit down and explain our feelings and our situation, of course he'll see the truth.
只要我们有充分的理由，就能说服他们意识到自己错了，并让他们拯救这个社区。我们在书中一次又一次地看到，这种方法每次都奏效。只要我们能坐下来和那个人谈谈，坐下来解释我们的感受和处境，他当然会看到真相。
Oh boy, oh, these poor liberals, they are liberals. These are like ex-socialists and things like that. You know, these are real hardcore. But what's funny is they're like, hey, maybe there's an alternate road for this. And they happen by luck to be kicked down the ladder to the one guy in the planning commission who is like, yeah, there is an alternate route. You know, they happen by luck to be kicked down the ladder to the one guy in the planning commission who was like, yeah, there is an alternate route.
天哪，这些可怜的自由派，他们确实是自由派。他们就像是前社会主义者之类的人。你知道，他们是真正的铁杆派。但有趣的是，他们会想，嘿，也许还有另一条路可走。幸运的是，他们顺着梯子找到了规划委员会里的那个人，那个人说，是的，确实有另一条路。你知道，他们幸运地找到了规划委员会里的那个人，那个人说，是的，确实有另一条路。
You know, it should go through the park. It shouldn't go through your homes. And, uh, that person is told never to talk to them again. It's so awful. He just low enough to not feel like the presence of Robert Moses in every moment of his like waking life. And so he looks at something like with like clear eyes, you know, uninfluenced and he goes, yeah, totally.
你知道，它应该穿过公园，而不应该穿过你们的家。然后，那个人被告知再也不要和他们说话了。这太可怕了。他只是足够低调，以至于不会在清醒生活的每一刻都感受到罗伯特·摩西的存在。所以他能用清澈的眼睛看问题，不受影响，然后说，是的，完全同意。
This would be so much better if it was right here. And then as soon as he suggests it, all of a sudden the shadow of Moses, like the eye of Sauron like turns on him. And they have to get an engineer who used to work for Moses, but was kind of blackballed because he spoke his mind too many times.
如果它就在这里，那会好得多。但当他一提出这个建议，摩西的阴影就像索伦之眼一样突然转向了他。他们不得不找一位曾经为摩西工作过的工程师，但他因为说真话太多次而被列入了黑名单。
They have to get him to make plans for an alternate route that they can at least show to the city. But he goes, I'll only do it anonymously. People are so afraid of Moses that they do not want to be putting their name on this. The new route they have, it's nearly identical to the old one, except it avoids their homes, is less expensive, and would be easier to build. And they're trying to get a meeting with Moses and Moses office is like, it's not worth it. He's never gonna change it. The coordinator has decided on the route. He is not gonna change his mind.
他们不得不让他制定一条替代路线，至少可以展示给市政府看。但他却说，我只能匿名做。人们太害怕摩西了，以至于不敢在上面署名。他们提出的新路线与旧路线几乎完全相同，只是避开了他们的家，成本更低，而且更容易建造。他们试图与摩西会面，但摩西的办公室却说，没必要。他永远不会改变主意。协调员已经决定了路线。他不会改变主意的。
Yeah, and he's right. But they keep on going through this because they keep on finding other people. And this is where they try to, they think this is what democracy is for. I'm gonna talk to the borough president and see if they support us. And mostly when they meet with these people individually, they go, yeah, that doesn't make sense. Yeah, I'll support this change and present it. But every time they present
是的，他是对的。但他们还是坚持这样做，因为他们不断地寻找其他人。这就是他们试图做的事情，他们认为这就是民主的意义所在。我要去和区长谈谈，看看他们是否支持我们。大多数时候，当他们单独与这些人会面时，他们会说，是的，这确实有道理。是的，我会支持这个改变并提出来。但每次他们提出
it to someone, it makes sense in the moment, but as soon as Moses has the ability to be around them or it comes up for some kind of vote, they forget the promises they once made to the community in East Tremont. And the East Tremonters, they're doing everything right. Like they form a neighborhood association, they are lobbying their elected representatives, like they are trying to get into the press. They're doing everything right,
给某人看时，当时听起来确实有道理，但一旦摩西有机会出现在他们身边，或者进行某种投票时，他们就忘记了曾经对东特雷蒙特社区做出的承诺。东特雷蒙特的居民们，他们所做的一切都是正确的。比如他们成立了社区协会，游说民选代表，试图联系媒体。他们所做的一切都是正确的，
and they just simply, they're not having no results, and it's because of Moses. And there's a thing that Moses says that really hits me hard because it is he's making that argument of like no because I don't care that means I'm the best person to talk about this and he says this route will be the backbone of traffic for centuries after a few objecting tenants have been removed from the scene you have this is that letter he writes the Bronx borough president you have from time to time remarks that I do not have to be elected to office. Perhaps that is why
但他们就是没有任何结果，这都是因为摩西。摩西说的一句话让我感触很深，因为他提出了这样的论点：不，因为我不在乎，这意味着我是谈论这件事的最佳人选。他说，在一些反对的租户被从现场移除后，这条路线将成为未来几个世纪交通的骨干。这就是他写给布朗克斯区长的那封信，你时不时地评论说我不必通过选举上任。也许这就是为什么
I'm in a position to protect the really long range public interest. This idea that because I'm not answerable to the public, that's why I can do the hard things that have to be done even though people don't like them. And I'm like, what is he a Supreme Court justice? What's going on here, Moses? Boom, relevant, relevant. And he pulls his tricks all the time of, if you obstruct me, I'm going to take money away from your borough. I'm going to reveal things about you that you don't want people to know.
我能处于保护长期公共利益的位置。这种观点认为，因为我不对公众负责，所以我才能做那些必须做但人们不喜欢的艰难事情。我就想，他是什么最高法院大法官吗？这到底是怎么回事，摩西？砰，切中要害，切中要害。他总是耍花招，如果你阻碍我，我就削减你们区的资金。我会揭露你不想让人知道的事情。
And like you're saying, they just, in private, they will meet with the East Tremonters. And these are mostly women from East Tremont. And this is the early 1950s. These are women who are not used to taking a public role in something. And they're finding this strength and this courage to go from up in the Bronx down to City Hall, a place that they've never imagined they would have reason to go to,
就像你说的，私下里，他们会和东特雷蒙特的居民见面。这些人大多是来自东特雷蒙特的女性。那是20世纪50年代初。这些女性不习惯在公共事务中扮演角色。她们正在寻找力量和勇气，从布朗克斯前往市政厅，一个她们从未想过会有理由去的地方，
and to talk to these very powerful people and say, you need to help us save our homes. And they'll be like, of course, of course. And then it just doesn't happen. You know, Moses' route is just kind of going through the process without really any, any obstruction. And in theory, Carol says, East Tremont, the people there, they could have slowed it down with a legal battle, but lawyers cost money. They don't have that money. None of them are lawyers. They're not educated people. They're garment workers. And so they can't do the work themselves. And later on, we're going to see a successful fight with Moses.
去和那些非常有权势的人交谈，说，你们需要帮助我们拯救我们的家园。他们会说，当然，当然。然后事情就没下文了。你知道，摩西的路线就这样在没有任何阻碍的情况下推进了。理论上，卡罗说，东特雷蒙特的人们本可以通过法律斗争来减缓进度，但律师需要钱。他们没有钱。他们中没有一个是律师。他们不是受过教育的人。他们是制衣工人。所以他们无法自己完成这项工作。后来，我们将看到一场与摩西的成功斗争。
And the difference there is the people fighting him are upper middle-class people who have access to money. Some of them are lawyers. They have access to the press in a way that ordinary people, the people that he's turned on do not, and they feel like it's hopeless, but they still fight and Lillian Edelstein really becomes is one of these like civic heroes that shows up in the book where she's doing things she's never done before, like she's teaching herself how to type and run a Mimeo machine.
不同之处在于，与他抗争的人是中上层阶级，他们有钱。他们中有些人是律师。他们有普通人（那些被他针对的人）所没有的接触媒体的渠道，他们觉得这毫无希望，但他们仍然在战斗。莉莲·埃德尔斯坦真的成为了书中出现的平民英雄之一，她做着以前从未做过的事情，比如自学打字和操作油印机。
She's teaching herself how to run a local camp, a publicity campaign. Like she's arranging rallies. She's chartering buses, things that she's never thought she'd had to do. She's doing now, but enthusiasm just keeps falling. It's hard because they keep hitting failure after failure after failure. But Roman, there's one person who seems to have been listening to them. Who is it? Who could be their potential savior in this situation?
她自学如何开展当地的宣传活动。比如组织集会。包租巴士，这些她从未想过自己需要做的事情。她现在都在做，但热情一直在下降。这很难，因为他们不断遭遇一次又一次的失败。但是罗曼，有一个人似乎一直在听他们说话。是谁？在这种情况下，谁可能是他们的潜在救星？
It's Robert F. Wagner Jr. This is before he's the mayor. We talked about him as the mayor in a couple chapters ago. So if this was a Marvel comic, there'd be an asterisk that would say, takes place between Impey and Wagner in chapter 34, smile and stand, you know, something like that. That's right. So right now he's the Manhattan borough president
是小罗伯特·F·瓦格纳。这是在他担任市长之前。我们在几章前谈到过他担任市长的情况。所以如果这是一本漫威漫画，会有一个星号写着，发生在第34章《微笑与站立》中的因佩和瓦格纳之间，你知道，类似这样的事情。没错。所以现在他是曼哈顿区长，
and part of the board of estimate. And also he's right now is about to run for mayor. So he sees all these people, these potential voters of which there are many. I mean, you're talking about 1500 apartments, that's at least 1500 voters and probably more like 3000 to 5000 voters. It's something around 5000 people,
也是估价委员会的成员。而且他现在正准备竞选市长。所以他看到了所有这些人，这些潜在的选民，其中有很多。我是说，你说的是1500套公寓，那至少有1500名选民，可能更接近3000到5000名选民。大约有5000人，
like Carol makes it sound like. So yeah, this is a, it's not enough to like win an election, but it's enough to make it, to swing an election, probably in a close one, like you want those people. Yeah, so at some point he promises them that he will hold off any approval of the combination of their different properties and stuff. And he's kind of like, I'm trying to think of this crests
就像卡罗说的那样。所以是的，这不足以赢得选举，但足以改变选举结果，特别是在势均力敌的情况下，你想要那些人。是的，所以在某个时候，他向他们承诺，他将推迟对他们不同房产等的征收批准。他有点像，我在想这是否
over to when he's the mayor, does it? It does. Okay. So he's the Manhattan borough president and he says, yes. And on the campaign, he says, I will not approve this route. I will not vote for this route. That's right. And he makes it, he makes a real promise, a public promise about it.
延续到他担任市长的时候，是吗？是的。好的。所以他是曼哈顿区长，他说，是的。在竞选活动中，他说，我不会批准这条路线。我不会投票支持这条路线。没错。他做出了一个真正的承诺，一个关于此事的公开承诺。
And Moses pulls the same stuff. He always pulls where he goes, hey, this is being built with federal and state money, and I represent those officials. And I think it's amazingly telling that he says, I represent those officials. He does not represent the people of New York.
摩西又耍了他一贯的把戏，他说，嘿，这是用联邦和州的资金建造的，我代表那些官员。我认为他说的“我代表那些官员”非常能说明问题。他不代表纽约人民。
He represents the money brokers that he's dealing with. He goes, and if you try to move this, you're not gonna get the money for this road, and you're not gonna get the money from the state or the federal government that you want ever again. And Wagner as mayor, he tries to drag it out as long as he can. Uh, and the deputy mayor offers his support too. And there are moments of hope and then they're undermined and they study an alternate route, but it turns out most of his staff studied the wrong route on purpose.
他代表的是他正在打交道的那些金钱掮客。他说，如果你试图改变路线，你就不会再得到这条路的资金，也不会再得到州或联邦政府的资金。瓦格纳作为市长，试图尽可能地拖延。副市长也提供了支持。有过希望的时刻，但随后又被破坏了。他们研究了一条替代路线，但结果证明摩西的工作人员故意研究了错误的路线。
And in the end, it doesn't matter. Moses applies his pressure. The deputy mayor switches sides, everyone on the board, including mayor Wagner votes to approve the condemnation of East Tremont, even though he has been on the record saying first saying, I will not vote for this unless these people are relocated first. And then saying, I will not vote for this.
最后，这并不重要。摩西施加了压力。副市长倒戈，委员会里的每个人，包括瓦格纳市长，都投票批准了对东特雷蒙特的征收，尽管他曾公开表示，首先说，除非这些人先被安置好，否则我不会投票支持。然后又说，我不会投票支持。
And, but then he does it. And the East Tremonters meet with the mayor and they go, what's going to happen to us? And he's like, yeah, I don't know. I don't know what's going to happen to you. Like he's, they've been completely sold out and they, they can't understand why, but, uh, the mayor and they go, what's going to happen to us? And he's like, yeah, I don't know. I don't know what's going to happen to you. Like he's, they've been completely sold out and they, they can't understand why, but, uh, the mayor has been assured that an efficient private firm, the NASA management company will handle their relocations. So don't worry. I guess they're in good hands, you know, and years later, Caro says he talks
但后来他还是做了。东特雷蒙特的居民与市长会面，他们问，我们会怎么样？他说，是的，我不知道。我不知道你们会怎么样。就像他，他们被彻底出卖了，他们无法理解为什么，但是，市长和他们说，我们会怎么样？他说，是的，我不知道。我不知道你们会怎么样。就像他，他们被彻底出卖了，他们无法理解为什么，但是，市长得到保证，一家高效的私营公司——拿骚管理公司将处理他们的安置问题。所以别担心。我想他们会得到妥善安置的，你知道，多年后，卡罗说他与
to Moses and he wants to know why did Epstein change his vote with the deputy mayor Epstein? Why did he change his vote, which led to the mayor also changing his vote? And Caro makes a notice of saying that like, nobody remembers this vote. And when he talks to the deputy mayors who at this point had died to his widow,
摩西交谈，他想知道为什么爱泼斯坦改变了他的投票，和副市长爱泼斯坦一起？他为什么要改变投票，导致市长也改变了投票？卡罗注意到，没有人记得这次投票。当他与此时已经去世的副市长的遗孀交谈时，
she's like, I don't know what you're talking about. Like, I don't have any idea what this is, but Moses remembers. And he says, quote, he was hit over the head with an ax, but I won't tell you what we did to him but in his words he seems to be hinting that they were maybe gonna reveal an affair that Epstein was having or insinuate that he was having an affair and
她说，我不知道你在说什么。我根本不知道这是什么，但摩西记得。他说，引用他的话，“他被斧头砍中了头，但我不会告诉你我们对他做了什么。”但在他的话语中，他似乎在暗示他们可能要揭露爱泼斯坦正在进行的婚外情，或者暗示他有婚外情，并且
Kara says like what about the difficulties of all these people of building it and Moses says there are more people in the way. That's all and talking about the people of East Vermont he says it was a political thing that stirred up the animals there. And he has no regrets, doesn't care, does not see those people as people. And one of the shattering things is that the New York Times reports on this story, basically not at all. But the one time they do is when the route gets approved. And it's just noting that after years of delay, the cross Bronx will finally finish its construction. Like this is a victory, you know, for the cross Bronx Expressway and for the city. And it comes after this long, like we've really done a kind of brisk summary of it, but this long story of these people trying and trying and trying and doing all the right things, all the things you're supposed to do in a democracy to save your home.
卡罗说，那么所有这些人建造它的困难呢？摩西说，挡路的人更多了。就是这样。谈到东特雷蒙特的人民时，他说，那是一件政治事件，激怒了那里的动物。他没有任何遗憾，不在乎，不把那些人看作人。令人震惊的事情之一是，《纽约时报》对这个故事的报道几乎为零。但唯一一次报道是在路线获得批准时。它只是指出，经过多年的延误，横贯布朗克斯高速公路终于要完成建设了。这就像是横贯布朗克斯高速公路和这座城市的一场胜利。这发生在这漫长的故事之后，我们确实做了一个简短的总结，但这个漫长的故事讲述了这些人不断尝试，不断努力，做了所有在民主国家应该做的事情来拯救他们的家园。
And it just doesn't matter. And the people in power are mostly deaf to them. And even when they seem to be hearing them, they bow to the other pressures. Moses just, he's got the power. And these people do not have that power. And so then, you know, Kero tries to sort of spend a moment here to go like, well,
但这根本不重要。当权者大多对他们充耳不闻。即使当他们似乎在听的时候，他们也会屈服于其他压力。摩西就是有权力。而这些人没有那种权力。所以，你知道，卡罗试图在这里花点时间去想，嗯，
why did this have to happen at all? Why did this bump out have to happen? Why did the alternate route not be chosen? That seems straighter. That seems like it would displace far fewer people. It would cost much less money. That's money he could spend on other roads. He loves building roads.
为什么这一切必须发生？为什么必须有这个凸起？为什么不选择替代路线？那看起来更直。那看起来会减少很多人的流离失所。那会花费少得多的钱。那是他可以花在其他道路上的钱。他喜欢修路。
He doesn't like to waste money, so. And the people fighting it had heard rumors that maybe the Tremont Bus Depot, you know, doesn't like to waste money. And the people fighting it had heard rumors that maybe the Tremont bus depot, you know, like it was necessary to preserve, that all kinds of things. Maybe the Bronx borough president had like a relative that owned land there, like they're hearing, nobody really knows for sure.
他不喜欢浪费钱，所以。而与之抗争的人们听到了传言，也许特雷蒙特公交车库，你知道，不喜欢浪费钱。而与之抗争的人们听到了传言，也许特雷蒙特公交车库，你知道，就像它有必要保留一样，各种各样的事情。也许布朗克斯区长有亲戚在那里拥有土地，就像他们听到的那样，没有人真正确定。
And the rumors sound, I mean, Caro seems to kind of lean on the bus one a little bit, but the rumors sound like rumors. They sound like someone desperately trying to figure out from a nip of something they heard from, you know, a neighbor what it might possibly be. It's something that I know Caro hates doing, which is being like, yeah, we don't know. Yeah. We don't know why he did it. Yeah. And, uh, but what it comes down to, and what Caro sort of settles on is that it doesn't matter. The reasons they don't matter in the, in the real world, because the reasons don't really matter to Moses.
这些传言听起来，我是说，卡罗似乎有点倾向于公交车那个传言，但传言听起来就像传言。它们听起来像是某人拼命地试图从他们从邻居那里听到的只言片语中弄清楚它可能是什么。这是我知道卡罗讨厌做的事情，那就是说，是的，我们不知道。是的，我们不知道他为什么要这样做。是的。但是归根结底，卡罗所认定的结论是，这并不重要。这些原因在现实世界中并不重要，因为这些原因对摩西来说并不重要。
What Moses wants is what Moses goes after. And that's it, that's the end of it. Doesn't like to be questioned. Yeah, the reason Moses did it is less important than the fact that only Moses's reason was the important one. Whatever reason he had, whether it was a whim, whether he was like, I think I'm gonna try
摩西想要什么，摩西就去追求什么。就是这样，结束了。不喜欢被质疑。是的，摩西这样做的原因不如“只有摩西的理由才是重要的”这一事实重要。无论他有什么理由，无论是心血来潮，还是他想，我想这次我要尝试
a slanty line this time. I'm gonna put a curve in my road. I'm tired of straight lines. It doesn't matter. Whatever he felt was the only factor that was important in the decision. And Caro says, neighborhood feelings, urban planning considerations, cost, aesthetics,
画一条斜线。我要在我的路上画一个弯。我厌倦了直线。这并不重要。无论他感觉如何，都是决策中唯一重要的因素。卡罗说，社区情感、城市规划考虑、成本、美学、
common humanity, common sense, none of these mattered in laying out the roots of New York's great roads. The only consideration that mattered was Robert Moses's will. And it should go without saying, we're going to talk about this more, I guess, I think in a little bit in the next chapter, possibly, but it goes without saying the Nassau management company, which gets millions of dollars in relocation
共同的人性、常识，这些在规划纽约伟大道路的路线时都不重要。唯一重要的考虑因素是罗伯特·摩西的意志。不用说，我们以后会更多地谈论这一点，我想，在下一章，可能，但不用说，获得数百万美元安置费的拿骚管理公司
contracts in the city is controlled by three of Moses's key aides, and we'll see is terrible. It's very bad at what it does. It's just another corruption thing. And there's a black line here that separates sections of the chapter, which is another thing he doesn't do that often. Every now and then Robert Carrow will throw in a little formatting trick that you don't expect to see.
城市里的合同由摩西的三名主要助手控制，我们将会看到，这太可怕了。它的运作方式非常糟糕。这不过是又一起腐败事件。这里有一条黑线将章节分成了几个部分，这也是他很少做的事情。罗伯特·卡罗偶尔会加入一些你意想不到的小排版技巧。
And he's doing it because he wants to introduce a quote, which he doesn't usually do, which is this section of dialogue from Fiddler on the Roof, which is the moment when the characters, the Jewish residents of the shtetl of Anatevka, you know, I could go into it in more detail. You know, it's a show that is very important to me. The moment when they realize
他这样做是因为他想引述一段话，这在他书中并不常见，这段话来自《屋顶上的提琴手》，是剧中角色——安纳特夫卡村的犹太居民——意识到……你知道，我可以更详细地讲讲。你知道，这部剧对我来说非常重要。当他们意识到……
they are being evicted from their homes. They've received a piece of paper, it's a letter from the Tsar saying you have to leave. And he's so explicitly comparing the relocation of these tenants to the expulsion of the Jews from the Pale of Settlement, the area of Russia that Jews were allowed to live in. And then we're told, no, you can't live in here anymore. And it's the expulsion that led many of the families
他们正被赶出家园。他们收到了一张纸，那是沙皇的一封信，说你们必须离开。他非常明确地将这些租户的搬迁与犹太人被驱逐出“定居区”（俄罗斯允许犹太人居住的地区）进行了比较。然后我们被告知，不，你们不能再住在这里了。正是这次驱逐导致了许多家庭……
in this chapter to come to the United States in the first place. It's the kind of expulsion that led my family to come here in the first place. And so as an East Coast, fiddler on the roof, loving Jewish guy with Eastern European roots in his family, this parallel, it just hits me so hard that he's, and there's a certain added aspect that I think Caro doesn't go into, but the idea that there's a, this kind of tribalism
在本章中，他们最初来到美国。正是这种驱逐导致了我的家人最初来到这里。所以，作为一个热爱《屋顶上的提琴手》、有着东欧血统的东海岸犹太人，这种平行对比深深地触动了我。而且还有一个额外的层面，我认为卡罗没有深入探讨，但那种部落主义的思想……
that should not play a part in politics, but that Moses is a Jew who is doing this to fellow Jews is like a little bit of extra bad. You know, he should know of anyone because this is something that if he felt any sense of community with these people, which he doesn't, he would be aware of. But it's just a moment where it feels like Karo is going out of his way to create a parallel between an explicitly non-democratic moment as well. That Moses is not just acting like a dictator or whatever. He's acting specifically like the Tsar of Russia, which is the kind of thing that America is not supposed to have or do at all. And it strikes me especially, it's not a connection I expect,
本不该在政治中占有一席之地，但摩西作为一个犹太人，却对同胞做这种事，这简直是错上加错。你知道，他本该比任何人都清楚，因为如果他对这些人有任何社区感——但他并没有——他本该意识到这一点。但这只是一个时刻，感觉卡罗特意创造了一个与明确的非民主时刻的平行对比。摩西不仅表现得像个独裁者什么的。他表现得就像俄罗斯的沙皇，而这正是美国根本不应该有或做的事情。这让我印象深刻，这不是我预料到的联系……
Caro expected anyone to make because they didn't know exactly which books and musicals I had seen and read. But that Moses is comparing himself earlier to Lincoln and that Lincoln said at one point that the specifically used Russia an example that if slavery is legal in the United States, then all the things that America says about equality and freedom and democracy are false. It's all hypocrisy and that he would rather live in a place like Russia then, which does not have the base alloy of hypocrisy as he calls it and is open about the fact that it is a kingdom run by a czar, unlike the United States, which purports to be something different. And so it's just, um, Carol here is he's making these connections and swimming in these waters, especially hard in this chapter, this idea that, uh, Moses is, is in the chapter about RM, the fun-loving party thrower. He is a king in the fun way and here is he is a czar in the bad way where he is throwing people out of their houses. Yeah, yeah. And if you thought the other part was heartbreaking, this is in a way where the
卡罗预料到有人会做出这种联想，因为他们并不知道我具体看过或读过哪些书和音乐剧。但摩西早些时候将自己与林肯相提并论，而林肯曾指出，他特别以俄罗斯为例，说如果奴隶制在美国是合法的，那么美国关于平等、自由和民主的所有言论都是虚假的。这全是虚伪，他宁愿生活在像俄罗斯那样的地方，因为那里没有他所说的“虚伪的贱合金”，并且公开承认它是一个由沙皇统治的王国，而不像美国，声称自己与众不同。所以，嗯，卡罗在这里，他正在建立这些联系，并在这些水域中游泳，在这一章中尤为艰难，这种想法是，嗯，摩西是，在关于RM（那个热爱聚会的派对组织者）的那一章里。他是一个“好意义上”的国王，而在这里，他是一个“坏意义上”的沙皇，他把人们赶出家门。是的，是的。如果你觉得另一部分已经够令人心碎了，那么这部分……
misery really begins when they finally decide that this is the end of this neighborhood. And as you know, hinted, the Nassau Management Company is not really up to the task. No. Its office is located far away. Its business hours are like maybe a couple hours a day, he mentions, and so people go there to try to find that the apartments that they're offering people
当他们最终认定这个社区已经走到尽头时，苦难才真正开始。正如你所暗示的，拿骚管理公司（Nassau Management Company）根本无法胜任这项工作。不。它的办公室离得很远。他提到，它的营业时间可能每天只有几个小时，所以人们去那里试图寻找公寓，结果发现他们提供给人们的……
to be placed are far worse than the ones they came from. There are long lines of people waiting for them and then the women show up to go look at them and they go, well, if none of these people are going to take it, it must be so awful that I wouldn't wanna take it either. They'll get sent to apartments that have people living in them already
安置点比他们原来的地方差得多。那里排着长队等着他们，然后女人们去看房，她们会说，好吧，如果这些人都不想要，那它一定糟透了，我也不想要。他们会被送到已经有人居住的公寓里……
that are not even vacant. It's another kind of Kafkaesque moment where Moses is like, you know what I can use to crush people? Bureaucracy. Like I can send them running in circles, try to call the office. You can't, the phone's busy. Try to show up in person. You can't, the door's locked, it's closed. Okay. You got it. You got an apartment address from us. Surprise. It's terrible. And it's leaving them with no place to turn at the exact time that now that Moses has the ability to take control of these buildings, he is physically making it so incredibly undesirable
甚至都不是空房。这是另一个卡夫卡式的时刻，摩西就像是，你知道我可以用什么来压垮人们吗？官僚主义。我可以让他们团团转，试着给办公室打电话。你打不通，电话占线。试着亲自去。你进不去，门锁着，关门了。好吧。你从我们这里得到了一个公寓地址。惊喜。它糟透了。这让他们在摩西有能力控制这些建筑的同时，无处可去，他实际上让居住在那里变得极其令人不快……
and uncomfortable to live there to push them out. So January 1st, 1954, he takes over these buildings, turns off the heat, turns off the hot water. You know, and Roman, I know you live in Northern California where it's kind of chilly sometimes, but like January in New York is very, can get very cold. It's very cold. Yeah, it's not a time when you want, you don't want heat or hot water. And it's not like they can find it too many other places.
且不舒适，从而把他们赶走。所以1954年1月1日，他接管了这些建筑，关掉了暖气，关掉了热水。你知道，罗曼，我知道你住在北加州，那里有时有点冷，但纽约的1月非常、非常冷。非常冷。是的，这不是你想要没有暖气或热水的时候。而且他们也没法在其他太多地方找到住处。
It's the 1950s. Like there's not that many places to go to stay warm at the time, unless if you don't have money to spend. And on May 1st of that year, the residents are sent notices warning them to move out by the end of month where they'll be evicted. These are false notices. They have no legal backing. It's just more of this scare tactic.
那是20世纪50年代。当时没有太多地方可以保暖，除非你没钱花。那年5月1日，居民们收到了通知，警告他们月底前搬走，否则将被驱逐。这些是虚假通知。它们没有任何法律依据。这只是更多的恐吓手段。
And so families start to move. There are elderly widows that are trying to last as long as they can, but they start getting scattered to various public housing projects. There's this part that is so sad where it's these elderly couples that have met later in life, they are not married, but they are in love and they can't get apartments in the same public housing projects. The system is just not set up that way. And so they're just kind of scattered around the city and they're too poor to afford car fare to see each other. And so these elderly people are just never going to see their friends or their loved ones again. You know, they're just, it's just not going to happen. They're going to live alone again. You know, it's just not gonna happen.
于是家庭开始搬迁。有些年迈的寡妇试图坚持尽可能长的时间，但她们开始被分散到各个公共住房项目中。有一部分非常令人难过，那是些晚年相识的老夫妇，他们没有结婚，但他们相爱，却无法在同一个公共住房项目中获得公寓。系统根本不是那样设置的。所以他们就这样被分散在城市各处，他们太穷了，付不起去看望对方的车费。所以这些老人再也见不到他们的朋友或爱人了。你知道，这只是……这根本不会发生。他们将再次独自生活。你知道，这根本不会发生。
They're gonna live alone and lonely. Oh, it's so sad, so incredibly sad. I mean, that's something that Caro pointed out in our interview, like that the loneliness was what struck him the most of people's lives is that that was the saddest part. They didn't really like, you know, harp on the, you know, the physical structures they lost
他们将独自生活，孤独终老。哦，太难过了，极其难过。我的意思是，这是卡罗在我们的采访中指出的，孤独感是人们生活中最让他震惊的事情，那是其中最悲伤的部分。他们并没有真正地，你知道，纠结于他们失去的物理结构……
or anything like that. It was really about that loneliness of being isolated. And yeah, sure they have a place to live. Maybe they landed on their feet and found a place to live that was too expensive for them, but they never got back that sense of community and connection with other people. Something that has always struck me
或者类似的东西。这真的是关于那种被孤立的孤独感。是的，当然他们有地方住。也许他们站稳了脚跟，找到了一个对他们来说太贵的住处，但他们再也没有找回那种社区感和与他人的联系。这总是让我印象深刻……
about the work of 99% Invisible, a really wonderful podcast about architecture and design that I love, is that you often, you and the reporters who work on it, all the great and amazing staff of reporters and editors and writers. Mostly them at this point, yes. Yeah. Yeah. As absentee landlord, Roman Mars, goes on his power broker jaunts, you know, there's a real emphasis on the emotional impact often of infrastructure, of architecture, of living. It's very easy for official organizations to put a lot of emphasis on the money something costs,
关于《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）的工作，这是一个我非常喜欢的关于建筑和设计的精彩播客，你和在那里工作的记者们，所有那些伟大而了不起的记者、编辑和作家团队。主要是他们，是的。是的。是的。当“缺席房东”罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）进行他的权力经纪人游历时，你知道，人们确实非常强调基础设施、建筑和生活对情感的影响。官方机构很容易把重点放在某件事的成本上……
on the amount of work that has to be put into it, on the amount of cars that can be moved per hour, you know, or per day through a space, the amount of money you can raise in tolls, without putting the emphasis that deserves to be there on the emotional cost of something because it's harder to quantify and it's easier to dismiss because it's an individual thing, but that loneliness, that caro hits it and that this isn't just a matter of people living in more rundown apartments than before, but yeah, this is a matter of their, their feeling of security in the world being taken a hit, their feeling of living in a place where they know the people and have relationships with them being hit their sense that they have any sort of control over their lives in this world being hit.
放在投入的工作量上，放在每小时（或每天）可以通过空间的车辆数量上，你知道，或者放在你可以通过收费筹集多少钱上，而没有把应有的重点放在某件事的情感成本上，因为这更难量化，也更容易被忽视，因为它是个人的事情。但那种孤独感，卡罗抓住了它，这不仅仅是人们住在比以前更破旧的公寓里的问题，是的，这是关于他们在世界上的安全感受到打击，关于他们生活在一个认识周围人并与他们建立关系的地方的感觉受到打击，关于他们认为自己在世界上对生活有任何控制权的感觉受到打击。
It's such a, I'm glad that Caro also looks at it from the point of view of how are these people feeling about it and getting that across? Because it's in many ways, it's so devastating and it's like, I feel lucky I've never been thrown out of my home, but I've been lonely. I know what it's like to be lonely. And to live that way every day with no end in sight is, it's so horrifying. It's a nightmare. And they just bungle everything about this in terms of taking care of these people.
这真是……我很高兴卡罗也从这些人的感受以及如何传达这种感受的角度来看待它。因为在很多方面，这太令人震惊了，我觉得很幸运，我从未被赶出家门，但我经历过孤独。我知道孤独是什么滋味。每天那样生活，看不到尽头，真是太可怕了。这是一场噩梦。他们在照顾这些人方面把一切都搞砸了。
I mean, not that his intention was ever to take care of these people. I feel like bungle implies that they were trying and they failed out of incompetence, whereas they're trying to do it on the cheap and with as little effort as possible. Yeah, but they keep claiming success, which is infuriating,
我的意思是，并不是说他的初衷是照顾这些人。我觉得“搞砸”暗示他们是在尝试，但因无能而失败，而他们是在试图以尽可能低廉的成本和尽可能少的努力来完成这件事。是的，但他们一直声称成功，这令人愤怒……
and probably it keeps on being reported as a success. At a certain point at the end of that year, the Nassau Management Company announces that in less than 10 months, we have relocated 90% of the 1,530 occupants of section two, which is a lie. They've been, I mean, they've moved out. I mean, they haven't, they weren't relocated by the management company. Cause at this point also, as soon as people start moving out, they start tearing
而且可能它一直被报道为成功。在那一年年底的某个时候，拿骚管理公司宣布，在不到10个月的时间里，我们已经重新安置了第二区1530名住户中的90%，这是一个谎言。他们已经……我的意思是，他们搬走了。我的意思是，他们并不是由管理公司重新安置的。因为在这一点上，一旦人们开始搬走，他们就开始拆除……
those buildings out and they're tearing apart buildings while people are still living in them. If the top floor gets vacated completely, it doesn't matter if there are people living in the next floor, they'll just start ripping the top floor off. And so it becomes this self-sustaining cycle of people who are tried to stay have to leave because their buildings are being destroyed around them. And that place, this once comfortable neighborhood, not comfortable in a rich sense, but comfortable in a, you felt safe and you felt home there. Suddenly it is just rubble, the rubble gets lit on fire, crime starts to go
那些建筑，而且他们在人们还住在里面的时候就开始拆除建筑。如果顶层完全空了，即使下一层还有人住，他们也会直接把顶层拆掉。于是这就变成了一个自我维持的循环，那些试图留下来的人不得不离开，因为他们的建筑在他们周围被摧毁了。那个曾经舒适的社区——不是富裕意义上的舒适，而是那种你感到安全、感到家的地方——突然间就变成了瓦砾，瓦砾被点燃，犯罪开始……
through vandals come in, he talks about how one mother finds her son's jumping back and forth over a whole 20 feet deep, because the basements of these buildings that are no longer there are just open pits full of debris that they don't even put fences around. It's another one of these, again, more urban dystopia stuff where it's just like rats and glass all over the floor. That's the around. It's another one of these, again, more urban dystopia stuff where it's just like rats and glass all over the floor. That's the thing.
蔓延，破坏者进来了，他谈到一位母亲发现她的儿子在20英尺深的洞上跳来跳去，因为那些不再存在的建筑的地下室只是充满了碎片的露天坑，他们甚至没有在周围设置围栏。这是另一个，又是那种城市反乌托邦的东西，到处都是老鼠和玻璃。这就是……这是另一个，又是那种城市反乌托邦的东西，到处都是老鼠和玻璃。这就是……
It's like rats, glass and dust everywhere. And I don't know if you've ever read the book, The Sheep Look Up by John Brunner. It's a science fiction, kind of ecological catastrophe, horror satire novel. And it's the only book I can think of that comes close to my feeling reading this. And that's one where it's extrapolating
到处都是老鼠、玻璃和灰尘。我不知道你是否读过约翰·布鲁纳（John Brunner）的《羊群抬头》（The Sheep Look Up）。这是一部科幻、生态灾难、恐怖讽刺小说。这是我能想到的唯一一本在阅读时感觉与之接近的书。那是一本关于……
into the future world where the environment has just collapsed and everyday life is a nightmare. Just this idea of, yeah, anyway, I'm trying to still live in my neighborhood. They won't push me out, but everything is rats and glass and dust and vandalism. It's just, ugh, what a, and so, yeah, by the end, they haven't necessarily relocated 90% in a good way, but they've certainly pushed them out.
推演到一个环境已经崩溃、日常生活就是噩梦的未来世界。就是这种想法，是的，无论如何，我还在努力住在我的社区里。他们不会把我赶走，但到处都是老鼠、玻璃、灰尘和破坏行为。真是，呃，多么……所以，是的，到最后，他们不一定是以好的方式重新安置了90%，但他们确实把他们赶走了。
And that's a victory that the Nassau Management Company is happy to announce. Yeah. So that's the story of One Mile of the Cross Bronx Expressway. And that leads us to the next chapter. It is the afterword of the previous chapter. Which mostly you have afterwards for when you're talking
那是拿骚管理公司乐于宣布的胜利。是的。这就是横贯布朗克斯高速公路（Cross Bronx Expressway）一英里的故事。这把我们引向了下一章。它是上一章的后记。通常你只有在谈论……
about a whole book, but apparently this chapter is itself kind of its own sort of dystopian novel, and so it has an afterword. What is going on here, Elliot? Why do we have an afterword for the previous chapter we just read? This is an interesting question, because as you mentioned, afterwards are usually for whole books. You don't use like putting an epilogue
整本书时才会有后记，但显然这一章本身就是一种反乌托邦小说，所以它有一个后记。这到底是怎么回事，埃利奥特？为什么我们刚读完的上一章会有后记？这是一个有趣的问题，因为正如你提到的，后记通常是给整本书写的。你不会在小说中间放一个尾声……
in the middle of a novel. I mean like, this is the epilogue for that last chapter. And you're like, well, why didn't you just make it the next chapter or part of the previous chapter? And I think he is doing it for, for effect, you know, for, for dramatic and structural effect, but also because he is, there's a little bit of a pun there maybe that he is literally talking about what happened afterward, what happened after that, that chapter. And I think he wants to, I think it's, it's, it's actually, I think really masterful that in that
我的意思是，这是上一章的尾声。你会想，好吧，为什么不直接把它作为下一章或上一章的一部分呢？我认为他这样做是为了效果，你知道，为了戏剧性和结构上的效果，但也因为他……那里可能有一点双关语，他实际上是在谈论“之后”发生了什么，在那一章之后发生了什么。我认为他想要……我认为这实际上非常精湛，因为在那个……
one mile chapter, he is taking you through the experience of being a resident of that neighborhood as it is taken from them. And in this, this next chapter, he can kind of zoom out a little bit and instead look at it from the point of view of numbers and facts and figures and the consequences of what happened. That's right. This is about how the fact that it isn't just all those people being moved out, destroyed that look at it from the point of view of numbers and facts and figures and the consequences of what happened.
一英里的章节里，他带你体验了作为该社区居民在被剥夺家园时的经历。而在接下来的这一章中，他可以稍微拉远镜头，从数字、事实、数据以及所发生后果的角度来看待它。没错。这是关于这样一个事实：不仅仅是所有那些人被赶走，摧毁了……从数字、事实、数据以及所发生后果的角度来看待它。
That's right. This is about how the fact that it isn't just all those people being moved out destroyed that neighborhood. The fact of this highway dividing this section of the Bronx destroyed this neighborhood in a way that was beyond removing those 1500 families. Yes. It is the continuing tragedy that happens after that construction, after that, like the, I guess that's a great way to think about it.
没错。这是关于这样一个事实：不仅仅是所有那些人被赶走摧毁了那个社区。这条高速公路分割布朗克斯这一区域的事实，以一种超越了驱逐那1500个家庭的方式摧毁了这个社区。是的。这是在施工之后发生的持续悲剧，在那之后，就像，我想这是一个很好的思考方式。
That like this afterward is a little bit his way of saying like, everything is after this and it doesn't end, it doesn't stop. Yeah. It's not like, well, we had to break some eggs to build that road, but now the road is here. Everything functions great as I intended. It's wonderful.
就像这个后记是他的一种方式，说“一切都在这之后”，而且它没有结束，它不会停止。是的。并不是说，好吧，我们为了修那条路不得不打破一些鸡蛋，但现在路修好了。一切都按我预想的那样运作得很好。这太棒了。
And you know what? I mean, it was, it'd be amazing. It was chapter 38, one mile afterward. It just starts with, and he was right amazing. It was chapter 38, one mile afterward. It just starts with, and he was right. The road was great and everybody loved it. Like that's, it's not gonna, I mean, that's not gonna happen when the chapter previous
你知道吗？我的意思是，如果第38章是“一英里后记”，那将是惊人的。它只是以“他是对的”开头。路很棒，每个人都喜欢它。就像那样，它不会……我的意思是，当上一章……
to the last one was the meat ax. It's just not, it's, people don't title the chapters meat ax when good things happen at the end. So it's November, 1955. The tenants have been rushed out of their homes. Time to build that highway When the money comes through they don't have it at the moment It turns out the traffic is gonna be heavier than expected
是“肉斧”时，这种情况不会发生。人们不会在好事情发生时把章节命名为“肉斧”。所以是1955年11月。租户们被匆忙赶出家门。是时候修那条高速公路了。当钱到位时，他们当时还没有钱。事实证明，交通量将比预期的要大……
So they got to build some new bridges too And you know what we're gonna finish try to finish some other stuff sooner in time for the 58 gubernatorial election So this road where it was so important that these people be kicked out of their homes because construction had to start in 90 days. Uh, it isn't finished until 1973. The East Tremont section isn't complete until 1960. So it takes five years after he throws everybody out to get the money and then build the road. And it's just like, even if you like the road and you feel like they had to be
所以他们还得修一些新桥。而且你知道吗，我们要尝试在58年州长选举前完成其他一些事情。所以这条路，当初为了在90天内开工而必须把这些人赶出家门，结果直到1973年才完工。东特雷蒙特（East Tremont）路段直到1960年才完工。所以在他把所有人都赶走后，又花了五年时间才筹到钱并修好路。这就像，即使你喜欢这条路，并且觉得他们必须被……
kicked out, those are at least a couple of years that they might've been able to stay in their homes, you know, and the mass it's this, and this road is so expensive. The cross-border project originally Moses was like, Oh yeah, it'll cost $47 million. It ends up costing about $250 million, which is amazing. Um, but he says only 5,000 people were evicted from East Tremont. It's not like the whole neighborhood was kicked out. There are still 55,000 East Tremonters who did not need to leave their homes. They get to stay. Wonderful. Everything will be fine for them as a massive road is dug deep into the earth,
被赶走的人，他们本可以在自己的家里多住几年，你知道，而且这个工程规模太大了，这条路造价极其昂贵。跨区项目最初摩西说，哦，是的，它将耗资4700万美元。最终却花了大约2.5亿美元，这太惊人了。嗯，但他声称只有5000人从东特雷蒙特被驱逐。并不是整个社区都被赶走了。还有55000名东特雷蒙特居民不需要离开他们的家。他们可以留下来。太好了。当一条巨大的道路深深地挖进地底时，他们的一切都会好起来的，
right under their windows. And they have to deal with the consequences of the stuff that we were reading about earlier with section three. An express rate is going through their neighborhood. So it's the demolition noise, jackhammers, drilling, blasting. The ground is shaking. There, the buildings they're in haven't been, they haven't been evicted from the buildings are not condemned, but the walls are starting to break and fishers are opening up in the floors because the buildings are shaking buildings shift to the point that they are unsafe to live in.
就在他们窗户下面。他们不得不处理我们之前在第三部分读到的那些后果。一条高速公路穿过他们的社区。所以那是拆迁的噪音、手提钻、钻探、爆破。地面在震动。那里，他们所在的建筑物并没有被拆除，也没有被宣布为危房，但墙壁开始破裂，地板上出现了裂缝，因为建筑物在震动，建筑物移位到了不适合居住的地步。
And there's dust everywhere. There's dirt everywhere. The residents start to call it fallout. They talk about if you sit in a chair in your apartment, you will be covered in dust and dirt. Like you wake up in the morning and you're covered in dust and dirt. It sounds so incredibly disgusting.
到处都是灰尘。到处都是泥土。居民们开始称之为“放射性尘埃”。他们谈论说，如果你坐在公寓的椅子上，你身上就会覆盖满灰尘和泥土。就像你早上醒来，身上全是灰尘和泥土。这听起来太令人作呕了。
The idea that if you stop moving, dirt just settles all over you. It's horrifying. It's so gross. But at least you can still go about normal life, right? Even though it's expressways going through your neighborhood, right? You can still do your normal stuff.
那种如果你停止走动，灰尘就会落满你全身的想法。这太可怕了。太恶心了。但至少你还能过正常生活，对吧？即使有高速公路穿过你的社区，对吧？你仍然可以做你正常的事情。
Not at all, you can't do anything. And even after it's done, the way that this, and this is something we talked about with AOC, the way that this divides and sort of makes what used to be a neighborhood not functioned by having this split in it is just devastating, but it's a little bit more slow motion devastating. Just like the basic functioning doesn't work.
一点也不，你什么都做不了。即使在它建成之后，这种方式，这是我们和AOC谈论过的事情，这种分裂的方式，以及让曾经的社区因为有了这个裂口而无法运作的方式，简直是毁灭性的，但这是一种更慢动作的毁灭。就像基本功能无法运作一样。
But they also just like, he talks about how, you know, like you can hear the jackhammers, and that's one thing, and maybe the jackhammers go away, but then the amount of poison that these cars spit out, like you just live with the carbon monoxide, and it makes people sick. It just makes everything worse and worse and worse and just degrades this neighborhood in a million ways
但他们也只是，他谈到，你知道，就像你可以听到手提钻的声音，那是一回事，也许手提钻消失了，但随后这些汽车喷出的毒气量，就像你只能忍受一氧化碳，这让人感到恶心。它只会让一切变得越来越糟，并以无数种方式让这个社区退化，
beyond just destroying the apartments that were in the way of the road. Yeah, it's that the idea that when the construction finishes, the road is still making it a worse place to live. He mentions it, he goes, people get nausea, they get headaches, they get dizziness for days, and then their bodies acclimate to the carbon monoxide, which is I think one of the scariest parts of this book,
不仅仅是摧毁了挡在路上的公寓。是的，这就是那种想法，当施工结束时，这条路仍然让它成为一个更糟糕的居住地。他提到了这一点，他说，人们会感到恶心、头痛、头晕好几天，然后他们的身体适应了一氧化碳，我认为这是这本书中最可怕的部分之一，
maybe to me, the idea that a human body is just like, I guess I'll just deal with all this poisonous gas going into me, and you have no idea what other effects are going on because you're no longer feeling the symptoms of it. That your body is just like, look, where you're living is so unsafe that I'm just not even going to tell you about it anymore. Because I told you plenty through how bad you were feeling and you didn't go anywhere. It's just unbearable. And more and more people move away.
也许对我来说，人体就像是，我想我只能忍受所有这些进入我体内的毒气，而你根本不知道还有什么其他影响，因为你不再感觉到它的症状了。你的身体只是说，看，你住的地方太不安全了，我甚至不再告诉你了。因为我已经通过你感觉有多糟糕告诉过你很多次了，而你并没有去任何地方。这简直无法忍受。越来越多的人搬走了。
They are replaced by poor residents, mostly poor black residents. And this is where some of that language starts coming in where I think to give Carol the benefit of the doubt, he is not trying to villainize the people moving in, but is villainizing the forces that are breaking these neighborhoods down. A lot of those residents he mentions get moved, they move in and they are taken advantage of by their landlords. They get charged much higher rents than the Jewish East Tremont people who are leaving and the buildings are going unmaintained. And it's really the people in positions of power that are allowing these buildings to deteriorate. That's the kind of thing that Kara Singh invites vandalism, theft,
他们被贫穷的居民取代，主要是贫穷的黑人居民。这就是一些那种语言开始出现的地方，我认为给卡罗（Caro）一点信任，他并不是试图将搬进来的人妖魔化，而是在妖魔化那些正在摧毁这些社区的力量。他提到的许多居民搬进来，被房东利用。他们被收取的租金比离开的犹太裔东特雷蒙特人要高得多，而且建筑物也没有得到维护。真正让这些建筑物恶化的是那些掌权的人。这就是卡罗所说的招致破坏、盗窃、
break-ins. And people are just moving away. Businesses are moving away because the insurance rates are going up so high. When you leave a boarded up storefront behind that contributes to this feeling that the neighborhood is falling apart and it creates the opportunity for more kind of trouble in the neighborhood. And by 1962, 1963, there are stories of horrible crimes being committed. One in particular, this assault of a teacher who is leading a class trip in the park and gets kidnapped and assaulted. And Caro cannot ascertain the truth of this story.
入室抢劫的事情。人们只是搬走了。企业因为保险费涨得太高而搬走了。当你留下一个用木板封住的店面时，这会加剧社区正在分崩离析的感觉，并为社区中更多的麻烦创造了机会。到1962年、1963年，有关于发生可怕犯罪的故事。其中一个特别的案例，是对一名在公园里带领班级旅行的老师的袭击，她被绑架并遭到袭击。卡罗无法确定这个故事的真实性。
He can't really see if it actually happened, but the rumor of it is enough to drive more people out. And hey, there's maybe some hope. In 1959, a new group of residents, because Edelstein, the former kind of champion of the neighborhood, she has long since moved away, they have a way to save the neighborhood. Look, what if we made this a Title I
他无法真正看出它是否真的发生过，但关于它的谣言足以驱使更多人离开。嘿，也许还有一些希望。1959年，一群新的居民，因为埃德尔斯坦（Edelstein），这位曾经的社区捍卫者，她早已搬走，他们有一种拯救社区的方法。看，如果我们把它变成一个第一章（Title I）
housing development project? And they bring it to Moses, who oversees the title one housing city and he's like, I like it. I approve of this project. But you know what? Instead of being a small low income project, let's make this a 5,400 unit complex. It's going to go in the space where the best apartment buildings that are still standing are we're going to tear those down and we'll put it in. And these will be middle income rents, which is higher than the residents can pay. And so it's one of the, it's the sad thing of like they agitated for a solution and the solution made things worse for them.
住房开发项目呢？他们把它带给摩西，他负责第一章住房城市项目，他说，我喜欢它。我批准这个项目。但你知道吗？与其做一个小型低收入项目，不如把它建成一个5400个单元的综合体。它将建在仍然矗立的最好的公寓楼所在的地方，我们要拆除那些建筑，然后把它放进去。这些将是中等收入租金，这比居民能支付的要高。所以这是其中之一，这是可悲的事情，就像他们为解决方案而奔走，而解决方案却让事情对他们来说变得更糟。
And the residents, they try to use a different housing program that Moses doesn't have control over and they find land that the city owns. They find a private developer who will do the job and the city is like, great. Turns out that land is technically owned by the tri-borrow authority. And it's just, they feel like there's no way of fighting Moses. It turns out that land is technically owned by the Triborough Authority. Oh no. And it's just, they feel like there's no way of fighting Moses. He controls everything. They're helpless. More people are leaving.
居民们试图使用摩西无法控制的另一种住房计划，他们找到了城市拥有的土地。他们找到了一个会做这项工作的私人开发商，城市方面说，太好了。结果那块土地在技术上是由三区大桥管理局（Triborough Authority）拥有的。而且这只是，他们觉得没有办法对抗摩西。结果那块土地在技术上是由三区大桥管理局拥有的。哦，不。而且这只是，他们觉得没有办法对抗摩西。他控制着一切。他们无能为力。更多的人正在离开。
It's so, it's just every step. It's terrible. Moses is behind every door. It's like the story of the lady and the tiger, except it's called the tiger and the tiger. All the doors have tigers behind them. Like there's no good way to do it. Ugh, it's terrible. Yeah.
这太，这简直每一步。太可怕了。摩西在每一扇门后。这就像那个关于女士和老虎的故事，除了它被称为老虎和老虎。所有的门后面都有老虎。就像没有好的方法来做这件事。呃，太可怕了。是的。
And so this sort of, this neglect by the powers that be, it creates more problems in the community. And it just, it just gets worse and worse, because powerful people in charge have chosen this place to be abandoned. And there is no investment. It's just a mess. But one of the things that's interesting is that it's really a testament to how these larger forces are the things that cause this type of effect in a neighborhood. He makes a point in the previous chapter, he says this is the kind of neighborhood that works and if you left it alone, even with the forces of blight that everyone's worried about, it would keep
所以这种由当权者造成的忽视，在社区中制造了更多的问题。而且它只会，它只会变得越来越糟，因为负责的权势人物选择了这个地方被遗弃。而且没有任何投资。这简直是一团糟。但有趣的一点是，这确实证明了这些更大的力量是如何导致社区产生这种影响的。他在上一章中指出，他说这是一种运作良好的社区，如果你不理它，即使有每个人都担心的衰败力量，它也会继续
working. And when new people move into this neighborhood, they are brought into the neighborhood and assimilated into it and it works. And he just, he says outright, if you leave this neighborhood alone, it will survive and they don't leave it alone. And it gets mangled, you know, and, and by now East Tremont is in a different place than it was 50 years ago, you know, but it took many years of work, I'm assuming from authorities, but also from the people living there. But the people living there, yeah.
运作。当新的人搬进这个社区时，他们被带入社区并融入其中，它运作良好。他只是，他直截了当地说，如果你不理这个社区，它就会生存下来，而他们并没有不理它。它被毁坏了，你知道，而且，到目前为止，东特雷蒙特与50年前相比处于不同的位置，你知道，但我假设这需要当局，以及住在那里的人们多年的努力。但住在那里的人们，是的。
Mostly from the people living there to make it a place worth living in again. Yeah, things are made worse by the powers that be and things are made better by a community sort of like bucking against those trends. This is why, Roman, I'm glad that we're finally getting into the kind of hardcore libertarian sentiment that I feel like has always been an important part of 99PI.
主要是住在那里的人们让它再次成为一个值得居住的地方。是的，当权者让事情变得更糟，而社区通过某种方式抵制这些趋势让事情变得更好。这就是为什么，罗曼，我很高兴我们终于进入了那种硬核自由意志主义的情绪，我觉得这一直是99PI的重要组成部分。
No, I hate to, I believe so much in the power of official work to make the world better for people. But the flip side of that is that power can be abused by a guy like Robert Moses to make like life worse for people. And the balance of democracy has to be the balance between the people on the top and the people who are living on the level of the ground. And it's when that balance gets thrown off in either way, things can go wrong. Yeah. Yeah. But what's important to just remember like in the store, the record, I just want to make sure people know, I don't think there's a hard libertarian
不，我讨厌，我非常相信官方工作让世界变得更美好的力量。但硬币的另一面是，这种权力可以被像罗伯特·摩西这样的人滥用，让人们的生活变得更糟。民主的平衡必须是高层人士与生活在地面上的人们之间的平衡。当这种平衡在任何一方面被打破时，事情就会出错。是的。是的。但重要的是要记住，就像在记录中一样，我只是想确保人们知道，我不认为99 PI中贯穿着一种硬核的自由意志主义
theme running through 99 PI. There is not. And mostly I like government that works, but I like them to work. I like it for it to work for the people. You like a meat ax that is cutting up meat for people to enjoy when they're hungry. You don't like a meat ax that is cutting through homes. That's right. But this place, what roads do, roads like this that are meant to move people through a place
主题。并没有。我大多喜欢有效的政府，但我喜欢它们运作。我喜欢它为人民服务。你喜欢一把为饥饿的人切肉的屠刀。你不喜欢一把切开房屋的屠刀。没错。但这个地方，道路的作用，像这样的道路，旨在将人们通过一个地方
and not in a place, to move people out. So like the, one of the people we will talk to in this episode, Majora Carter, one of the things that she talks about in her writing and in her work is that the ultimate goal of someone who lives in a neighborhood that's been abandoned by the powers that be is that you get to get out of that neighborhood instead of staying in to build it and to make it better in different ways for the people who serve it, whose equity they can build,
而不是在一个地方，是将人们移出。所以，我们在这一集中将要交谈的人之一，马乔拉·卡特（Majora Carter），她在她的写作和工作中谈论的一件事是，一个生活在被当权者遗弃的社区中的人的最终目标是，你有机会离开那个社区，而不是留下来建设它，并以不同的方式为服务它的人们让它变得更好，他们的资产可以建立，
who that can pass on, that can like accrete and begin to like grow the way that a lot of people have had that ability to sort of like to build wealth. And usually, you know, real estate is the way people build wealth in this world and but when you have a place like this that's undervalued and left behind but its inherent value could be so great there's people who come in and are predatory that don't serve the public and take it away.
可以传承，可以像滚雪球一样开始增长，就像很多人有能力建立财富一样。通常，你知道，房地产是人们在这个世界上建立财富的方式，但是当你有一个像这样被低估和遗弃的地方，但其内在价值可能非常巨大时，就会有掠夺性的人进来，他们不服务于公众，而是把它夺走。
And it takes a real mindset change of like being in a place, investing in a place and thinking of it differently than as something to go through or get out of. Or to look down on. Yeah, exactly. And there's such a huge sense in this that Robert Moses looks down on these people. They are ants to him.
这需要一种真正的思维转变，即身处一个地方，投资一个地方，并以不同于将其视为一个要穿过或离开的地方的方式来思考它。或者看不起它。是的，完全正确。而且在这种感觉中，罗伯特·摩西看不起这些人。对他来说，他们是蚂蚁。
And his goals are more important than their goals. His dreams are more important than their dreams. And the only way to do it properly, it does feel like is to say to the people who live in a place, what are your dreams? What are the things that would make your life better? Now I'll use expertise to make that possible as opposed to the expert coming in and saying, roads are great and I like roads. And the best way to do it is to go straight through where you live. And it's true, like the Bronx is not the place it was in the 1970s.
他的目标比他们的目标更重要。他的梦想比他们的梦想更重要。而正确做到这一点的唯一方法，似乎就是对住在一个地方的人说，你们的梦想是什么？什么样的事情会让你们的生活变得更好？现在我将利用专业知识使之成为可能，而不是专家进来后说，道路很棒，我喜欢道路。最好的方法就是直接穿过你们居住的地方。这是真的，就像布朗克斯不再是1970年代的那个地方了。
The Bronx is a great borough. I really love it. When I lived in New York, I wish that I went there more often. I usually did not have a reason. I had to invent reasons to go up there. I was able to go to the zoo, which I love. But my wife and I, we both have kind of family roots there, people who lived there a long time ago, and it's a great borough. But when you go there and when you ride in the Cross Bronx Expressway,
布朗克斯是一个很棒的行政区。我真的很喜欢它。当我住在纽约时，我希望我能更经常去那里。我通常没有理由。我不得不编造理由去那里。我能去动物园，我喜欢那里。但我和我妻子，我们都有在那里的家庭根源，很久以前住在那里的人，这是一个很棒的行政区。但当你去那里，当你乘坐跨布朗克斯高速公路时，
it does feel like you are riding through a scar that the borough has managed to heal past in many ways. But it's still there. It's like a, and it's a, I'd like to say that it's a, it's a C-section scar that's left behind because of the birthing of a new and better world. You know, it's a, it's a, it's a symbol of the work and the, and the sacrifice that went
确实感觉你正骑行穿过一道伤疤，这个行政区在许多方面已经设法愈合了。但它仍然在那里。它就像一个，我想说它是一个剖腹产的伤疤，因为一个新而更好的世界的诞生而留下的。你知道，它是一个，它是一个，它是一个象征，象征着为了创造伟大的事物而付出的努力和牺牲。
into creating something great. But in reality, it seems like, it seems like someone hit the Bronx with a meat ax and it took, and the Bronx has healed, but the scar is still there. And it's just very, it's sad that that scar probably didn't have to be there at all. I mean, I, I can, I will clearly say it didn't have to be there at all. but the scar is still there. And it's just very, it's sad that that scar probably didn't have to be there at all.
但在现实中，它看起来，它看起来就像有人用屠刀砍了布朗克斯，它花了，布朗克斯已经愈合了，但伤疤仍然在那里。而且这只是非常，很遗憾那道伤疤可能根本不需要存在。我的意思是，我，我可以，我会清楚地说它根本不需要存在。但伤疤仍然在那里。而且这只是非常，很遗憾那道伤疤可能根本不需要存在。
I mean, I will clearly say it didn't have to be there at all. I mean, this is- Let's the jury still out Roman. I mean, we gotta wait till the evening to see how good the day has been. Okay, I got it. Let's give it another 100, 200.
我的意思是，我会清楚地说它根本不需要存在。我的意思是，这是——陪审团还没有定论，罗曼。我的意思是，我们得等到晚上才能看到这一天过得有多好。好吧，我明白了。让我们再给它100、200年。
When aliens arrive and the only way to defeat them is to march our troops down the cross Bronx. And that's how we can get into the weak point of their ship. We'll be glad that Moses did it someday. That's that story. I'm sure that was one of his plans. Yeah. These are a couple of really rough, dark chapters where Moses at the height of his power,
当外星人到达，而击败他们的唯一方法是让我们的军队沿着跨布朗克斯行进时。这就是我们如何进入他们飞船弱点的方法。总有一天我们会庆幸摩西这样做了。这就是那个故事。我相信那是他的计划之一。是的。这是几个非常粗糙、黑暗的章节，摩西在他权力的巅峰时期，
he's also kind of the worst he is as a human. That happens a little bit more in the book, but I think by next, I think maybe in the next episode or subsequent episodes, things, the Robert Moses temple begins to crumble. Yes, if you've been waiting for this guy to fall, you're like, he just keeps getting higher and higher in the power structure, and he never receives his comeuppance.
他也是他作为一个人最糟糕的时候。这种情况在书中发生得更多一点，但我认为到下一集，或者随后的剧集中，事情，罗伯特·摩西的庙宇开始崩塌。是的，如果你一直在等待这个家伙倒台，你会觉得，他在权力结构中不断攀升，却从未得到报应。
By the end of the next episode, his up and will begin to come. And then it's all just tumbling down from that. But you're going to start seeing him losing battles. You're going to start seeing people not liking him. You're going to end your, I promise you this listener, I promise you, you will hear an episode, not next episode, but someday, when Robert Moses offers to resign and that resignation gets accepted, I promise you. You will get to hear that someday. So hold out, don't lose hope, hold out some hope.
到下一集结束时，他的报应将开始到来。然后一切都将从那里崩塌。但你将开始看到他输掉战斗。你将开始看到人们不喜欢他。你会结束你的，我向你保证，听众，我向你保证，你会听到一集，不是下一集，但总有一天，当罗伯特·摩西提出辞职，而那份辞职被接受时，我向你保证。总有一天你会听到那个消息。所以坚持住，不要失去希望，保持一些希望。
Don't lose hope, it is coming. There's a light at the end of the tunnel, so stick with us. And now for a conversation with Majora Carter. Majora is another one of those people I knew I wanted to have on the show from the very beginning. The way she thinks about neighborhoods like the South Bronx, where she grew up, is directly antithetical to the way Moses viewed them. He saw them as places to move through as quickly as possible to get out of, and she sees them as places to stay. My name is Majora Carter and I am an urban revitalization strategist and also a real estate developer, and I'm from the South South Bronx in New York
不要失去希望，它正在到来。隧道尽头有光，所以和我们在一起。现在进行与马乔拉·卡特的对话。马乔拉是我从一开始就知道我想请到节目中的人之一。她思考像南布朗克斯这样她长大的社区的方式，与摩西看待它们的方式直接对立。他把它们视为尽快穿过以离开的地方，而她把它们视为留下的地方。我叫马乔拉·卡特，我是一名城市振兴战略家，也是一名房地产开发商，我来自纽约南布朗克斯。
City. Well let's talk about first being from the South South Bronx, New York City. You were born, raised, and you continue to live in the South Bronx. New York City. Well, let's talk about first being from the South Bronx, New York City. You were born, raised, and you continue to live in the South Bronx. Tell me about how Robert Moses has influenced your life. Well, before I even knew of a Robert Moses, he was influencing my life because my neighborhood really did bear the scars of his handiwork.
好吧，让我们先谈谈来自纽约南布朗克斯。你出生、长大，并且继续住在南布朗克斯。告诉我罗伯特·摩西是如何影响你的生活的。好吧，在我甚至知道罗伯特·摩西是谁之前，他就在影响我的生活，因为我的社区确实承受着他手艺的伤疤。
And I lived in an area that had a little piece of a highway in it that was never actually built but was but served to separate my community from itself and from the waterfront that honestly, I didn't know existed because that little highway was was stuck there. You know, There were years of financial disinvestment that came as a result of all sorts of things, but in particular, most notably in my lifetime, much of the fires that happened as a result of the financial disinvestment, landlords were torching their buildings because there was no kind of money coming in because of redlining, you know,
我住在一个区域，里面有一小段高速公路，它从未真正建成，但却起到了将我的社区与自身以及与海滨隔离开来的作用，老实说，我不知道海滨的存在，因为那条小高速公路被卡在那里。你知道，由于各种各样的原因，多年来出现了金融撤资，但特别是在我的一生中，最显著的是，由于金融撤资而发生的大部分火灾，房东们正在烧毁他们的建筑物，因为由于红线政策，没有任何资金进来，你知道，
and the collaboration of the banking industry, you know, within that as well. You know, again, all kind of Robert Moses's work played part and parcel to that. Like, did he cause all that? No, but did it exacerbate it all? Yes, 100%. Yeah, so let's talk about one of those like specific instances where this exacerbate it all, yes, 100%.
以及银行业在其中的合作，你知道，也是如此。你知道，再次，所有罗伯特·摩西的工作都在其中发挥了作用。就像，是他造成了这一切吗？不，但它是否加剧了这一切？是的，100%。是的，所以让我们谈谈其中一个具体的例子，即这种加剧了这一切的情况，是的，100%。
So let's talk about one of those specific instances where this kind of abandoned bridge clearing was this dumping ground that you helped turn into Hunts Point Riverside Park. So tell me about that story and when it happened and just the details of that. Yeah, it was sort of funny. Having growing up in here in the South Bronx
所以让我们谈谈其中一个具体的例子，这种被遗弃的桥梁清理是这个垃圾场，你帮助把它变成了亨茨角河滨公园。所以告诉我那个故事，它是什么时候发生的，以及细节。是的，这有点好笑。在南布朗克斯这里长大，
and feeling the impact of just how disinvested we were, not just economically, but I also feel like it was almost a spiritual disinvestment that many people from our communities experienced because, especially during the era I grew up in where there was a lot of abandoned buildings, you know, where that had been burned out as a result of the fires and also lack of financial investment in them as well. Um, so I grew up with that in my mind and literally worked to measure my success
并感受到我们被撤资的影响，不仅是在经济上，而且我也觉得这几乎是一种精神上的撤资，我们社区的许多人都有过这种经历，因为，特别是在我长大的那个时代，有很多废弃的建筑物，你知道，那些因为火灾而被烧毁的，以及缺乏对它们的金融投资。嗯，所以我带着那种想法长大，并真正努力衡量我的成功，
by how far I got away from my neighborhood with education. Um, you know, got myself into some great schools and was sore never to come back except for my mother's really, really good fried chicken. Um, and, uh, so I did often, but, but living here was not something I really wanted to do, but I had to because I was, um, broke. And when I started graduate school and needed a cheap place to stay, and the cheapest place I knew was mommy and daddy's house, my old bedroom. And that's what I did.
通过我通过教育离我的社区有多远。嗯，你知道，我进入了一些很棒的学校，并发誓再也不回来，除了我母亲做的非常好吃的炸鸡。嗯，而且，呃，所以我确实经常回来，但是，住在这里并不是我真正想做的事情，但我不得不这样做，因为我，嗯，破产了。当我开始读研究生，需要一个便宜的地方住时，我知道最便宜的地方就是妈妈和爸爸的房子，我的旧卧室。这就是我所做的。
And it was then, here I am going to school at NYU, not spending a whole lot of time here and only got connected, reconnected to my community because I discovered that there happened to be, and then a part of the program I was in was this young man who had been working on opening an arts organization here. And that was unbelievable discovery. It was literally two blocks away from my house.
那时，我正在纽约大学上学，没有花太多时间在这里，只是因为我发现碰巧有，而且我参与的项目的一部分是这个年轻人，他一直致力于在这里开设一个艺术组织。这是一个令人难以置信的发现。它离我家只有两个街区。
But through that, as I started doing art stuff, you know, and having like the time of my life and like, oh my gosh, there are actually people in my neighborhood who was super cool. And so that was fun. But then we discovered that there was this huge waste facility that was about to be placed on our waterfront thanks to the city's rather discriminatory land use policies that continued to concentrate
但通过那个，当我开始做艺术相关的事情时，你知道，并且度过了我一生中最美好的时光，就像，天哪，我的社区里竟然有超级酷的人。所以那很有趣。但后来我们发现，由于城市相当歧视性的土地使用政策，一个巨大的废物处理设施即将被安置在我们的海滨，这些政策继续集中
environmentally burdensome facilities in poor communities of color around New York City. And my neighborhood was one of those neighborhoods. And so it was around that time when I understood that there wasn't enough art in the world that was going to help our neighborhoods. And so I really started looking for what we can do to create more of an opportunity for us to feel like our neighborhood had some kind of value. Because it was just like, again, the spiritual disinvestment that I started this with, people felt like there was nothing you can do in our neighborhoods. And that the best you can do was get out of it if you could. And that just felt weirdly wrong in every single way, because it was just an admission.
环境负担沉重的设施在纽约市周围贫穷的有色人种社区。我的社区就是其中之一。所以就在那个时候，我明白世界上没有足够的艺术能帮助我们的社区。所以我真的开始寻找我们能做些什么来创造更多的机会，让我们觉得我们的社区有某种价值。因为就像，再次，我开始时提到的精神撤资，人们觉得在我们的社区里你什么也做不了。而且你能做的最好的事情就是如果可以的话离开它。这在各方面都感觉非常奇怪地错误，因为它只是一种承认。
Because for me, maybe it was, I was happy that I did have some education and some distance because that's when I realized, I was like, oh, it is because we're a poor community of color and that's politically vulnerable that we're being treated this way. So how do we flip that dynamic? And so one of the, so we did, I definitely worked on things like,
因为对我来说，也许是，我很高兴我确实接受了一些教育并保持了一些距离，因为那时我意识到，我当时想，哦，是因为我们是一个贫穷的有色人种社区，而且在政治上很脆弱，所以我们才受到这种对待。那么我们如何扭转这种动态呢？所以其中一个，所以我们确实，我绝对致力于像，
you know, how do you develop a much more sustainable solid waste management plan, which was a, which is an amazing, wonderful undertaking that I'm just grateful that I got to be a part of with a bunch of other really incredible people. But what was really interesting to me was like, how, in addition to fighting against stuff, what are we fighting for? Because again, this is our neighborhood that has been literally defined and created outside of our hopes and dreams and desires. And what is it that we can do to make it something that actually feeds our hopes and dreams and all that good stuff. So we started thinking about that. And one of the things that came up
你知道，你如何制定一个更可持续的固体废物管理计划，这是一个令人惊叹的、美妙的事业，我很感激能与一群其他非常了不起的人一起参与其中。但对我来说真正有趣的是，除了反对某些东西之外，我们还在为什么而战？因为再次，这是我们的社区，它被字面上定义和创造在我们的希望、梦想和欲望之外。我们能做些什么来让它成为真正滋养我们的希望、梦想和所有好东西的东西呢？所以我们开始考虑这个问题。其中一件事出现了，
is how often people would take their kids outside of the neighborhood in order to experience nice things, whether it was a shop or a park. And that's when I kept getting these notices from this woman named Jenny Hoffner, and she was working with the Parks Department at the time through a grant from the US Forest Service. And they were working specifically on threatened urban waterways around the country. And the Bronx River, the only true freshwater river in all of New York City, is one of
是人们多么经常带他们的孩子到社区外面去体验美好的事物，无论是商店还是公园。就在那时，我不断收到这个叫珍妮·霍夫纳（Jenny Hoffner）的女人的通知，她当时通过美国林务局的拨款与公园部门合作。他们专门研究全国各地受到威胁的城市水道。而布朗克斯河，纽约市唯一真正的淡水河，是其中之一，
those threatened very urban rivers and Robert Moses and then we're back to Robert, was like the biggest threat to it because Lord have mercy, literally. So he built all the like the spaghetti network of parkways that literally run through the Bronx and cross it and it's really like hilarious when you look at a map and see it. And so, and then there's the Bronx River Parkway. And I only knew that there was a Bronx, a real Bronx River because I could see it on a subway map,
那些受到威胁的非常城市化的河流，而罗伯特·摩西，现在我们又回到了罗伯特，就像是对它最大的威胁，因为上帝保佑，字面上。所以他建造了所有像意大利面条一样的公园大道网络，它们字面上穿过布朗克斯并横跨它，当你看着地图看到它时，这真的很滑稽。所以，然后还有布朗克斯河公园大道。我只知道有一条布朗克斯，一条真正的布朗克斯河，因为我可以在地铁地图上看到它，
but I had never seen it. Literally had never seen the Dagon thing. And he, you know, rather famously, you know, wanted people to travel on the parkways, everyone and cars, of course. And their goal was to like have something nice to look at as they traveled, you know, along the way. And he just thought that the way rivers kind of meandered, you know, that like, you know, sort of swishy way that they do was just like, that wasn't cute.
但我从来没见过它。字面上从来没见过那个该死的东西。而且他，你知道，相当出名地，你知道，希望人们在公园大道上旅行，每个人都在车里，当然。他们的目标是，你知道，在他们旅行时，你知道，沿途有一些美好的东西可以看。而他只是认为河流那种蜿蜒的方式，你知道，那种他们所做的摇摆方式，就像，那并不可爱。
And, you know, who wants to make those hairpin turns, you know, you know, as they're like on a parkway in their big old car like oh god forbid and uh so he straightened the river in this ridiculous engineering feat that was just the most horrible thing i mean just terrifying for the river yeah yeah and so here was this jenny hoffner lady she was so cool she was very cute like i just adored her she was just look, we've got this little seed grant, you know, for people who want to do work on the Bronx River. And I'm like, well, she is obviously really smart and knows all sorts of things, but clearly she doesn't know
而且，你知道，谁想在他们开着大旧车在公园大道上时做那些发夹弯，你知道，你知道，就像哦，上帝禁止，呃，所以他在这个荒谬的工程壮举中拉直了河流，这简直是最可怕的事情，我的意思是，对河流来说简直太可怕了，是的，是的，所以这里有这位珍妮·霍夫纳女士，她太酷了，她非常可爱，就像我简直崇拜她，她只是看，我们有这个小种子基金，你知道，给那些想在布朗克斯河上做工作的人。而我当时想，好吧，她显然真的很聪明，知道各种各样的事情，但显然她不知道
you can't get to the river from here. Cause you just can't. And to be clear, let's draw a picture. So why can't you get to the river from there? Like what is in the way? Yes. Okay. So there you could, again, there is a river. We knew that it was somewhere out there,
你不能从这里到达河流。因为你就是不能。为了清楚起见，让我们画一幅图。那么为什么你不能从那里到达河流呢？就像什么挡在路上了？是的。好吧。所以你可以，再次，有一条河。我们知道它在外面某个地方，
but all along where we knew the river was, there was a whole other layer of industry. There was either, you know, some light manufacturing, there was the Hunts Point Market, which literally is the second world's largest food distribution center, which literally is the second world's largest food distribution center, which literally covers all of it. And it's about, in my neighborhood, it's only about 690 acres. They take up a third of the acreage in this entire community. So most
但在我们知道河流所在的所有地方，还有另一层工业。要么是，你知道，一些轻工业，要么是亨茨角市场，它字面上是世界第二大食品配送中心，它字面上是世界第二大食品配送中心，它字面上覆盖了所有这些。而且大约，在我的社区，它只有大约690英亩。他们占据了这个整个社区三分之一的面积。所以大部分
of it's on the waterfront. So it's just like, you can't really get there. It's like, it's ridiculous. And so that's all I knew to be on the waterfront. So that doesn't sound very hospitable, but I had a crazy, just a very large crazy dog at the time. Her name was Xena. Yes, for some of us of a certain age, she was named after the warrior princess. It's true. And she was just like utterly rambunctious
它在海滨。所以就像，你真的不能去那里。这就像，这太荒谬了。所以这就是我知道在海滨的所有东西。所以这听起来不太好客，但我当时有一只疯狂的，非常大的疯狂狗。她的名字叫西娜（Xena）。是的，对于我们某些年龄段的人来说，她是以战士公主命名的。这是真的。而且她简直就是完全喧闹，
and I'd go jogging with her. And so one time while I was still in the neighborhood, she pulled me to what I thought was just like a dump that you could see from the street. I saw it pretty much every time I went running. It was like it never occurred to me to go into it because it's a dump. It's just like part of the dumps that are around here. But this time, one day,
我会带她去慢跑。所以有一次，当我还在社区里时，她把我拉向了我以为只是从街上就能看到的垃圾场。我每次去跑步时几乎都能看到它。就像我从来没想过要进去，因为它是一个垃圾场。它就像这里周围的垃圾场的一部分。但这一次，有一天，
she literally pulled me and decided there was something in there that she just had to get. And I just happened to be at the other end of her leash. And she pulled me in, and I was just like, this is gross. I mean, there was like, weeds, piles of garbage everywhere. And I'm trying to run through it, like hurdling over these things.
她字面上拉着我，决定里面有什么东西她一定要得到。而我碰巧在她的皮带另一端。她把我拉了进去，我当时想，这太恶心了。我的意思是，到处都是杂草，成堆的垃圾。我试图跑过它，就像跨越这些东西一样。
It was just crazy passing. There she was having the time of her life. But literally at the end of it, at a clearing, I realized, oh my God, I did just run through a dump. But what I'm facing now at the end of that little run was this beautiful river. It was really early, it was like six o'clock in the morning.
这简直是疯狂的经过。她在那里度过了她一生中最美好的时光。但字面上在它的尽头，在一个空地上，我意识到，天哪，我确实刚刚跑过一个垃圾场。但我现在在那次小跑结束时面对的是这条美丽的河流。时间真的很早，就像早上六点钟。
It really is an image I will never forget because it's just like, that was like beautiful, kind of, it wasn't magic hour, but it felt like it was. And it was like the sunlight was glinting off the water. It was a good high tide. So it just looked really beautiful. And you could see like this, with this crazy park across the river that really was just like a bunch of weeds, but I didn't care. It looked really beautiful from where I was standing. And I was like, Oh my gosh, like this is,
这确实是一个我永远不会忘记的画面，因为它就像，那就像美丽的，某种，它不是魔幻时刻，但感觉就像是。而且就像阳光在水面上闪烁。那是很好的涨潮。所以它看起来真的很美。而且你可以看到像这样，这条河对岸那个疯狂的公园，那真的只是一堆杂草，但我不在乎。从我站的地方看，它看起来真的很美。我当时想，天哪，就像这是，
this is, this is the Bronx river. There is a river here. I who knew? And, um, and that's when I thought, Oh, maybe Jenny like figured that maybe I might figure this out. Yeah. And she was a hundred percent right. Went back, wrote the proposal, you know, to get this tiny little seed grant. And after that, like, I was the craziest driven woman. And I was like, look, we're going to get a park on this waterfront. And yeah, and eventually we did. That little $10,000 seed grant, I mean, was leveraged many, many times over. It became a $3 million park, a good seven years later,
这是，这是布朗克斯河。这里有一条河。谁知道呢？而且，嗯，就在那时我想，哦，也许珍妮就像猜到也许我可能会发现这一点。是的。而且她是百分之百正确的。回去，写了提案，你知道，去获得这个微小的种子基金。在那之后，就像，我是最疯狂、最有干劲的女人。我当时想，看，我们要在这个海滨建一个公园。而且是的，最终我们做到了。那个1万美元的小种子基金，我的意思是，被多次杠杆化。它在七年后变成了一个300万美元的公园，
but it made these beautiful little baby steps along the way. I made friends with everybody that I could. I was older at the time, so I didn't really know who I wasn't supposed to talk to. I made friends with businesses. I made friends with government agencies. I was like, look, I don't care who you are. Can you help us do this?
但它在这一路上迈出了这些美丽的小步。我和我能认识的每个人都交了朋友。我当时年纪大了，所以我真的不知道我不应该和谁说话。我和企业交了朋友。我和政府机构交了朋友。我当时想，看，我不在乎你是谁。你能帮我们做这件事吗？
But it was a beautiful moment, you know, to see how that crazy little dump transformed into the absolute, it's a now a national award winning park. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, it's pretty cool. It's amazing how it's a now a national award winning park. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, it's pretty cool. It's amazing how it's like, like there are certain stories that recur in myth and in cycles and your story of going into this forgotten
但这真是一个美好的时刻，你知道，看到那个疯狂的小垃圾场是如何转变成绝对的，它现在是一个国家级获奖公园。是的，是的，是的。是的，这很酷。令人惊奇的是，它现在是一个国家级获奖公园。是的，是的，是的。是的，这很酷。令人惊奇的是，它就像，就像有些故事在神话和循环中反复出现，你走进这个被遗忘的
area and finding the place where the park should be on the waterfront is so similar to the story of Moses when he was young, when he was still doing good things, going into the lands of Long Island and finding these places that people had either forgotten or not known about. It seems like, is the secret to be on the ground, to really be looking at a place and really knowing it from the ground up to find ways to create things like that for people? Yeah, I mean, you gotta be exploring. Although that was the thing for me, you know,
区域并找到公园应该在海滨的地方的故事，与摩西年轻时，当他还在做善事时，走进长岛的土地并找到人们要么忘记要么不知道的地方的故事非常相似。看起来，秘诀是在地面上，真正地观察一个地方并真正从地面了解它，以找到为人们创造像那样的事物的方法吗？是的，我的意思是，你必须去探索。虽然那对我来说是那件事，你知道，
reading the Power Broker and realizing that Robert Moses was actually started off kind of cool. It was just like... It's the tragedy of it. Wait, what? Wait, I did that. Like, no, I don't want, no. It's amazing because it's like he went out and found the world that was kind of carved up by the Long Island robber barons and reclaimed it. And you found the world that he carved up.
读《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）并意识到罗伯特·摩西实际上开始时还挺酷的。这就像……这是它的悲剧。等等，什么？等等，我做了那个。就像，不，我不想，不。这很惊人，因为就像他出去找到了被长岛强盗大亨瓜分的世界并收回了它。而你找到了他瓜分的世界。
And so someday in the future, I guess the world you've left behind, someone else will find some amazing spot in it. This is true. You know what? And maybe they will, or maybe they'll improve it. Like that's the way I'm gonna try to think of it. They're gonna make it better.
所以总有一天在未来，我猜你留下的世界，别人会找到其中一些令人惊叹的地方。这是真的。你知道吗？也许他们会，或者也许他们会改进它。就像这就是我打算思考它的方式。他们会让它变得更好。
Yeah, you'll make it good and they'll make it even Like that's the way I'm gonna try to think of it. They're gonna make it better. Yeah, yeah, you'll make it good and they'll make it even better. Exactly, yeah, yeah. Exactly. You won't take that heel turn that Moses takes, yeah. Yeah, because that would be painful. But you do have to be on the ground. Like how else are you gonna see what folks need? And the talking to people I find, you know,
是的，你会让它变得很好，而他们会让它变得更——就像这就是我打算思考它的方式。他们会让它变得更好。是的，是的，你会让它变得很好，而他们会让它变得更好。完全正确，是的，是的。完全正确。你不会采取摩西采取的那种急转弯，是的。是的，因为那会很痛苦。但你确实必须在地面上。就像你还能怎么看到人们需要什么？而且我发现与人们交谈，你知道，
is something that often goes, I don't know, maybe undervalued in some ways. Like I think of journalists who can be deeply embedded when they, like, I'm deep embedded or however that phrase is. And I do think that on some level we do have to do that. It's not, you don't always have to do it in order to see what a community needs. But I do think it's super important for there to be opportunities for folks, um,
是一件经常被，我不知道，也许在某些方面被低估的事情。就像我想到那些可以深入嵌入的记者，当他们，就像，我深入嵌入或者无论那个短语是什么。而且我确实认为在某种程度上我们必须这样做。这不是，你不总是必须这样做才能看到社区需要什么。但我确实认为，让人们有机会，嗯，
you know, within those communities to also be the leaders in terms of how their, their neighborhoods are developing. And, and I feel like that is often something that, you know, especially in the kind of neighborhoods that, that I work in where that's not always considered. Like a viable path for folks. But I'm really grateful that I had a chance to, you know, express that, that need I think for creation, you know,
你知道，在那些社区内，也成为他们社区如何发展的领导者，这是超级重要的。而且，我觉得这通常是一件事，你知道，特别是在我工作的那些社区，那并不总是被考虑。就像对人们来说不是一条可行的道路。但我真的很感激我有机会，你知道，表达那种我认为对创造的需求，你知道，
of our own future. And I'm super excited that there are other folks following, you know, behind me who also feel like they can do it too. Yeah. I mean, Robert Moses was completely disinterested in the opinions of people in the neighborhood about what he was doing. But also, but one of his other virtues beyond the sort of the beginning stages of him
我们自己的未来。而且我超级兴奋，有其他人跟随，你知道，在我身后，他们也觉得他们也能做到。是的。我的意思是，罗伯特·摩西完全不关心社区里的人对他正在做的事情的意见。但也，但他除了那种开始阶段的，他
chomping through and exploring places was he had this ability to see beyond what was there into imagine a future, imagine something. And you write about this in your book that this is a key element to being a part of your neighborhood revitalizing the neighborhood of seeing beyond what is there. So could you talk about that a little bit?
大步前进并探索地方之外的另一种美德是，他有这种能力看到超越那里的东西，去想象一个未来，想象一些东西。你在你的书中写到了这一点，即这是成为你社区振兴社区的一部分的关键要素，即看到超越那里的东西。所以你能谈谈那个吗？
Yeah, I mean, I think early on when folks would ask me that question, I would think that it was mostly just because I was a creative. I was an artist and so that's part of being an artist. You literally look at a blank canvas or a piece of sheet music or a floor that you're going to dance on or whatever, and then you imagine like, imagine something different flowering up in there.
是啊，我的意思是，我觉得早些时候当人们问我那个问题时，我以为那主要是因为我是一个创作者。我是一名艺术家，所以那是作为艺术家的一部分。你面对的是一张空白的画布、一张乐谱、或者一块你即将要在上面跳舞的地板，诸如此类，然后你会想象，想象一些不同的东西在其中绽放。
But now, the way that I see that is more about people feeling as though they actually have the right to create. And I realized that that idea and just that feeling is often not in communities like the ones that I feel have been most impacted by Robert Moses' work. Because so many of us have spent in the communities really have been designed by others through the lens of systemic racism and on all of that, that I think it beats the hell out of people and just feeling like it's just enough to survive, you know, in some ways, rather than to try to do much more
但现在，我对此的看法更多是关于人们是否觉得他们真的有权去创造。我意识到，那种想法和那种感觉在社区中往往是不存在的，比如那些我觉得受罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）工作影响最深的社区。因为我们中太多人花时间在那些实际上是被他人通过系统性种族主义等视角所设计的社区里，我认为这让人感到精疲力竭，在某种程度上，人们觉得仅仅维持生存就足够了，而不是去尝试做更多的事情。
of anything else. And so I really do, I consider it, you know, a privilege, you know, that I've been able to do the work that I've done. But I also feel that it's a right that folks can express. But I think there's far too many people who feel as though that that work is actually belongs to be the work of someone else and not necessarily folks within our communities. Yeah, I can totally, I could see that like as agency has robbed of you of when a highway is put in or a river is straightened. There must be just this moment where,
做任何其他事情。所以我确实认为，这是一种特权，我能够做我所做的工作。但我也觉得这是一种人们可以表达的权利。但我认为有太多人觉得，那种工作实际上应该是别人的工作，而不一定是属于我们社区内的人。是的，我完全可以理解，当高速公路被修建或河流被拉直时，那种代理权被剥夺的感觉。一定有那么一个时刻，
I mean, even you who went to school had all these ways that you were empowered or must have thought, well, can I do something at this park? I mean, am I allowed to? You know what I mean? Like, there must have been just a period of time where you just had to get over your old mental roadblocks to get to the point where, yeah. And it was those mental roadblo where you just had to get over your old mental roadblocks to get to the point where, yeah.
我的意思是，即使是你这样受过教育的人，也有各种方式被赋权，或者一定想过，好吧，我能在公园里做点什么吗？我的意思是，我被允许这样做吗？你明白我的意思吗？一定有一段时间，你必须克服你旧有的心理障碍，才能达到那种状态，是的。正是那些心理障碍，你必须克服你旧有的心理障碍，才能达到那种状态，是的。
Yeah. And it was those mental roadblocks that I had to get over, but it only came through the knowledge that like, no, these communities were designed to be this way, which means they could be designed another way. That's right. That's right. That's all. And that was one of the most liberating moments of my entire life, when I felt that I didn't necessarily have to ask permission to try to do something. And I remember first hearing
是的。正是那些我必须克服的心理障碍，但这仅仅来自于一种认知，即：不，这些社区被设计成这样，意味着它们也可以被设计成另一种样子。没错。没错。就是这样。那是我一生中最具解放感的时刻之一，当我感到我不一定非要请求许可才能尝试做某事时。我记得第一次听到
just literally those words from a mentor of mine who also totally did whatever she could to sort of smack Moses around as well. Her name was Yolanda Garcia and she was a second generation Puerto Rican woman from Melrose, which is a neighborhood nearby in the South Bronx, and her family owned this furniture store and had for a generation and she was still running it. And then the city was decided to do urban renewal and they were just, you know, there weren't that many people left. I mean, that neighborhood was just as badly damaged through the fires as ours was.
这些话正是来自我的一位导师，她也竭尽所能地去抨击摩西。她的名字叫尤兰达·加西亚（Yolanda Garcia），她是来自梅尔罗斯（Melrose）的第二代波多黎各女性，那是南布朗克斯附近的一个社区，她的家人拥有一家家具店，已经经营了一代人，她当时还在经营它。然后城市决定进行城市更新，他们只是，你知道，没剩下多少人了。我的意思是，那个社区和我们的一样，在火灾中受到了严重的破坏。
Then her neighbors were just like, no, we're not leaving. We're going to work and we're going to create the plan ourselves. And so she and her neighbors started an organization called We Stay, or Nos Quedamos. It's just that we stay in Spanish. And they spent a decade working on developing
然后她的邻居们只是说，不，我们不会离开。我们要工作，我们要自己制定计划。于是她和她的邻居们成立了一个名为“我们留下”（We Stay），或“Nos Quedamos”的组织。在西班牙语里就是“我们留下”的意思。他们花了一十年时间致力于开发
a plan for that area, and with homeownership, and just some really beautiful, you know, features that really made you go like, okay, yeah, I see what you're doing. But unfortunately, Yolanda didn't survive. She didn't, she literally died at her desk. She was younger than I am now. She was in her early, mid fifties.
那个区域的计划，包括房屋所有权，以及一些非常美丽的、你知道的，让你觉得“好吧，我明白你们在做什么”的特色。但不幸的是，尤兰达没能挺过来。她没有，她真的是死在了办公桌前。她比我现在还年轻。她当时才五十出头。
And, you know, she didn't get to see the construction of her work in part because she wasn't really taking care of herself, which was also I think a part of that lack of agency. She suffered from a lot of the health conditions that many folks in the South Bronx do, which I also think stems from people feeling as though they care that there is more of a self-esteem issue. It's kind of like, this is what happens, you know, real diabetes is something that just like happens to people, you know, in our community. And maybe I can do something, but there's the stress of just living life as a person of color and we feel it all. And yeah, it's still, that still haunts me.
而且，你知道，她没能看到她工作的成果，部分原因是因为她并没有真正照顾好自己，我认为这也是那种缺乏代理权的一部分。她患有许多南布朗克斯人都有的健康问题，我也认为这源于人们觉得他们关心的是一种自尊心问题。这有点像，这就是会发生的事情，你知道，糖尿病就是那种会发生在社区里人们身上的事情。也许我可以做点什么，但作为一个有色人种生活本身就有压力，我们都能感受到。是的，这仍然困扰着我。
But I feel like I get a chance to, but hearing her, you know, remind me that I did and do have an opportunity and a right to create the kind of things in our communities, whether or not there are people telling us that we don't deserve them or need them or anything like that. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, there are a lot of qualities to Robert Moses' mind, which represent cardinal sins and why he shouldn't have been the person
但我感觉我有机会，听到她提醒我，我确实有机会也有权利在我们的社区创造那种东西，无论是否有人告诉我们我们不配拥有它们，或者不需要它们，或者诸如此类。是的。是的。我的意思是，罗伯特·摩西的思想中有很多特质代表了七宗罪，这也是为什么他不应该成为负责所有这些事情的人。
in charge of all of these things. But one of them is his overall mission in these roads was to move people through and out of places. That's what these things were for, you know. And I think that that focus, you know, creates the condition that you talk about a lot in your book and you do a lot in your work, which is this idea that you're kind of incentivized, if you do well, your goal is to leave. Yes. And you have this quote that's on the Smithsonian Museum of African American History that says,
但其中之一是他在这些道路上的总体使命是将人们从这些地方移走。这就是这些东西的用途，你知道。我认为这种关注点，你知道，创造了你在书中谈论很多、在工作中也做很多的条件，即这种想法：如果你做得好，你就会受到激励，你的目标就是离开。是的。你在史密森尼非裔美国人历史博物馆里有一句名言，上面写着：
nobody should have to move out of their neighborhood to live in a better one. I can guarantee you that this is not a central tenant of Moses, this is a central tenant of yours. No, definitely not. So what does that mean? Like when the master planner of New York is all about moving people through these places
没有人应该为了住进更好的社区而被迫搬离自己的社区。我可以向你保证，这不是摩西的核心原则，这是你的核心原则。不，绝对不是。那意味着什么？当纽约的总体规划师一心只想把人们从这些地方移走，
and not about being in these places, I mean, the parks you could talk about, but those parks were distributed unfairly so clearly. But what is it, when you think about development that's responsible, that's responsive and, you know, gives equity back to the people who are actually from there. How do you do that? You know? I mean, you remember what are the things that everybody wants, you know, in a place that
而不是关于留在这些地方时，我的意思是，公园你可以谈论，但那些公园的分配显然是不公平的。但是，当你想到负责任的、有响应性的、并且你知道，将公平还给真正来自那里的人的发展时，那是什么？你怎么做到这一点？你知道吗？我的意思是，你记得每个人都想要的东西是什么，你知道，在一个地方，
makes them feel like they don't have to move out of their neighborhood to live in a better one. I mean, it's really simple. People want great places to live, work and play. They want to feel good about how they move through an area. Is it walkable? Is it the kind of place where you feel like you're happy to spend your money and feel like you're getting quality for it, as opposed to feeling like, you know, you're getting reamed in some awful way. And it's just like not a pleasant experience for you, whether it's where you're living or where you're working or where you're shopping. And I feel like that is, people feel that that's in particular for poor people and poor people of color. And I've seen it all over, you know, the country. I we tend to use a phrase instead of just like poor disadvantage.
让他们觉得不必为了住进更好的社区而搬离自己的社区。我的意思是，这真的很简单。人们想要居住、工作和娱乐的好地方。他们想对自己如何在区域内移动感到良好。它适合步行吗？它是那种让你觉得乐意花钱并感到物有所值的地方吗，而不是觉得，你知道，你以某种糟糕的方式被宰了。这对于你来说不是一种愉快的体验，无论是在你居住、工作还是购物的地方。我觉得人们觉得，特别是对于穷人和贫困的有色人种来说，情况就是这样。我在全国各地都见过。我们倾向于使用一个短语，而不是仅仅说贫穷、弱势。
Those the same those communities are we call them low status because low status really, you know, without including race or economic status, it's just but it's clear that those are the places where inequality is assumed by people both inside and outside the neighborhood. And it shows up statistically. And they could be areas as diverse as inner cities or Native American reservations or even poor white towns where there once was industry, but it's long gone.
那些社区，我们称之为“低地位”社区，因为低地位真的，你知道，在不包括种族或经济地位的情况下，很明显，这些地方是不平等被内部和外部的人所默认的地方。而且它在统计数据上表现出来。它们可以是像内城、美洲原住民保留地，甚至是曾经有工业但早已消失的贫困白人城镇那样多样化的地区。
And now those places remind you statistically of inner cities. And so we know that that happens as well. Low status communities are the places where young people that grow up in them are taught to measure success by how far they get away from those areas. And that is exactly the places where we should be thinking about how do we make it so that the experience of anyone going
现在这些地方在统计上让你想起内城。所以我们也知道这种情况会发生。低地位社区是那些在其中长大的年轻人被教导通过远离这些地区来衡量成功的地方。而这正是我们应该思考如何让任何经过它们的人的体验，
through them, literally, on a daily, just how does it make them feel? And what do we need to do in order to make it seem as though we can create more economic, environmental, and social wellness in those areas by making a really local and living economy on all those fronts. And I believe you can do that because people in low status communities like the same Deg
字面上，每天，它让他们感觉如何？我们需要做什么才能让人们觉得我们可以在这些领域创造更多的经济、环境和社会健康，通过在所有这些方面建立一个非常本地化和充满活力的经济。我相信你可以做到，因为低地位社区的人们和
on things that everybody else does. It's just like we want a cool place to live. We want to feel safe. We want to have the opportunity to make a living and have a clean, beautiful place, decent place to live. And that's pretty much all there is. So why do we feel as though that somehow or another that's only, you can only get that, you're only good enough
其他人一样想要同样的东西。就像我们想要一个很酷的居住地。我们想要感到安全。我们想要有机会谋生，拥有一个干净、美丽、体面的居住地。基本上就是这样。所以为什么我们觉得，不知何故，那只有，你只有在能得到那个的时候，你才足够好。
when you can get that. But obviously, you can't do that in low status neighborhoods. That's just not going to work because there's something fundamentally wrong with them. And I feel as though people really on some level believe it. And that's what we're struggling with. So no, Robert Moses probably, no, I, I, I, he would disagree with me on, on, on the fact that there are some places that are, are good. Yeah, no, he would. No, but it's true. There's a, it's so much of the book that what Robert Carroll writes about is about choices,
但显然，你不能在低地位社区做到这一点。那行不通，因为它们在根本上是有问题的。我觉得人们在某种程度上真的相信这一点。这就是我们正在挣扎的事情。所以不，罗伯特·摩西可能，不，我，我，他会不同意我的观点，关于有些地方是好的。是的，不，他会。不，但这是真的。书中罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）写了很多关于选择的内容，
the choices that people making these decisions make and how none of them are natural. Like you said, things were designed this way. There was a choice that was being made and that Robert Moses was kind of choosing which people deserve nice things and which people do not deserve nice things. And how do you think you go about showing people that even that choice that some people deserve them and some don't, that's a choice about not treating people equally and kind of creating high status or low status neighborhoods. How do you think you go about, it seems like you're saying such a fundamental mindset. How do you go about shifting that in the people it needs to be shifted in?
做这些决定的人所做的选择，以及它们都不是自然的。就像你说的，事情就是这样设计的。有人做出了选择，而罗伯特·摩西是在选择哪些人配得上美好的事物，哪些人不配。你认为你该如何向人们展示，即使是那种“有些人配得上，有些人不配”的选择，那也是关于不平等对待人们，并创造高地位或低地位社区的选择？你认为你该如何去改变它？这似乎是一个非常根本的思维方式。你该如何去改变那些需要被改变的人的这种想法？
Oh, I mean, and this is where I do think being a somewhat creative person helped me, because it was really easy for me to just know, oh, the problem is, is that people don't feel like there are choices, you know, but what if we made choices for people to choose between something? So that's why, you know, actually working to build, to be a project-based developer for me was such an easy kind of push. Because I knew that if all we did was talk about how things could be better, first of all, it just gets boring and it just gives
哦，我的意思是，这就是我认为作为一个有创造力的人对我有帮助的地方，因为对我来说，很容易就知道，哦，问题在于人们觉得没有选择，你知道，但如果我们为人们创造一些选择呢？所以这就是为什么，你知道，实际上致力于建设，成为一名基于项目的开发商对我来说是一个很容易的推动。因为我知道，如果我们所做的只是谈论事情如何变得更好，首先，这会变得很无聊，而且它只会给
people reasons to be like, well, it's not happening here, so let's move somewhere else. That's why it was just like, okay, if we can literally change the landscape for folks to see something different, but it's still in their neighborhood, maybe they could see that, you know what? Maybe things can change here.
人们理由说，好吧，这里没发生，所以让我们搬到别处去。这就是为什么它就像，好吧，如果我们能字面上改变景观，让人们看到不同的东西，但它仍然在他们的社区里，也许他们能看到，你知道吗？也许这里的事情可以改变。
That could be just enough of a push for them to just sort of question, why do things happen the way that they do now? And maybe things could be different. And so for me, so the artist in me was just like, oh yeah, and that was much more exciting than just talking about a change that could eventually happen somewhere
那可能足以推动他们去质疑，为什么事情现在是这样发生的？也许事情可以变得不同。所以对我来说，艺术家的一面就像，哦是的，这比仅仅谈论一个最终可能发生在某处的改变要令人兴奋得多，
as opposed to just working to create it there. And it was super fun because it would also was one of the many things I like about me, but in particular what I like about me in this arena. That was true. But I don't know, I have this really crazy sense that I could celebrate the small victories. I can see the tiniest little thing and know that things have
而不是仅仅努力在那里创造它。这超级有趣，因为它也是我喜欢自己的许多事情之一，但特别是我在这个领域喜欢自己的地方。那是真的。但我不知道，我有一种非常疯狂的感觉，我可以庆祝小的胜利。我可以看到最微小的东西，并知道事情已经
changed and then you make a big deal out of it so that folks go, know that something just happened because people don't always see those little things as the changes that they are, or even as anything because they're just so used to not even seeing anything. Sometimes they don't even pay attention. So you make a celebration out of it so folks will go like, oh, wait, something did just change. That wasn't like this before.
改变了，然后你把它大肆宣扬，这样人们就会知道刚刚发生了什么，因为人们并不总是把那些小事看作是它们所代表的改变，甚至不把它们看作任何东西，因为他们太习惯于什么都看不到了。有时他们甚至不注意。所以你把它变成一种庆祝，这样人们就会觉得，哦，等等，确实有什么东西改变了。以前不是这样的。
Even with that little crazy park, yeah, it was a dump when it started. People remember that, believe me. And so even with that little crazy park, um, yeah, it was a dump when it started. People remember that, believe me. So we had after the many different cleanups that we did, you know, we started doing things like hosting, um, you know, canoe rides out there, literally. It was just really simple just to like remind people like, Oh, no, no, no, we do have this amazing natural asset that can actually be fun. And things like that just like blew people's minds because it was just like, wait a second. But we still had to like show them and
即使是那个疯狂的小公园，是的，它刚开始的时候是个垃圾场。人们记得这一点，相信我。所以即使是那个疯狂的小公园，嗯，它刚开始的时候是个垃圾场。人们记得这一点，相信我。所以我们在进行了多次清理之后，你知道，我们开始做一些事情，比如举办，嗯，你知道，在那里的独木舟之旅，字面上。这真的很简单，只是为了提醒人们，哦，不，不，不，我们确实有这个惊人的自然资产，实际上可以很有趣。诸如此类的事情让人们大吃一惊，因为就像，等一下。但我们仍然必须向他们展示并
celebrate those kinds of things. I'll never forget the first like, you know, big event that we had down there. And we had canoe rides, we had like the senior citizens center who did this beautiful Latin dance come out. We had a DJ. We had the best time. It was almost as if we might as well have just invited people to Mars because people just could not believe this was happening in their own neighborhood. It was just a beautiful, beautiful thing. But then fast forward to five years later, when we actually had the
庆祝这类事情。我永远不会忘记我们在那里举办的第一次大型活动。我们有独木舟之旅，我们有老年中心，他们表演了美丽的拉丁舞。我们有一个DJ。我们玩得很开心。就好像我们邀请人们去火星一样，因为人们简直不敢相信这发生在他们自己的社区里。那真是一件美丽、美丽的事情。但快进到五年后，当我们真正有了
opening for the park, and it was after a $3 million insertion. And the next thing you know, we had this beautiful thing where, you know, gorgeous park won national awards. And people were like, it's, wait, that's in our neighborhood? CB Yeah. BT Like, is it for us? CB Yeah. BT Is it for us? And I feel like that was such a telling moment to me,
公园的开幕式，那是在投入了300万美元之后。接下来你知道的，我们有了这个美丽的东西，你知道，华丽的公园赢得了国家奖项。人们就像，等等，那是在我们的社区吗？CB 是的。BT 它是为我们准备的吗？CB 是的。BT 它是为我们准备的吗？我觉得那对我来说是一个非常有说明意义的时刻，
that here we had all worked so hard to show that something like this was wanted and needed in our neighborhood. And then we get literally like all the bells and whistles. It is just spectacular. And there were folks who were kind of like reticent to even walk in it. Like it was sort of cute when it was sort of like a DIY version of a park, but with wood chips. And we literally had a sprinkler from Home Depot, which was our water feature. It was hysterical, but it was nice. People liked it. But the other piece, again, that was the part,
我们所有人都如此努力地工作，以表明我们的社区需要这样的东西。然后我们真的得到了所有的配套设施。这简直太壮观了。有些人在里面走动时甚至有点犹豫。当它是一个DIY版本的公园时，它有点可爱，但有木屑。我们真的有一个来自家得宝（Home Depot）的喷水器，那是我们的水景。这太搞笑了，但它很好。人们喜欢它。但另一部分，再次，那是那部分，
it was a psychological break that people were just, because I'm like, that just does not compute, because we're used to our neighborhoods being a certain way and expect it like that. Yeah. And that's all these, now there's all these sort of official kind of design cues that these are places that you're not supposed to be in. Not supposed to be. Yes. And I was just like, wait a second, you were just here before we went under construction. Like this was your park. And now because it's nice, it's not. And I was just like, wait a second, you were just here. Yeah, yeah. Before we went under construction,
这是一个心理上的突破，人们只是，因为我心想，这不符合逻辑，因为我们习惯了我们的社区是某种样子，并期待它那样。是的。现在有所有这些官方的设计暗示，这些地方是你本不应该待的地方。不应该待。是的。我当时就像，等一下，你在我们施工前就在这里。这曾经是你的公园。现在因为它变好了，它就不是了。我当时就像，等一下，你在我们施工前就在这里。是的，是的。
like this was your park. And now, because it's nice, it's not. That's fascinating, yeah. Yeah, we gotta work on that. That's tragic and fascinating, but that's something that could be worked on for sure. Yeah, totally, we do every day, literally. And it's a process.
就像这曾经是你的公园。现在，因为它变好了，它就不是了。这太迷人了，是的。是的，我们得解决这个问题。这既悲剧又迷人，但这绝对是可以解决的事情。是的，完全可以，我们每天都在做，字面上。这是一个过程。
And the hope, I guess, is that the longer it's there, the more it becomes taken for granted. No, this is ours and we deserve it. Yeah. And we deserve things like this. Right, and it was just like the same, on that same token, having highways literally run through your community,
希望，我想，是它存在的时间越长，它就越会被视为理所当然。不，这是我们的，我们应得的。是的。我们应得这样的东西。对，就像，在同样的意义上，让高速公路字面上穿过你的社区，
separating you from your waterfront, that was normal too. Yeah, yeah. So Robert Moses is so fascinating because it's the big vision that was kind of like, you got to have a big vision. So I can respect that on some level, except how it was so horribly executed. Yeah, for sure. It feels like what he has in common with what you're doing and what it sounds like is, correct
把你和你的滨水区隔开，那也是正常的。是的，是的。所以罗伯特·摩西太迷人了，因为那是大愿景，就像，你必须有一个大愿景。所以我可以在某种程度上尊重这一点，除了它是如何被如此可怕地执行的。是的，当然。感觉他和你在做的事情有什么共同点，听起来是，纠正
me if I'm wrong, very necessary to any kind of development is imagination. He has to be able to imagine taking the world as it is and changing it, and then it takes a lot of imagination, it sounds like, to look at what he's left behind and saying, no, it doesn't have to be this way either. There's a better way beyond that. It seems like it's such a hard thing for people who live in a world to imagine a different version
我如果我错了，任何形式的发展都非常必要的是想象力。他必须能够想象把世界变成现在的样子并改变它，然后听起来需要很大的想象力，去审视他留下的东西并说，不，它不必是这样。在那之外还有更好的方式。对于生活在世界中的人们来说，想象一个不同版本的世界似乎是一件很难的事情，
of that world, you know? Yeah, yep. I realized that wasn't really a question. I was just kind of restating what you said already, but I just inserted the word imagination into it. But I love the fact that you did, because it does require that. And what happens when your imagination
那个世界，你知道吗？是的，是的。我意识到那不是一个真正的问题。我只是在重述你已经说过的话，但我只是在里面插入了“想象力”这个词。但我喜欢你这样做的事实，因为它确实需要那个。当你的想象力
is stunted in some way. And I think unfortunately, many people, you know, in New York City felt that in a really big way. You know, because the neighborhood, and just kind of all neighborhoods have so much imposed on them from outside forces, development from outside forces, things done to your community that you have no say in or you have limited say in.
在某种程度上受到阻碍时会发生什么。我认为不幸的是，许多人，你知道，在纽约市，以一种非常大的方式感受到了这一点。你知道，因为社区，以及所有的社区，都被外部力量强加了太多东西，来自外部力量的发展，对你的社区所做的事情，你没有发言权，或者你的发言权有限。
As you do these things with your neighborhood in mind to make it better for the people in it, including you who grew up there, you have managed a bit of skepticism from people who are used to the old way of doing things and that making things nicer means it's no longer for them and that means they no longer own it, that it's been taken from them in this sort of like,
当你考虑到你的社区来做这些事情以使它对里面的人更好时，包括你这个在那里长大的人，你已经从那些习惯了旧做事方式的人那里得到了一些怀疑，他们认为事情变好意味着它不再是为他们准备的，这意味着他们不再拥有它，它以这种，
you know, kind of rapaciousness and a sort of con that sort of robs the value of a place. How do you navigate that and sort of get, you know, things better without losing people in the process and making them understand that they're not being left behind, they're being included? I love how you refer to the skepticism, rather most people would call it my haters.
你知道，某种贪婪和某种骗局被从他们手中夺走，这剥夺了一个地方的价值。你如何驾驭这一点，并在不失去人们的过程中让事情变得更好，让他们明白他们没有被抛在后面，他们被包括在内了？我喜欢你提到怀疑的方式，大多数人会称之为我的“黑粉”。
I call them my fan club, the majority part of fan club, because I really do think that they kind of have a little crush on me, actually. It's just like, they can't spend that much time thinking about me, and it just like, puts so much effort into it. But there's also, you know, but yes, there is actual like, real admiration too, but you know.
我称他们为我的“粉丝俱乐部”，粉丝俱乐部的大部分，因为我真的认为他们实际上对我有一点点迷恋。就像，他们不能花那么多时间去想我，却投入了这么多精力。但也有，你知道，但是的，也有真正的钦佩，但你知道。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Can you, can you just, just so people kind of understand the premise here, it's difficult I know for you to represent their point of view, but like what are they hating on exactly? Like to, you know, for people who just don't know any of this situation. Oh, oh man, Lordy, Miss Claudia.
是的，是的，是的。你能，你能只是，为了让人们理解这里的前提，我知道让你代表他们的观点很困难，但他们到底在讨厌什么？就像，你知道，对于那些根本不知道这种情况的人来说。哦，哦天哪，克劳迪娅小姐。
It truly doesn't make that much sense to me because, but from what I understand, many believe that any development is oppositional to the development of the community in a good way. And so when I started calling myself a real estate developer or wanting to work with understanding how the way local economic development could work that could be in service
这对我来说真的没有多大意义，因为，但据我所知，许多人认为任何发展都与社区的良好发展背道而驰。所以当我开始称自己为房地产开发商，或者想要通过理解当地经济发展如何运作来工作，从而能够服务于
of supporting our communities, it was just like, you gotta be kidding. It's either all about building only affordable housing or urban gardening. It just can't be. And anything that's different from what is sort of like the predetermined notions of how we're supposed to be was just considered anathema
支持我们的社区时，就像，你在开玩笑吧。这要么是关于只建造经济适用房，要么是城市园艺。它不能是别的。任何与预先设定的我们应该如何发展的观念不同的东西，都被认为是社区发展精神的
to the spirit of community development. I just felt and still do feel that we have the ability for our communities to generate and retain wealth, which was literally denied to start with black folks, and other ones fell right behind. But we're still at the bottom of the heap, black people. It seemed to me that that was one of the reasons why we needed to be thinking about wealth creation,
禁忌。我只是觉得，并且仍然觉得，我们有能力让我们的社区创造和保留财富，这在最初对黑人来说是字面上被拒绝的，其他人紧随其后。但我们仍然处于底层，黑人。在我看来，这就是我们需要考虑财富创造的原因之一，
wealth retention within our communities, um, and doing it in a way that actually supported us first. So that's why we focus a lot on home ownership, local business development, and really thinking through that, through how we don't have to always be the recipients of someone else's large S because that really hasn't worked out for us. Yeah, yeah. I'm just saying.
在我们社区内保留财富，嗯，并以一种真正首先支持我们的方式来做。这就是为什么我们非常关注房屋所有权、本地商业发展，并真正思考这一点，通过我们如何不必总是成为别人慷慨的接受者，因为这对我们来说真的没用。是的，是的。我只是说说而已。
Totally, and that's the thing that's like, you write about this in this kind of like sense that if you interview all these well-meaning people, they go, well, we want affordable housing options, we want community centers, we want urban gardens, like you mentioned. And then when you talk to people who really live there, they're just like, I just really want a good place
完全正确，这就是那种事情，就像，你写到这一点时，那种感觉，如果你采访所有这些好心人，他们会说，嗯，我们想要经济适用房选择，我们想要社区中心，我们想要城市花园，就像你提到的那样。然后当你和真正住在那里的人交谈时，他们只是说，我只是真的想要一个好地方
to get a cup of coffee. Yeah, good place to get a cup of coffee. Nice place to shop. Places that feel good and safe and fun and fun. And the story that got them to that point of skepticism and criticism and sort of knee jerk reaction is also the world that Robert Moses created. You're like when everything is about someone else's, that's somebody else's resource to exploit,
去喝杯咖啡。是的，喝杯咖啡的好地方。购物的好地方。感觉良好、安全、有趣的地方。让他们达到那种怀疑、批评和膝跳反应程度的故事，也是罗伯特·摩西创造的世界。你就像，当一切都是关于别人的，那是别人的资源可以利用时，
you learn that behavior too, you know? So. Amen. Yeah. Well, we're just about out of time, but I just had a pleasure talking with you and thank you so much for being on the 99% Invisible Breakdown on the Power Broker. We had a great time. I am so excited.
你也学会了那种行为，你知道吗？所以。阿门。是的。好吧，我们的时间快到了，但我很高兴和你交谈，非常感谢你参加关于《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）的《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）解析节目。我们玩得很开心。我太兴奋了。
I can't believe I'm on this. Thank you so much for having me. It's just, it's an honor. It really, really is. Next month, we're going to finish part six. Finally, it's a very long part and start part seven called The Loss of Power. See, we told you there'd be some come up and soon. Don't worry. The arc of history is long, but it bends towards Robert Moses eventually not tearing people's homes down.
我不敢相信我参加了这个节目。非常感谢你们邀请我。这真是一种荣幸。真的，真的是。下个月，我们将完成第六部分。终于，这是一个非常长的部分，并开始第七部分，名为“权力的丧失”。看，我们告诉过你会有报应的。别担心。历史的弧线很长，但它最终会向着罗伯特·摩西不再拆毁人们房屋的方向弯曲。
We'll be covering chapters 39 through 41, that's pages 895 through 983. And if you just cannot wait that long to hear my voice talking about something and interrupting people when they're trying to talk, then please turn to my other podcast, The Flophouse, on the Maximum Fund Network. Remember, you can still buy live stream tickets to our talk with Robert Caro that's coming up on Monday, October 7th. Find them at nyhistory.org slash programs. And be sure to check out our amazing Power Broker merch at 99pi.org slash store.
我们将涵盖第39到41章，也就是第895到983页。如果你实在等不及那么久来听我的声音谈论某事，并在人们试图说话时打断他们，那么请转到我的另一个播客《The Flophouse》，在Maximum Fund网络上。记住，你仍然可以购买我们即将于10月7日星期一与罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）进行的谈话的直播门票。在nyhistory.org/programs上找到它们。并一定要查看我们在99pi.org/store上的精彩《权力掮客》周边商品。
I've been wearing my Power Broker t-shirt all the time on my walks with my dog and I'm still waiting for someone to come up and say hi to me. The 99% invisible breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Real, mixed by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck,
我遛狗时一直穿着我的《权力掮客》T恤，我还在等有人走过来跟我打招呼。关于《权力掮客》的《99%隐形》解析由Isabel Angel制作，Comiti编辑，Swan Real配乐，Dara Hirsch混音。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是Cathy Tu，我们的高级编辑是Delaney Hall，Kurt Kolstad是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Gabriella Gladney、Martin Gonzalez、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Ley、Lashma Dawn、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg、Nina Potuck，
and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where there are fun discussions with 5,000 other beautiful nerds about the power broker,
以及我，Roman Mars。《99%隐形》的标志是由Stefan Lawrence创作的。这个系列的艺术作品是由Aaron Nestor创作的。我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰上城区。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到这个节目，以及我们自己的Discord服务器，那里有5000个其他美丽的极客在进行有趣的讨论，关于《权力掮客》，
about architecture, about movies, about music, about podcasts you should be listening to. That's where I'm hanging out most of these days. You can find a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There is a Mr. Softy ice cream truck outside my window. Can you hear that? It's really loud up here. So I'm shocked.
关于建筑，关于电影，关于音乐，关于你应该听的播客。那是我最近大部分时间待的地方。你可以在99PI.org找到那个Discord服务器的链接以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。我窗外有一辆Mr. Softy冰淇淋车。你能听到吗？这里声音真的很大。所以我很震惊。
We can't hear it. But if it shows up on the recording, that's real Bronx atmosphere That's that that proves it. Okay. There you go Mr. Softie, you know right there is it is a part of the site guys here There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们听不到。但如果它出现在录音里，那就是真正的布朗克斯氛围。那证明了这一点。好吧。给你，Mr. Softie，你知道就在那里，它是现场的一部分。伙计们，这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。